SORRY TO KEEP YOU WAITING BUT
TO HAVE WE HAVE A VERY BUSY
AGENDA TODAY. TO WERE STARTING A
BIT LATE.
VIA PROBABLY HAVING TO TRUNCATE.
OF A PUBLIC COMMENT TAG AND.
ON ON A COUPLE OF THE BIG
ISSUES.
.
SO FOR THOSE OF YOU ARE
PREPARED TO MAKE LONG STATEMENTS
WERE PROBABLY GONNA HAVE TO JUST
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME ASK YOU
TO. STATE TO WHO YOU ARE WHO YOU
REPRESENT INTO WHETHER YOU
SUPPORTER OPPOSE WHAT IS IS
PROPOSED. AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT BECAUSE WE NORMALLY LIKE TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO A BUG AND
EXPRESS THEMSELVES A LITTLE MORE
FULLY.
WE'RE TO BEGIN WITH A ISSUE ONE
THE.
AND WILL TAKE ROLE WHEN WE HAVE
A THIRD MEMBER GET HERE BUT.
FOR NOW WILL LACK OF BEGIN WITH
PRESENTATIONS AND STARTING WITH
ISSUE ONE THE.
SP FIVE.
BCP'S WILL BE GIVEN WITH VIA LA
GO AND ASK THAT YOU PROVIDE US
WITH A.
BRIEF AND GENERAL OVERVIEW OF
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
EXPENDITURES AND YOUR COMMENTS.
ANSWER TRAILER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COME FORWARD.
I STARTED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MISTER FONG.
BRYAN BROWN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
JUST VERY BRIEFLY FROM THE
BACKGROUND I KNOW THIS IS THE.
ISSUE THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH LAST YEAR
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED FE
FIVE.
WHICH BUT APPROVED FOUR POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS. EMPLOYEES THAT
MEASURE ON THE JUNE BALLOT IT
WOULD PROVIDE THAT FUNDING FOR A
VARIETY OF RESOURCE RELATED
PURPOSES. AND AFFECTING YOUR GEN
ON PAGE FIVE YOU CAN SEE A
SUMMARY OF THE BOND. AND YOU'LL
SEE THAT THAT FUNDING GOES FOR A
VARIETY OF PURPOSES ON STATE
LOCAL PARK HABITAT RESTORATION
AND FLOOD PROTECTION PROJECTS
AND OTHER WATER RELATED PROJECT
IN PARTICULAR.
ON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
ONE QUARTER THE TOTAL FUNDING
AUTHORIZED IN S. B. FIVE. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIS
FUNDING IS SPREAD ACROSS
EIGHTEEN APARTMENTS IN ROUGHLY
THIRTY DIFFERENT BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND THOSE ARE
SUMMARIZED ON PAGES TWO THROUGH
FOUR OF YOUR COMMITTEE AGENDA.
I THAT ONE BILLION DOLLARS THAT
ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT IF FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE SO THAT FOR
GRANT PRIMARILY TO NONPROFITS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT DIFFERENT PROJECTS.
AND MORE THAN HALF OF THAT LOCAL
ASSIST IN FINDING IS FOR LOCAL
PARKS PROJECTS.
OTHERS ALSO INCLUDED IN THEIR
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS THAT INCLUDES NINETY
FOUR MILLION FOR FLOOD
PROTECTION PROJECTS. IN TWENTY
FOUR MILLION FOR THE SOLVENCY
RESTORATION WORK.
IN LESS THAN FIVE PERCENT OF THE
FUNDING PROPOSED FOR STATE
OPERATIONS ENOUGH MOSTLY TO
EITHER DEVELOP GUIDELINES FOR
PROGRAMS THAT GRANT GUIDELINES.
OR TO DO OTHER SORT OF GRANT
ADMINISTRATION AND OVERSIGHT
WORK.
SO WITH THAT A SHORT OVERVIEW
OUR OFFICE DID HAVE FOUR
COMMENTS FOR THE COMMITTEE AND
REVIEWING THE THE PLAN.
FIRST OF WHICH IS THAT WE THINK
OVERALL THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PLAN IS VERY REASONABLE AND ITS
APPROACH TO WHAT IT PROPOSES
DEFINED IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
WE NOTE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND TARGETS
THE PROJECT FUNDING AT PROGRAMS
WHERE THEY CAN REASONABLY BE
EXPECTED TO GET FINDING OUT FOR
PROJECT IN THE BUDGET YEAR. IN
MOST CASES THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE
BUILDING ON THE ALREADY EXISTING
PROGRAMS ARE RECENTLY ACTIVE
PROGRAM SO. UPDATING GUIDELINES
SHOULD BE A RELATIVELY
STRAIGHTFORWARD PROCESS AND CAN
REASONABLY BE EXPECTED BE DONE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND AND
GRANTS AWARDED BEFORE THE END OF
THE YEAR. AND FOR NEW PROGRAMS
AT THE MINISTRATION IS TYPICALLY
ONLY REQUESTING FUNDING FOR THE
FATE OPERATIONS SO THAT WOULD BE
THE PERSONNEL THAT'S VERY TO
DEVELOP THOSE GUIDELINES FOR NEW
PROGRAMS. KNOWING THAT AWARD
PROBABLY WOULD HAPPEN UNTIL
SUBSEQUENT YEARS AND WE THINK
THAT'S A REASONABLE APPROACH.
A DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATION IS
HAVE GENERALLY FOCUSED ITS.
FUNDING ON PROGRAMS WHERE
THERE'S NOT EXISTING.
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED BOND
FUNDING AVAILABLE AND SO.
AND AND WE THINK THAT'S A
REASONABLE APPROACH IS OVERALL
WE RECOMMEND APPROVAL OF THE PRO
PROPOSALS.
WITH A COUPLE MINOR.
CHANGES THAT WOULD RECOMMEND
WHICH I MENTIONED JUST A MOMENT
ANEST ASSUMING OF COURSE THAT FD
FIVE DON'T PASSED IN JUNE.
SO THOSE COUPLE OF CHANGES WERE
RECOMMENDING WE THINK THE RATHER
MODEST BUT. THE FIRST OF WHICH
IS TO SCHEDULE HOW THE PROJECT
THAT WOULD BE FINE DID.
WITHIN NINETY FOUR MILLION FOR
FLOOD PROTECTION PROJECT.
IF YOU CERTAINLY KNOW THEIR
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WORTH OF
FLOOD PROTECTION PROJECT
POTENTIALLY.
IN IN NEED ACROSS THE STATE. V.
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL DOESN'T
IDENTIFY WHICH SPECIFIC PROJECTS
WOULD BE FUNDED WITH THIS NINETY
FOUR MILLION BUT WE THINK THERE
COUPLE ADVANTAGES OF SCHEDULING
ABOUT IN THE BUDGET ACT. OWE IT
WE WOULD TYPICALLY DO FROM US
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS THE
FIRST DAY IS OF COURSE TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROJECT HAD A
PRIORITIZE ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITIES. AND SECONDLY WE
THINK IT WOULD THAT ALLOW FOR
SOME ADDITIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT IF IF PROJECTS IDENTIFIED.
IN THE FUTURE A NEED TO CHANGE
EITHER IN SCOPE OR IN COST IF
THE COST INCREASE.
THE IMITATION BE REQUIRED TO
COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
NOTIFY YOU OF THOSE CHANGES THAT
WE THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT CAL
AND ABILITY MEASURE.
THEIR SECOND CHANGE WOULD
RECOMMEND IS THERE'S ABOUT
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT IF FOR
VARIOUS HABITAT RESTORATION
PROJECT. WE KNOW HOWEVER THERE
IS OVER HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS CURRENTLY UNCOMMITTED
FROM PROPOSITION ONE FOR SIMILAR
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES. AND WE
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO US WHAT
THAT FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNED
WITH THE ACTIVITIES PROPOSED.
BUT TO FIND THAT OUT OF
PROPOSITION ONE OUT OF THAT
RATHER THAN S. B. FIVE. IDEA
BEING THERE THAT THE.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD NEED TO
RUN PARALLEL BOND ADMINISTRATION
PROGRAMS FOR THOSE ACTIVITIES.
UP TO OTHER COMMENTS WE HAD THE
FIRST OF THE WE RECOMMEND THAT
YOU HAVE THE ADMINISTRATION
REPORT IT SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
THE FEAR ON THEIR LONGER TERM
SPENDING PLAN. WE KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ONLY PURPOSE
IDENTIFIES A SPENDING PLAN FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. CLEARLY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAD A NUMBER OF
OTHER ACTIVITIES AND PROGRAMS
THAT WERE PRIORITIES TO YOU AND.
HAVE YOU INCLUDED THEM ENOUGH B.
FIVE AND WE WOULD THINK YOU.
WOULD COULD BENEFIT FROM
UNDERSTANDING WHAT HOW LONG THE
MINISTRATION BELIEVE IT WILL
TAKE TO GET THOSE OTHER DOLLARS.
.
SPENT IN THOSE PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS IMPLEMENTED.
AND LASTLY WE THINK YOU SHOULD
USE THE A SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS
TO CONSIDER. ALTERNATIVES SHOULD
S. B. FIVE ULTIMATELY FAIL.
IN WITH VOTERS AND IN JAIL AND
THAT THE ELECTION IS ON JUNE
FIFTH JUST TEN DAYS BEFORE YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE TO PASS
A BUDGET. WHICH DOESN'T LEAVE
YOU MUCH TIME FOR THAT OCCUR.
TO DEVELOP A BACK UP PLAN IN.
WE THINK IN.
THERE ALMOST CERTAINLY ACTIVITY
THEM PROGRAMS
PROPOSED IN THE ADMINISTRATION
PLAN THAT PROBABLY A HIGH ENOUGH
PRIORITY YOU WOULD WANT TO FIND
IN THE BUDGET YEAR EVEN IN THE
ABSENCE OF THE GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS. A ONE EXAMPLE
BEING THE SALTON SEA MANAGEMENT
PLAN WHICH WE HAVE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS TO BEGIN
IMPLEMENTING BUT THERE COULD BE
OTHER PROGRAMMATIC PRIORITY IF
YOU HAVE AS WELL. ANYONE
IDENTIFY THOSE AS WELL AS WHAT
FUNDING SOURCE IF YOU WOULD
IDENTIFY TO USE.
AND THAT COULD INCLUDE
EVERYTHING FROM GENERAL FUND TO.
CAP AND TRADE AUCTION REVENUES
TO ELP HALF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
LICENSE PLATE FIND A MUCH
SMALLER FUNDING SOURCE. EACH OF
THOSE COME WITH SOME A
RESTRICTION ON HOW THEY CAN BE
USED AND OF COURSE COME WITH A
TRADE OFF OF. USING THOSE
FUNDING FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS WOULD LEAVE LEFT
AVAILABLE FOR OTHER PRIORITIES
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
BUT IN IN. IN ANY CASE WE THINK
THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO. HAVE
SOME.
OF THOSE PRIORITIES AND
ALTERNATIVES IDENTIFIED IN
ADVANCE OF JUNE FIFTH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
A JUST THAT UNION IN REGARDS TO
SOME OF THE LA US OBSERVATIONS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION COURSE
CONTINUES TO TRACK THE STATUS.
THE EIGHT AND.
AND YOU KNOW THAT BUDGET.
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AND WILL BE.
YOU KNOW CONSIDERING A CASE BY
CASE PROGRAM BACK FROM PROGRAM
BASIS THE NEED TO YOU KNOW FUND
THESE IF PROPOSITION.
PASS AND THAT'S.
YOU APPROACH THE ADMINISTRATION
TAKING IN TERMS OF.
.
THE PROPOSITION.
SECRETARY LAIRD WELCOME IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN YOU'VE HAD
A. BUSY YEAR AND TO.
THESE ALLOCATION SURF THERE
PROVED ARE GONNA KEEP YOU BUSY
INTO THE NEXT YEAR. EXACTLY AND
THANK YOU AND HOPEFULLY WE WON'T
HAVE THE.
A THE SAME FLOODS OF FIRES AND
MUD SLIDES WE HAD THAT KEPT US
BUSY THIS LAST YEAR.
IT OF HER HOPEFULLY IT'LL COME
DOWN I'M GONNA TAKE A THE
ADMONITION A LITTLE SERIOUSLY
FROM THE CHAIR THAT YOU HAVE A
PACKED AGENDA. THING LA AND
SINCE OR YOUR CONSIDERING TWENTY
SIX
DEPARTMENTS BOARDS COMMISSIONS
CONSERVANCY CENTER PART OF THE.
RESOURCES AGENCY WHAT I THOUGHT
I DO IS JUST GIVE YOU A HIGH
LEVEL. OF WHAT IS IN HERE AND
AND SORT OF HOW IT FITS POLICY
WISE AS YOU THEN MOVE INTO THE
INDIVIDUAL UP.
DEPARTMENTS.
A CLIMATE RESILIENCY AN
ADAPTATION IS STILL EVEN WHERE
THE POINT.
AS AN AGENCY AND THERE ARE MANY
THINGS THAT ARE SORT OF VERY
PRESCIENT AND AND VERY PRESENT.
IN IT RIGHT NOW.
OUR CLIMATE ADAPTATION STRATEGY
THE UPDATE TO SAFEGUARDING WAS
RELEASED. AND IS NOW BEING USED.
OUR OUR SEA LEVEL RISE GUIDANCE
OF WE ARE CONSIDERING THIS VERY
AFTERNOON AT THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL TO APPROVE
AND THEN. I HAVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LOOK AT.
A WE WILL BE RELEASING THAT
CALIFORNIA FORCE CARBON PLAN.
SORT OF.
SCIENTIFIC FOUNDATION AND
POLICY VISION FOR THE RESILIENCY
OF FORESTS.
AND THEN IN BASING ACTIONS ON
SCIENCE THE FOURTH.
OUR ASSESSMENT WILK SHOULD COME
OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE YEAR.
WHICH IS A WHOLE COLLECTION OF
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES THAT THEN.
ARE A LOT OF THE ACTIONS CAN BE
BASED ON.
YOU ALREADY HAVE A LITTLE OF
THE DISCUSSION ON.
.
S. B. FIVE AND PROP AND
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT. THE BIG
THINGS FOR US
OF SOME OF THEM WERE MENTIONED
THERE'S ALSO HEALTHY AND
RESILIENT FOR US.
A AGRICULTURE ENERGY OF A WELL
THAT'S AND.
IN CAP AND TRADE THERE'S A SAFE
NEIGHBORHOOD PARKS
OR CAPITA GRANTS FLOOD CONTROL
THAT WAS MENTIONED. SIGMA HAVE
ADAPTATION OF THE SALTON SEA
RESTORATION AND I SHOULD
MENTION.
THAT. IS THAT WE HAD MONEY TO
FUND THE SALTON SEA RESTORATION
TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WHAT'S
IN THE BOND WILL PICK IT UP AND
CARRY IT TO THE END OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE. WHEN THEY ADOPTED.
THE MANAGEMENT PLAN FOR THE
SOLVENCY IT WILL CARRY IT
THROUGH WHAT IS THE LIFE OF THAT
MANAGEMENT PLAN IN THE
PROJECTIONS FOR REST.
A RESTORATION.
AND THERE'S COSTA PROTECTION AND
HABITAT RESTORATION AND I FEEL
OBLIGATED TO JOIN IN THE CHORUS.
OUR IT HASN'T PASSED YET.
AND IF ANYBODY IS LISTENING AND.
IF THEY HAVE A CONSCIENCE
EITHER WAY THEY NEED TO ACT ON
IT TO DECIDE THAT THESE WERE ONE
FACT BE IN THE BUDGET ON. ON
JUNE FIFTEENTH BECAUSE IT WILL
BE IN FRONT OF THE VOTERS TEN
DAYS BEFORE.
WE DO HAVE CAP AND TRADE ARE
STARTING MENTION HEALTHY
RESILIENT FOREST'S.
A AGRICULTURAL ENERGY EFFICIENCY
ENERGY COR RENEWABLE ENERGY
PROGRAM. AND.
CAO FIRE.
WE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR IN WHAT
TURNED OUT.
THE TO BE PREDICTIVE IN ONE WAY
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO FINALLY
MOVE.
TO RECOGNIZING THE NEW NORMAL IN
BUDGET FUNDING THE FIRE SEASON
HAD EXPANDED ON BOTH BANDS OVER
THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS. WE
ACTUALLY A ADJUSTED HOW THINGS
ARE FUNDED AND THEN IT TURNED
OUT THAT THAT'S EXACTLY. ABOUT
THAT LONG FIRE SEASON HAPPENED
IN THIS YEAR. AND THERE ARE
MONEY IN HERE FOR THE FIRST OF
A.
SERIES OF HELICOPTER
PROCUREMENT.
I HAVE FOR VENTURA FIRE CAMP A
FOR MCCLELLAN RELOAD SO THEIR
THINGS HERE THAT ARE FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THERE IS DIDN'T I KNOW IT'LL BE
DISCUSSED THERE'S.
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND IF YOU LOOK AT.
THE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS THAT
DEPEND ON THE GENERAL FUND ALL
TOOK A HIT. IN THE MELTDOWN OF
TWO THOUSAND NINE.
ACCOUNT FAR WORKED ITS WAY BACK.
WITHOUT US SOME OF THE A PARKS
FUNDING THAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE
LAST.
A YEAR PARKS HAS WORKED ITS WAY
BACK. AND THIS IS THE ONE
REMAINING ONE. THAT HAS NEVER
REALLY COME BACK FROM THE CUTS.
ABOUT A OF THE BUDGET.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE TEN ELEVEN.
AND THIS PROPOSAL IS SUSTAINABLE
ONGOING FUNDING FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND.
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US.
OF THE PARKS.
IMPLEMENTING OF THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THEY'RE DEALING WITH THE
NEW ENTITY THAT WOULD RAISE
MONEY OUTSIDE A A NON PROFIT. OF
THEY HAVE DEALT WITH THE
PROMOTIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT SO THAT
EVERYBODY CAN PROMOTE WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE LEGISLATURE'S
ACT ON PARTNERSHIPS.
NOW THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE ACTUALLY
FUND BY INDIVIDUAL PARK SO WE
COULD TELL YOU HOW MUCH AN
INDIVIDUAL PARK COSTS.
AND NOW THAT THERE ARE IS A
FRAMEWORK FOR PARTNERS.
TO SUPPORT THERE'S A TARGET
THAT SET UP BECAUSE IT'S CLEAR
WHAT THE INDIVIDUAL FUNDING IS
AND A PARTNERSHIP BASIS.
AND SO OR SOME OF THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE HERE AND THEN LASTLY.
AHA. THE WHOLE SAFETY OF DAMS OF
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED A BILL. ARE
A LITTLE EARLIER A IT IN THE
YEAR WE ARE ALSO WORKING HARD
ON.
THE PRIORITIZATION OF
INSPECTIONS AND INSPECTIONS OF
EXISTING DAMS IN CALIFORNIA AND
MADISON.
A INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET AS
WELL I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT.
A YOU HAVE BEFORE.
THANK YOU.
AYE AYES ARE HEAVILY MISTER
FALK.
THERE'S NO QUESTION SO. SO WHILE
WE HAVE A.
HOLD OPEN RECOMMENDATION ON S.
B..
ON THE S. B. FIVE BCP'S ISSUE
ONE DID YOU WANT TO ADD ANY
COMMENTS LOOKS LIKE YOU DON'T.
THE CLINTON.
SORRY COMPETE IT IS BEATING AND
WEEK CITY OR IT WOULD EVEN ARE
TAUGHT ON THAT WE SUPPORT WITHIN
THE BUDGET ON S. B. FIVE.
AND JUST AYE AYE USES WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NOW.
GO THROUGH THE OTHER ISSUES WAS
THERE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD
ON THOSE OTHER ISSUES I THINK
YOU'VE COVERED. UP MOST OF IT.
NO ON.
THANK YOU.
A HOME SO WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
HOLD OPENED A RECOMMENDATION ON
ALL OF OUR ISSUES TODAY AND TO.
WE CERTAINLY WON'T BE DOING
ANYTHING TO.
CHANGE THAT WHILE WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM BUT.
I SUSPECT WHO WON'T BE TAKING
ACTION ON NOT ON ANY OF OUR
ISSUES TODAY.
WHO WERE?
IN HERE NOW FROM UPRIGHT CASH.
TO. DEBORAH HOLDERS THAT WHO'S
THE.
A HEAD OF OUR OCEANS AREA WILL
BECOME AS FOR HIDING IN THE BACK
AYE THINGS ABOUT FORCE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BLUMENFELD SO
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DEBORAH
HOWEVER STAT I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD PROTECTION COUNCIL. AND.
THE BUDGET BECAUSE FOR FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE FEE
PROGRAM. TO BE APPROPRIATED FOR
THE OCEAN PROTECTION TRUST FUND
IN ORDER TO PRINT TO SUPPORT THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL'S
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE THREATS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. ON COASTAL
AND MARINE ECOSYSTEMS AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT RELY ON THE.
THE CURRENT AND ANTICIPATED
SEVERITY OF CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS ON CALIFORNIA'S OCEAN
COAST INCLUDING INCREASES IN
OCEAN TEMPERATURE HYPOXIA OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION AND SEA LEVEL
RISE.
AND IMPACTS TO FISHERIES AND
MARINE BIODIVERSITY ARE
SIGNIFICANT AND WILL ONLY
CONTINUE TO INCREASE
THE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO HELP OPC LEVERAGE
IT WILL HELP A PC LEVERAGE ITS
CURRENT INVESTMENTS. AND BUY NEW
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND WILL STRENGTHEN OUR
EFFECTIVENESS IN PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S MARINE LIFE ARE
HABITATS AND COASTAL COMMUNITIES
HOWEVER GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS ON THE
OCEAN.
AND THE IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
LONG TERM HEALTH AND
SUSTAINABILITY OF COASTAL
COMMUNITIES AND THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IS SIMPLY THE STARTING
POINT. IT WILL ENSURE THAT OPC
HAS THE NECESSARY FUNDING IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN TO CONTINUE OUR
CRITICAL WORK BUT MORE FUNDING
WILL BE NECESSARY. TO BUILD
RESILIENCE AND IMPROVE OCEAN
HOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE A.
ELLIOTT.
NO NO COMMENTS. RIGHT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOTHING.
IT. AND TO ISSUE THREE.
ALOT BOBBY HAVING THE I'M BRING
TASK FROM THAT'S A RESOURCES THE
IN SAY TEN GUARDS AT THE. AGENCY
CHAU WILL BE PASSED ON.
THEN AFTER.
A WEEK CONCLUDED THIS
PRESENTATION WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE.
THAT'S RISK AGENCY BUDGET.
GOOD MORNING THE PROPOSED CNN
ARE A SECURITY OPERATIONS WILL
SERVICE AND SUPPORT ALL OF THE
AGENCIES ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT'S ALL THIRTY SIX OF THEM.
THE SCENE IN OUR ORGANIZATION
I'M SECURITY OPERATION WILL WORK
IN COLLABORATION AND FEDERATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES SECURITY OPERATIONS
CENTER.
THE CNN OUR SECURITY OPERATION
WILL PERFORM SECURITY ROUTE
REMEDIATION AND EXISTING
SECURITY VULNERABILITIES.
PERFORM SECURITY PREVENTION
ACTIONS IMPLEMENT AND MANAGE
DEFINE SECURITY CONTROLS.
PERFORM SECURITY THREAT ANALYSIS
CONTROL MEASURE ACTIONS AND
SERVE AS THE AGENCY SECURITY
INCIDENT RESPONSE TO.
THE SCENE A OUR SECURITY
OPERATIONS IN FEDERATION WITH
THE STATE'S SECURITY OPERATIONS
CENTER WILL GREATLY ENHANCE.
THE OVERALL SECURITY.
OF THE POSTURE OF THAT
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCE
AGENCIES.
TO SECURE. AND ENSURE THE
EXECUTION OF THE SECURITY
OPERATION GOES AS INTENDED
RESOURCE AGENCY IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND STATE INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICE WILL PROVIDE
DIRECTION AND OVERSIGHT.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS LA JOH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION ALL ASK IF THERE'S
ANY UP.
OF MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK TO THAT THAT'S
RESOURCES THEY JUST BUDGET.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
WE ARE.
.
PRICING BREVITY TODAY ONE
CHAIRMAN BLOOM OF.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PROMISE
OF CIVIC FOREST TRUST I JUST
BRIEFLY WANTED TO SPEAK TO THE
S. B. FIVE. ALLOCATIONS AND
HIGHLIGHT THAT PARTICULAR LOOK
AT THE WHILE THE CONSERVATION
BOARD APPROPRIATION WHICH IS
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS SPREAD
ACROSS A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS VERY VERY LIMITED.
WHILE THERE IS A QUITE A LOT
MORE CAPACITY IN THE PROPOSED
BOND THAT WOULD OTHERWISE NOT BE
AVAILABLE UNTIL JULY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN JOIN KNOWN LEAD FROM
THEIR CAPACITY STANDPOINT TO
DIFFER. ACTUAL ACCESS TO THOSE
FUNDS THAT LONG WHEN THOSE COULD
BE REALLY CRITICAL TO LEVERAGING
SOME OF THE OTHER. GTR AFFAN
OTHER RESOURCES THAT ARE OUT
THERE ON THE LANDSCAPE TO GET TO
LANDSCAPE RESILIENCE SOONER THAN
STARTING TWENTY NINETEEN. SO
ENERGY TO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT
HOW THOSE TOM.
ALLOCATIONS ARE DISTRIBUTED
ACROSS THE VARIOUS.
PLACES THEY ARE.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM MY NAME IS
DAN YORK WITH THE WILD LANDS
CONSERVANCY AND I ECHO.
THAT I REQUEST TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT OTHER
SHOVEL READY ALLOCATIONS.
AND WE SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S.
ALLOCATIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF THE OCEAN CONSERVANCY
I WANTED TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSITION SIXTY FUNDING FOR
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL OF
OVER SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION. LIVES
IN COASTAL COMMUNITIES IN THIS
FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE
THAT THAT STATES.
CLIMATE RESILIENCY IN
ADAPTATION BUT I WOULD JUST ECHO
THAT THIS IS JUST A STAR AND
THERE'S I'M DEFINITELY MORE
FUNDING NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE.
BUT YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE ON FOR A
LOT OF ON THE ON BEHALF OF US
SOON. I'M SPECIFIC TO BE A P. C.
ITEM.
RELATED TO LPF.
SOON IS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
I DON'T AGREE STAFF COMMENTS
THAT THE ISSUE ITSELF IS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE. SPECIALLY FOR OUR COASTAL
AND.
OUR OCEANS HOME SAKE.
WE DO WANT TO HAVE A LONG
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING BE ON THIS
ONE TIME ALLOCATION.
SO I'D BE HAPPY TO SET UP A
MEETING WITH WITH A CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION.
JUST BECAUSE WE.
WE WANT TO SEE AS MUCH BEING
DONE IN ON THIS IS POSSIBLE ADAM
LOOK FOR THE COMPETITION THANK
YOU.
WELL I MEAN I KNOW WITHOUT A MY
CALIFORNIA ALSO ONE ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE PREVIOUS.
A PERSON WHO JUST SPOKE.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE ALLOCATION
OF FUNDING FOR THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK FENCE
MAKEUP HALF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY I GENERALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE PROP SIX STATE MONEY HAPPY
TO SEE THAT'S GONNA GO OUT TRY
TO GO OUT THIS YEAR. BUT I'M WE
DO FEEL THAT IT SHOULD BE
ADDITIVE TO THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN GOING TOWARDS
NATURAL RESOURCES PROGRAMS AND
NOT A SUBSTITUTE.
THANK YOU.
HOW I A MINORITIES ON BEHALF OF
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE AND I
JUST WANNA ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER IN SUPPORT
THINKING?
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AARON
EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SP FIVE
PROGRAM FUNDING BE ALLOCATED
THIS YEAR THINK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO.
ISSUE FOR.
AND TO THAT IS THE.
I LA RIVER REVITALIZATION UPDATE
THERE WAS A I A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION OF UP PROP ONE
MONEY IN THE.
.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET RELATIVE
TO THE LA RIVER NIGHT.
LIKE TO GET AN UPDATE ON THE
PROGRESS IN PLANNING FOR. THOSE
REVITALIZATION EFFORTS.
WERE GONNA BE HEARING FROM A
MARK STANLEY.
OF THE SAN GABRIEL LOWER LA
RIVER AND MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
AND MELISSA SMITH SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY WELCOME TO
BOTH OF YOU.
AND ALL OF YOU.
YEAH ALRIGHT.
TEAMS ARE GOOD.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK MONNING
PROVIDING US TODAY I MARK
STANLEY WITH A SIDE GABLE AND
LOWER LOS ANGELES RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
AND WE DO HAVE A TEAM HERE TODAY
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA SPEAK ON
BEHALF. OF THE ENTIRE FIFTY ONE
MILES OF THE LA RIVER ALL OF
START WITH THE LOWER HALF OF THE
RIVER.
WE BE CAN.
WITH THE PROCESS OF ENGAGING
THE COMMUNITY.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS.
THE WORKING GROUP WAS FORMED TO
A. B. FIVE THIRTY.
AB FIVE THIRTY WAS LEGISLATION
TO PRIMARILY ENGAGED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS APART TOGETHER ALL
TWELVE CITIES ALONG THE LOWER
HALF OF EVER. COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION IS REGION
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE AN
INTEREST AND. HOW WE CAN ENHANCE
SELF LOS ANGELES RIVER?
THAT WAS A VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROCESS LOW WERE NOW AT THE END
OF.
THAT PROCESS THE IN THE
DOCUMENT HAS REDUCE HAS BEEN
PRODUCED.
IT INCLUDED LOTS OF COMMUNITY
AND GAUGE RIGHT NOT ONLY WHAT
THE WORKING GROUP MEMBERS THAT
WHAT'S FORTY MEMBERS STRONG. BUT
THE COMMUNITY AS WELL.
THROUGH ALL TYPES OF EVENTS.
MEETING IN INFORMATION SESSIONS
AS WELL AS.
ACTIVITIES THAT WERE FUN EVENTS.
TO BRING OUT OF THE COMMUNITY
AND HELP THEM PROVIDE ASIDE
INFORMATION ON. HOW THEY WANT TO
SEE THEIR LOWER HALF OF THE
RIVER?
AYE ENHANCED SO WAS A VERY MUCH
A COMMUNITARIAN PROCESS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE BEST PRICES.
I'VE EVER BEEN THROUGH WE
ESTABLISH COMMITTEES TO TALK
ABOUT ALL THE VARIOUS ISSUES
FROM ECONOMICS TO CONTINUING
FLOOD PROTECTION ALONG THE
RIVER.
TO.
WHAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S A HABITAT?
ALONG THE LOSSES LIFTS RIVER AS
WELL BECAUSE WITH A MOSTLY CS AS
CONCRETE.
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND.
THERE IS A SERIES OF.
ELEMENTS THAT THE COMMUNITY CAN
BUILD ON.
DOES THE COMMITTEE
STABILIZATION TOOL KIT THAT WAS
DEVELOPED AND.
SIGNATURE PROJECTS SO THEY CAN
GET AN EXAMPLE OF.
HOW? WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH
ENHANCE WITH ALONG THE RIVER.
THAT'S A BRIEF UPDATE ON THE
LOWER HALF OF THE RIVER.
WE HAVE TO MEMBERS ALL TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
UPPER HALF OF THE LA RIVER WITH
BELL HELLO JUST ONLY ONE PERSON
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE LOWER
HALF WAS MULTIPLE PEOPLE IN THE
UPPER HALF OF.
WHERE IS THE BALANCE?
WELL I AM MELISSA SMITH I'M THE
BUDGET THING GRANTS OFFICER FOR
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY SO I'M GOING TO
BRIEFLY DISCUSS THE MATERIALS
THAT WE PROVIDED FOR YOU TODAY.
THERE IS AYE PACKET THAT SHOWS
COME SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
OUR TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF DREAM
PROJECTS ALONG THE RIVER.
FUNDING FOR THAT INCLUDES
FUNDING FROM THE STATE GOING
BACK TO NINETEEN NINETY SIX LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PROPOSITION A AND
OTHER LOCAL CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
DIFFERENT GOVERNMENT ENTITIES.
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND NON PROFITS
AND WE'RE REALLY EXCITED FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THAT
PROPOSITION ONE URBAN CREEK
FUNDING AND POTENTIALLY
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT WILL
GIVE US TO CONTINUE OUR RIVER
REVITALIZATION EFFORTS.
AND SO WE'VE INVITED SOME OF
THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM OUR
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY THE
MOUNTAINS RECREATION
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY TO GIVE
YOU SOME. SPECIFICS ON SOME KEY
PROJECTS AND THAT'S WHAT THESE
LOVELY PEOPLE LIKE AIRFORCE ALL
PASS IT OVER TO BATON REYES
THANK YOU.
IT'S MORNING.
MY NAME IS ON ASTRONOMY I'M THE
CHIEF OF PARK DEVELOPMENT FOR
THE MRCA. OVER THE PAST TWENTY
FOUR YEARS THE MRCA HAS.
IMPLEMENTED OVER TWO DOZEN
PROJECTS.
AND THIS IS WORKING AND
PARTNERSHIP IN COORDINATING WITH
VARIOUS CONSERVANCY'S CITIES US
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE COUNTY AND
OTHER ENTITIES THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES TO.
AND IT'S SPECIALLY ALONG THE
THE WATERWAYS
UP TO EMPLOYMENT MULTIPLE
BENEFIT PARK PROJECTS
AND TO REVITALIZE LOS ANGELES
RIVER. UP YOU HAVE A FULL PACKET
OF PROJECTS BUT JUST HIGHLIGHT A
FEW OF THEM.
RECENTLY WE HAVE COMPLETED
PHASE TWO OF A FOUR ACRE LUIS
MCADAMS RIVERFRONT PARK WHICH IS
LOCATED IN AN EXTREMELY.
PARK POOR COMMUNITY AND SO THE
PARK NOT ONLY PROVIDES MUCH
NEEDED RECREATION OR AT THE
LOCAL RESIDENTS BUT IT ALSO
PROVIDES HABITAT FOR THE LOCAL
WILDLIFE. AND DAYLIGHTS A STORM
DRAIN.
TO TREAT AND INFILTRATES.
STORM WATER BEFORE IT ENTERS
THE RIVER UP THIS IS JUST A
QUICK PHOTO OF WHAT THE PARK
LOOKS LIKE WHEN IT'S DRY.
AND I REALLY.
WONDERFUL PHOTO I THINK OF.
EXHIBITING HOW IT CAPTURES AND
INFILTRATES THE STORMWATER OUT
WE LOOK FOR A TODAY.
YES POTENTIALLY TODAY I BECAUSE
IT WAS RAINING.
WERE ALSO CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH CITY AND VARIOUS OTHER
STATE ENTITIES ON THE FORTY TWO
ACRE GTO PROJECTS.
WHICH WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE
ARMY CORPS IS LA RIVER ECOSYSTEM
RESTORATION PLAN.
AND IS A MAJOR OPEN SPACE.
INVESTMENT AND GIVEN ITS
SIGNIFICANT SIZE.
G. TWO IS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
THAT WILL PROVIDE HABITAT.
RESTORATION IMPROVE WATER
QUALITY WITHIN THE LOS ANGELES
RIVER PROVIDE RECREATION AND
BRING MANY OTHER BENEFITS TO LOS
ANGELES AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF THE
OTHER PROJECTS.
YOU MIGHT HAVE IN THE PACKET.
THANK YOU.
AND THE MORNING AFTER I DON'T
MISS THE CHIEF RANGER WITH THE
MOUNTAINS RECREATION
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY. ONE OF
THE ITEMS THAT I'M ACTUALLY A
BOUTIQUE SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT IT'S
THE RECREATION ZONES THAT WE
MANAGE TO NAY LOS ANGELES RIVER
WITH BOTH IN THE SUPPORT OF A
SAN. AND ILLUSION VALLEY BOTH
AGAIN IN THE STATE OF LOS
ANGELES IN CONJUNCTION WITH US
IN LOS ANGELES IN THE ARMY CORPS
ENGINEERS WOULD NOW SERVED OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO'VE
ACTUALLY KAYAK. ON THIS AT THE
PUMP FROM THE IT SESSION OF THIS
FROM THE BEGINNING THIS PROGRAM
IN TWENTY ELEVEN. THIS IS ONLY A
FOUR MONTH PERIOD PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE DO CLOSE IT DOWN FOR
THE WINTER TIME WHEN. THE BRAIN
IS ACTUALLY BECOMES A TO POINT
B. ACTUALLY BECOMES A HACER SO
WE DO. MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS A.
ONE OF OUR KEY THINGS OF.
KEEPING UP WITH THE SAFETY OF
WHEN YOU'RE RECRUITING ALL THE
PAPER SO AGAIN I'VE BEEN OUR
MAYOR IN SUPPORT OF US AND YOU
GET ON THE FINGERS OF AIR TRAVEL
TO THE. THOMAS BRADLEY
INTERNATIONAL TERMINAL YOU'LL
SEE THAT HE ACTUALLY INVITES YOU
KNOW AND IS ONE OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS WHEN PEOPLE ARE COMING
TO VISIT LOS ANGELES. THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT THERE IS A RECREATION
IN A YOU CAN ACTUALLY RECORD LOS
ANGELES RIVER SO THAT'S WHAT
I'VE GOT RETAIL CONFIDENCE TO
ANY QUESTIONS PLEASE SERVE MY TO
GIVE A BUSINESS CARD. CONTACT ME
OR. ASK YOU KNOW TAKE YOU IT IS
AND MARK BOTH THE P. DOWN IN
THE.
IN THE WATER AND PADDLING
BECAUSE.
THREW UP A PLACE THAT THE ONLY
A FEW YEARS AGO. ON WE WOULD
THOUGHT OF AS A WASTELAND WE CAN
WORK ON THAT FOR YOU
IT'S THE.
ALTOGETHER NOW OKAY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SARAH
RESTS GONA I'M WITH THE MRCA AND
I AND THE URBAN RIVER PROGRAM
OFFICER. I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
PASSED LAST YEAR THAT'S AB FOUR
SIX SIX
AND THIS LEGISLATION ESTABLISHED
ON UPPER ALLEY RIVER AND
TRIBUTARIES WORKING GROUP. THIS
IS A COHESIVE COLLABORATIVE
WATERSHED PLANNING EFFORT AYE
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE UPPER PART
OF THE LA RIVER AND ITS
TRIBUTARIES. AND WILL BE
FACILITATING A WORKING GROUP
WHICH WILL CRAFT ONE
CONSOLIDATED PLAN FOR THE REGION
BECAUSE THERE HAVE BEEN VARIOUS
PLANS DEVELOPED SO WILL BE.
CREATING A ONE PLAN THAT WILL
IDENTIFY THE CONSISTENCIES
INCONSISTENCIES AND GAPS AND
AGAIN CREATE ONE PLAN. AND AT
THIS IS MEANT TO COMPLEMENT THE
EFFORTS OF THE LOWER RIVER
WORKING GROUPS OF AB FIVE THIRTY
THEY DID A FANTASTIC JOB. HAD A
LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED AND
WE PLAN TO DO THAT WITH A BEFORE
SIX SIX AND THE UPPER RIVER AND
TRIBUTARIES WORKING GROUP.
SO WE'LL BE BRINGING TOGETHER
REGIONAL STAKEHOLDERS WHO WELL
CREATE THIS CONSOLIDATED PLAN
AND IDENTIFY PROJECTS FOR THE
REGION.
GREAT
OBSERVERS LATEST EFFORT WILL SO
MARK AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
BICU GIVE HER PROBLEM. THAT'S
TALK ABOUT THE VARIOUS PROJECTS
ARE TAKING PLACE ALONG THE
RIVER.
WE HAVE A VERY STRONG PARTNER IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES DAY
MOVING FORWARD WITH A MASTER
PLAN THAT WILL CONSOLIDATE ALL
THESE ACTIVITIES FOR THE ENTIRE
FIFTY ONE MILES OF THE RIVER.
THAT TO CONSERVANCY IS BOTH
SANTA MONICA.
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY AND
RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
IS WORKING ON AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
EIGHTWHICH AS HER RANGERS
LEGISLATION.
TO CONDUCT A STUDY OF A PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PROGRAMMING ALONG OFF
OF FIFTY ONE MILES OF THE RIVER
WE WILL BE COMING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND PROVIDING A
REPORT AND UPDATE ON HOW THAT
ACTIVITY HAS TAKEN PLACE.
AND.
PROPOSITION ONE IS HELPING WITH
THE EMPLOYMENT TATIAN A
PROJECTS.
ALONG THE RIVER BOTH.
CONSERVANCY'S WAS ALLOCATED
FUNDING. OF FOR THOSE OF
PROGRAMS AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF PROJECTS. AND WE TOO ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO S. B. FIVE
MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
HAS ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
HEARD ON THIS. PARTICULAR ITEM.
STAYING NO ONE.
WILL MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT
EFFICIENT WILDLIFE.
WE'VE GOT.
TWO ISSUES.
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING.
AND THE STATE WATER PROJECTS
LOCAL DIRECTOR CALORIE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS STAFF.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO BEGIN OR.
LA AREA TO BEGIN WITH
OKAY.
SO MY NAME IS CHUCKBOTTOM I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL.
RESPOND TO ABOUT A SEVENTY YEAR
OLD PROBLEM.
THE DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL
SEEKS IN ONGOING PERMANENT FIFTY
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
NEW FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
AND NINETY EIGHT POSITIONS.
THERE A PURPOSE TO THIS
PROPOSAL.
IT'S TO FIX THAT SEVENTY YEAR
OLD PROBLEM.
SINCE ABOUT THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES.
THERE'S GENERAL CONSENSUS.
OUR DEPARTMENT'S MAIN CHALLENGE
IS TO STAND ABOVE FUNDING.
IN FACT I HAVE A NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT REPORT TO MY OFFICE.
FROM BOOZ ALLEN HAMILTON A
NATIONAL CONSULTING FIRM.
COMMISSION BY THE LEGISLATURE'S
JOINT.
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
IDENTIFYING THAT IS OUR MAIN
CHALLENGE.
THE TWO THOUSAND SIX.
OUR STATE LEGISLATURE AMENDED
OUR FISH AND GAME CODE.
SECTION SEVEN TEN.
TO ADD THIS LANGUAGE.
QUOTE THE LEGISLATURE FINDS AND
DECLARES THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES TO BE AN ADEQUATELY
FUNDED.
THE DEPARTMENT MUST SECURE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
RELIABLE FUNDING.
THERE'S ALSO A NEED.
FOR THIS PROPOSAL.
YOUR OWN STAFF ANNOUNCES TODAY
ON PAGE TWENTY ONE SAYS QUOTE.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR DFW IS
LONG OVERDUE.
THERE'S BEEN A WHOLE HECK OF A
LOT OF PROCESS.
SINCE I'VE BEEN DIRECTOR.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN CONVENE A BLUE
RIBBON PANEL PROCESS AND
STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN VISION
EFFORT.
THINK ABOUT REFORM FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT.
IT PRODUCED A REPORT IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN WITH TWENTY EIGHT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR AT LEAST THE LAST TWO BUDGET
CYCLES I PERSONALLY IN THE
DEPARTMENT INSTITUTIONALLY HAVE
BEEN PRETTY TRANSPARENT.
ABOUT A PROJECTED IMBALANCE IN
OUR MAIN FUND.
THE FISHING GAME PRESERVATION
FUND.
OVER THIS TIMEFRAME WE'VE.
SAW AND SECURED AT LEAST A
SUBSTANTIAL FEE INCREASES
IN CERTAIN SECTORS INCLUDING
LAST YEAR WHICH WAS PARTICULARLY
PAINFUL.
AS MANY WILL REMEMBER ABOUT A
COMMERCIAL FISHING FEE INCREASE.
ALL TO ILLUSTRATE THIS PROBLEM.
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
GAVE US THREE NEW INSTRUCTIONS.
FIRST WE WERE TO GET THE BAND
BACK TOGETHER.
SO WE RECONVENE THE STAKEHOLDER
VISION PROCESS GROUP.
THE SECOND MOST RECENT STRUCTURE
WAS TO GIVE YOU A PROGRESS
REPORT.
BENCHMARKED AGAINST THE TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN TWENTY EIGHT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE SUBMITTED THAT IN OCTOBER OF
LAST YEAR.
AND THE THIRD INSTRUCTION WAS TO
BASICALLY HIGHER THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND ENGAGE IN A
MISSION BASED BUDGETING PROCESS.
I SUPPORT THAT PROCESS
COMPLETELY.
IT ACTUALLY SHAPED THE PROPOSAL
FOR FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN A WHOLE HECK
OF A LOT OF STAKEHOLDER SUPPORT.
IT'S
RARE.
THAT THE DEPARTMENTS FAR LEFT
CONSTITUENCY AND FAR RIGHT
CONSTITUENCY. WILL ALIGN.
THE ORIGINAL STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
WAS NONPARTISAN.
THE MOST RECENT CONVERSATION WAS
BIPARTISAN.
AND I THINK YOU SEE A DIVERSITY
OF GROUPS IS SUPPORT THIS FIFTY
POINT SIX MILLION.
HERE'S WHAT WE DO WITH IT.
WE TAKE NINETEEN POINT SIX
MILLION.
AND WE'D FIX THE IMBALANCE
BEFORE IT REALLY COMES DO.
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO AVOID
CUTTING CRITICAL WORK.
AND WE TAKE ABOUT THIRTY ONE
MILLION. AND WE ENHANCE OUR
CONSERVATION EFFORTS.
ATTACHED OF THIS PROPOSAL IS AN
EXPENDITURE CONCEPT TO INVEST IN
NATURAL HERITAGE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
IT WAS DESIGNED BY THOSE
STAKEHOLDERS.
IT'S GOT FOUR ASPECTS.
THIS FIFTY MILLION WILL HELP US
ENHANCE CONSERVATION.
IT'S GOING TO BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
IT WILL BENEFIT HUNTERS AND
ANGLERS IF YOU'RE CALIFORNIAN
YOU LIKE THOSE RECREATIONAL
PURSUITS.
WE WILL INVEST IN PROGRAMS TO
RECRUIT RETAIN REACTIVATE
HUNTERS AND ANGLERS.
WILL INVEST IN OUR HATCHERY
PROGRAMS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY THIS WILL
REDUCE THE RISK
THAT I'M FORCED TO RAISE THE
FEES AGAIN ON HUNTERS AND
ANGLERS IN THE STATE.
FOURTH BENEFIT YOUR CALIFORNIAN.
THIS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WILL
HELP US GET MORE CALIFORNIANS
OUTDOORS INCLUDING.
INTRODUCING OURSELVES TO STE
CUSTOMERS WE TYPICALLY HAVE A
THOUGHT ABOUT.
AS AN EXAMPLE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN OUR URBAN CORES.
AND LASTLY THIS PROGRAM AND
PROPOSAL WILL HELP US PROVIDE
STABILITY IN SERVICES.
AS AN EXAMPLE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS.
WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO PLANTS AND ANIMALS THAT ARE
PROTECTED UNDER STATE LAW IN THE
STATE.
MOST OF THOSE ARE FOUND ON
PRIVATE LANDS.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW
US TO BUILD SPECIFIC PROGRAMS.
PRIVATE LANDS COLLABORATION.
AND REGULATORY PROTECTION FOR
THOSE LANDOWNERS IN WATER USERS
WHO WANT TO DO GOOD CONSERVATION
BUT NOT REMAIN EXPOSED UNDER
STATE ENDANGERED SPECIES LAW.
SO.
I THINK IN A MOMENT AND LATER
YOU MIGHT HEAR ABOUT A NEXUS
PROBLEM.
NEXUS MEANS A CONNECTION.
BETWEEN SOURCE AND EXPENDITURE.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE UC
DAVIS WROTE ECOLOGY CENTER IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ESTIMATES.
THAT THE TOTAL ANNUAL COST OF
WILDLIFE VEHICLE CONFLICT IN THE
STATE.
IS AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND THAT AS A CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATE THERE ABOUT SEVEN
THOUSAND WILDLIFE VEHICLE
CONFLICTS.
PER YEAR ACROSS THE STATE.
IN ADDITION OUR GAME WARDENS AND
OUR DEPARTMENT ARE SWORN PEACE
OFFICERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN A
LOAN.
THAT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONTACTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WITH CITIZENS
OFTEN THOSE CITIZENS ARE IN
CARS.
AND ON ROADS.
AND JUSTIN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. THEY ISSUE TWELVE
THOUSAND VEHICLE CALLED
CITATIONS.
WHY IS THIS INFORMATION
RELEVANT?
TWO MAIN FUNCTIONS OF THIS
PROPOSAL OUR TO EMPLOY THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT.
AND A TIRE RECYCLING FUND.
TO GENERATE THE FIFTY POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
IT'S A PROBLEM THAT'S BEEN
AROUND LONGER THAN I'VE BEEN
ALIVE.
EVERYONE AGREES IT'S A PROBLEM
STABLE FUNDING.
AND I WOULD SUBMIT HOW WE CHOOSE
TO MAKE BUDGET PRIORITIES.
IS AN EXPRESSION OF OUR VALUES.
THEY'RE MORE ANIMALS AND PLANTS
IN THIS STATE THAN ANY STATE IN
THE UNION.
THAT IS ONE OF TWENTY FIVE.
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY HOT SPOTS
ON THE ENTIRE PLANET.
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL MYLES
MISSION IS TO STEWARD THAT
RESOURCE.
AND EVERYONE AGREES WE LACKS
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING TO DO THAT
JOB.
I'LL STOP THERE.
THANK YOU.
OTHER ALEJO. TINKLING GOOD
MORNING RACHEL EHLERS WITH
ALEJO.
.
ALTHOUGH WITH THIS PROPOSAL IT'S
TEMPTING TO START DIVING
STRAIGHT INTO THE FUNDING
SOURCES THAT ARE PROPOSED AND
WHETHER WE THINK THAT THOSE ARE
REASONABLE OR NOT WE WOULD
ACTUALLY RECOMMEND. THAT YOU
BEGIN WITH WHAT YOU WANT THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO WHAT TASKS DO
YOU WANTED TO DO THEN. TURN TO
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO FUND IT SO
BEGINNING THERE WE WOULD
DEFINITELY RECOMMEND ADDRESSING
THE ON GOING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR GAP THAT THE DIRECTOR.
MENTIONED THAT STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE IN ORDER TO SUPPORT.
THE EXISTING ACTIVITIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS UNDERTAKING AND
NOT HAVE THIS PROBLEM KEEP
COMING BEFORE YOU AS IT HAS FOR
FOR RECENT YEARS.
THERE IS ALSO A STRONG CASE FOR
SOME LEVEL OF AUGMENTATION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT WE AGREE WITH
THAT PARTICULARLY GIVEN.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
CHALLENGES OF A GROWING
POPULATION IN THE STATE.
THAT PACKAGE OF ACTIVITIES THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PUT BEFORE
YOU WE THINK IS A REASONABLE
STARTING PLACE IN PARTICULAR
THOSE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON. PROTECTING US AND
ASSISTING THE STATE'S ENDANGERED
SPECIES BUT YOU MAY HAVE OTHER
PRIORITIES FOR A PACKAGE THAT
YOU'RE PUTTING TOGETHER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
SO ONCE YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT IT
IS YOU WANT THE DEPARTMENT TO DO
AND HOW MUCH TIME AND THAT WILL
COSTA THEN IT WOULD BE TIME TO
TURN TO WHAT FUNDING SOURCES SO
AS WAS MENTIONED THERE THREE
SOURCES PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. EIGHTEEN MILLION
FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT
TWENTY SIX MILLION FROM A TIRE
RECYCLING MANAGEMENT FUND AND
THEN SEVEN MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
SO STARTING WITH THE NBA THE
MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT WE THINK
THIS IS REASONABLE AND CONCEPT
TO USE THIS FUNDING SOURCE THE
CONSTITUTION DOES SAY THAT IT
CAN BE USED FOR MITIGATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS.
OF OF MOTOR VEHICLES I THINK
OUR CONCERN HERE IS THAT WE
HAVEN'T YET SEEN.
AND ACCOUNTING OUR
DEPARTMENT FOR HOW MUCH WOULD BE
REASONABLE HOW MUCH OF THEIR
WORKLOAD IS ACTUALLY A RESULT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES WE THINK THAT'S
pIMPORTANT BOTH FROM A LEGAL
BASIS AND A POLICY BASIS FOR
USING THAT FUNDING SOURCE. SO
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR THAT BUT
WE THINK THAT THAT THAT FUNDING
SOURCE COULD BE REASONABLE AND.
THE MODEST AMOUNT THAT IS
PROPOSED THAT FUND COULD
SUSTAIN.
WHEN. A WHEN YOU SAY YOU'RE
STILL WAITING FOR THAT THAT IN
FIRST THAT YOU EXPECT TO RECEIVE
IT AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT HAVE
INDICATED THEY'RE WORKING ON IT
YES.
AND THAT WINNER THEN THE NEED
FOR KIND OF A TIMELINE. ARE WE
LOOKING AT.
MORE THAN DAYS LESS THAN YOU
KNOW WEAKER SO WHERE WORKING ON.
THAT WORK LOAD JUSTIFICATION
GREAT THE CLOSE ENOUGH THANK
YOU.
AND FOR THE TIRE FUND HOWEVER WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY JUSTIFICATION
EVEN WITH THE INITIAL
INFORMATION DEPARTMENTS PROVIDED
THAT HAS THAT NEXUS THIS IS
THAT.
THERE WAS APPROVED AS A TWO
THIRDS VOTE IT IT IS A FEE IT'S
CALLED A FEE IN THE LEGISLATION.
AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN.
VETERANS OF JUSTIFICATION THAT
WOULD LINK THEY USE I HAVE A FEE
ON TIRES FOR WORKLOAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. AGAIN NAME THEY MAY
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION BUT BASED ON WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN INITIALLY WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT NEXUS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS FUND IS
SCHEDULED THIS PORTION OF THE
FUN THAT THAT IS PROPOSED TO BE
REDIRECTED TO THE PARCHMENT IS
SCHEDULED TO SUNSET AND TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AND SO WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT EXPANDING NEW
ACTIVITIES AND PROGRAMS UNDER
THE.
HEADER OF A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE WHEN THE FUND IS.
EXPECTED TO SUNSET AND THEN THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD FACE ANOTHER
TIME SIMILAR. ONGOING PROBLEM IN
A FEW YEARS.
AND THEN OF AB ONE COMPONENT OF
THAT ALSO AS WELL AS I THINK WAS
MENTIONED IS THAT THIS THIS TIRE
FUND IS CURRENTLY. TIME USED BY
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS A
PART OF THE PROPOSAL TO RE
DIRECTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE WOULD REQUIRE
OR IS BEING PROPOSED TO USE OF
BACKFILL. COME FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
FOR THE AIR BE THAT MAKE THEM
HOLD SO WE KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
HAS A LOT OF OTHER PRIORITIES
FOR THE DDR FUNDING SO.
.
YEAH THAT DID THIS WOULD REDUCE
AVAILABLE FUNDS FOR OTHER
PRIORITIES AND WHAT ABOUT THE
MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT TO FUNDING
DOES THAT CONSTITUTE DIVERSION
THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE BACK
FILLED THEM NO THERE'S A FOR
WELL. THAT THINK YOU PROBABLY
HEAR FROM SOME PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE IS FUNDING IN THAT I'M
FUND BALANCE FOR THAT THAT COULD
SUPPORT SO THERE'S NO DIRECT
BACKFILL.
BUT THAT FUND IS LARGE AND
SUPPORTS MANY OTHER ACTIVITIES
AND SO TO THE DEGREE YOU'RE
USING IT HERE YOU DON'T HAVE IT
AVAILABLE FOR SOME OF THOSE
OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT TIME. THAT
IT CURRENTLY SUPPORTS THERE'S NO
DIRECTORY DIRECTION BACK FILL AS
THERE IS WITH THE TIRE FUND IN
THIS CASE HOWEVER.
SO WE WOULDN'T AT THIS POINT
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE USE OF.
OF THE TIRE FUND BECAUSE OF ALL
OF THOSE CONCERNS THAT I
OUTLINES NO NEXUS
BOB THE SUNSET AND THE REQUIRED
TO BACK FILL.
SO THAT LEAVES YOU WITH. GENERAL
FUND FEES OR NEW TAXES THOSE ARE
KIND OF YOUR OTHER MIX OF
AVAILABLE FUNDS IF YOU WANT TO
SUPPORT AN AUGMENTATION FOR
THIS.
DEPARTMENT.
AS WAS MENTIONED THEY ARE GOING
THROUGH A BUDGETARY REVIEW RIGHT
NOW THAT'S TAKING A LOOK AT HOW
THEY'RE USING THEIR EXISTING
REVENUES AND HOW WELL THOSE
ALIGNED WITH THEIR EXISTING
ACTIVITIES IT'S HARD. TO MAKE A
DECISION WITHOUT KNOWING THAT
INFORMATION AND YOU WON'T HAVE
IT BASED ON THEIR TIMELINE BY
THE TIME YOU NEED TO MAKE A
DECISION FOR THIS BUDGET.
SO ONE OPTION YOU HAVE IS YOU
COULD USE GENERAL FUND TO MAKE.
AUGMENTATIONS ABOVE AND BEYOND
WHAT YOU CHOOSE TO USE FROM NBA
OR OTHER SOURCES AND THEN
REVISIT IT IN THE SUBSEQUENT
YEAR ONCE YOU'VE GOT THE RESULTS
OF THAT BUDGETARY REVIEW TO SEE
IF OTHER FEES OR. OTHER SOURCES
MAY BE APPROPRIATE.
WE DO THINK THAT THAT'S PART OF
OUR PACKAGE OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE RECOMMEND INCLUDING A
STATUTORY DEADLINE FORCE AT
STATUS UPDATE A WRITTEN STATUS
UPDATE ON THAT ON THAT BUDGETARY
REVIEW SO THAT IN BUDGET YEAR
PLUS WHEN YOU HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
REVISIT THIS.
DECISION IN THIS PACKAGE OF
FUNDS SOURCES RIGHT NOW THERE IS
THERE WERE THERE WAS A
BUDGETARY.
DEADLINE.
BASED ON THE PERCHED THAT
ADMINISTRATION HAS TAKEN IN THIS
REVIEW. FROM THAT THEY'RE TAKING
A LITTLE BIT LONGER THEY'RE
DOING A MORE IN DEPTH REVIEW BUT
WE THINK YOU KNOW SETTING A
DEADLINE FOR WHEN YOU'RE GOING
TO GET THAT INFORMATION WE
RECOMMEND THIS OCTOBER. SO THAT
INFORMS YOU OF WHETHER THIS
REVIEW IS GIVING YOU THE
INFORMATION YOU NEED AND SETS
YOU UP FOR A DISCUSSION NEXT
YEAR OF REVISITING WHAT THAT
FUNDING SOURCE.
MAY BE GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU JULIANNE MOORE IS IN
THE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE THE ADMINISTRATION
APPROACHED THE ISSUES
SURROUNDING THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AS A WHOLE
AND.
THIS PACKAGE THAT THAT'S BEFORE
YOU.
MAKES.
MAKES SENSE IT PROVIDES THE
DEPARTMENT WITH A LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE AND STABLE FUNDING
SOURCE.
IT MADE SENSE FROM A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE ARTICLE NINETEEN
DOES ALLOW THE USE OF THE MOTOR
VEHICLE.
FEES TO BE USED FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES.
IT.
FROM A POLICY PERSPECTIVE IT
PROVIDES.
AN ONGOING.
.
BACK FILL BASICALLY FOR THEIR
STRUCK OR ANSWER TO THEIR
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AND IT ALLOWS
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING. AT LEAST THOSE
SERVICES WITHOUT ANY CUTS.
AND THEN IT ALSO PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
TO PROVIDE FOUR SOME OF THE
PROGRAM EXPANSION AND TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES THAT HAVE
COME DOWN THAT WE HAVEN'T FUNDED
IN THE PAST.
FROM A FISCAL PERSPECTIVE.
AS FAR IS THE TIRE FUND. WE DO
FEEL THAT IT IS IT DOES HAVE
NEXUS AUTOMOBILES ARE.
CREATING.
AS OUR DIRECTOR BONHAM HAD HAD
MENTIONED. NUMEROUS INCIDENTS
WITH THE WILDLIFE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND.
SO IT IT IT HAS BEEN PASSED BY A
TWO THIRDS VOTE HAS ASKED THE LA
O. NOTED.
AND IT CAN BE USED FOR THAT
WE'VE KEPT KARL MOYER THE CARL
MOYER PROGRAM HOLE. BY BACK
FEELING THAT TWENTY SIX MILLION
WITH ADDITIONAL.
GIGI R. F..
AND IT IS THE INTENT TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU.
SO THE.
.
BUDGET PROPOSAL HAS ABOUT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS SOON ENOUGH
FUNDING FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
FIGHT REMEMBER THE NUMBER YES
CORRECTLY.
I AND AND IT'S BEEN SUGGESTED BY
FOLKS WHO ARE UNHAPPY WITH THE
OTHER.
IDENTIFIED SOURCES THAT THE AN
ENTIRE AMOUNT BE. FUNDED OUT OF
THE.
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND.
WHAT'S THE REASON THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
RECOMMENDING THAT VERSUS THESE
OTHER SOURCES SINCE THERE. ARE.
I FELT.
CLEARLY CALLS ON THE ON ON THE
OTHER RESOURCES THAT ARE THAT
ARE BEING IDENTIFIED.
MISS.
A CHAIR MAT. MARROW RESPOND
FIRST JR.
SO.
I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT PROSPECT
AND I UNDERSTAND IT.
BUT I THINK PASSED COULD BE PRO
LAW.
SO THE REASON WHY OUR DEPARTMENT
HAS AN IMBALANCE RIGHT NOW IN
OUR MAIN REPOSITORY. IS LARGELY
BECAUSE OF EARLIER FUN SHIPS OFF
OF THE GENERAL FUND.
YOU CAN COUNT THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
THE DEPARTMENT FUND SHIFTED
OFFER.
SO IN MY JUDGMENT RUNNING OUR
DEPARTMENT.
GENERAL FUND WILL ALWAYS REMAIN
CYCLICAL.
AND AN ANNUAL DETENTION BETWEEN
APPROPRIATE EXPENDITURES ACROSS
A WHOLE SUITE OF STATE.
INTEREST.
I ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S A POSSIBLE
OPTION.
BUT JUST LIKE I DEL CURRENTLY
THERE MAY BE AN APPETITE IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR A. TAX.
RELATED OUTDOOR GOODS OR OTHER
FUNCTIONS.
AND LIKE I DOUBT.
THERE ARE THAT MANY SECTORS IN
OUR PORTFOLIO WE CAN INCREASE
FEES ON.
OUR GOAL THAT OUR DEPARTMENT IS
TRYING TO FIND AN ADDITIVE MORE
SUSTAINABLE FUND SOURCE.
AND GENERAL FUND CREATES RISK
FOR US IN THE DEPARTMENTAL LEVEL
THAT WHAT THE LORD GIVETH.
THE LORD MIGHT TAKE IT THE WAY.
I HOPE THAT'S
SOMEWHAT INSTRUCTIVE FROM WHERE
WE SAID AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WAY AND. EVEN
THOUGH YOU DIRECTED THE QUESTION
TO THE DEPARTMENT FUNDS I THINK
OF.
QUESTION WHETHER DIVINE
INTERVENTION IS NECESSARY HERE.
I I I I THINK.
YOUR POINT IF I CAN.
.
SAVE MORE AND MORE COLLOQUIAL
FASHION IS THAT TO. WHEN THE
NEXT DOWNTURN HAPPENS AS
EVERYONE PREDICTS AT SOME POINT
IT WILL UNFORTUNATELY.
FISH AND WILDLIFE IS ONE OF THE
FIRST PLACES NOT ONE OF THE LAST
PLACES THAT.
.
WE RETURNED TO FOR HER AT A
TRIMMING THE BUDGET IN ORDER TO
MAKE UP THE SHORTFALLS SET. YET
EARLY ACCURATE.
SAID BETTER.
QUESTION MR FUNG.
GONNA TAKE ROLE SINCE WE GOT
THREE PEOPLE HAVE IT ABOUT IT
WILL DO THAT AFTER OKAY. FEET
BEFORE PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
WE'RE DONE WITH THIS
DESCRIPTION.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SO I OF COURSE HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ON ON THE DIVERSIONS
OF THE MOTOR VEHICLE FUND. AND
THE TIRE FEE CAR MORE FUNDS TO
GO TO AND THE EXPANSION OF
PROGRAM ACTIVITIES FROM THE
PUBLIC OFFICIAL WHILE I.
.
SO ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE MY
UNDERSTANDING AND MAYBE SOME.
WHAT THE CAR REGISTRATION?
?
FEET UP PAYMENTS ARE MADE NOW
WE'RE WHERE DOES THAT GO
CURRENTLY WHAT PROGRAMS IF THE
PART AND I SAID CAN ANSWER THIS
WHERE IS A BILL CURRENTLY.
IT IT I AM ON MY ASSUMPTION IS
THAT IT. OF MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT IT PAYS FOR DMV OPERATIONS
AND CHP OPERATIONS
BUT THIS CAR.
SO THERE'S A CLEAR NEXUS THAT
WENT A CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IS
PAYING THEIR CAR REGISTRATION
FEES THAT'S GOING TO PAY THOSE
PROGRAMS.
THAT IS CORRECT IT ALSO ALLOWS
FOR THE MITIGATION OF ANY
NEGATIVE IMPACTS.
SO THEN.
MAYBE YOU CAN CLARIFY THAT THE
NEXUS
TO THE TO THE. WHAT DO YOU SAY
TO A CALIFORNIA WHO'S PAYING
THEIR COURAGE AND HE'S NOW AND
AND YOU'RE ASKING NOW FOR THAT
MONEY TO BE DIVERTED TO FISH AND
WILDLIFE?
THE FIRST THING I WOULD SAY IN
THIS HYPOTHETICAL IS THANK YOU.
THE SECOND THING I WOULD SAY.
IS.
UNDER CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
ARTICLE NINETEEN SECTION THREE
BE.
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS THE MONEY
CAN BE USED FOR.
RESEARCH PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
IMPROVEMENT MAY NETS IN
OPERATION.
A PUBLIC STREETS AND HIGHWAYS
INCLUDING THE MITIGATION OF
THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS.
ROADS VEHICLES HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS
THE VILLAGE RATED SOME OF THE
DATA AROUND THAT.
THE THIRD THING I'D SAY IS.
OUR WILDLIFE OFFICERS ARE.
SWORN PEACE OFFICERS UNDER THE
PENAL CODE.
DAN IN DAY OUT THEY END UP
ISSUING CITATIONS ABOUT.
THE LAWS IN OPERATIONS OF OUR
STREETS AND HIGHWAYS.
SO THEN.
WITH THAT CREATE A PROBLEM FOR.
IF
FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE CHP AND
IDEA V. AS THERE WOULD THERE BE
AN ISSUE WITH THEIR FUNDING IF
THE F. NOW WERE.
IF THE GENERAL FUND IS
SUSPICIOUS AS YOU INDICATED AND
THAT YOU NEED A STABLE REVENUE
SOURCE I WOULD ASSUME THAT THE
DMV IN THIS YEAR'S P. ALSO IT IS
ABLE REVENUES.
SO OVER CONSTANTLY DIVERTING
MONEY FROM PROGRAM TO PROGRAM
OUT HOW WE SETTING EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT.
A DIFFICULT PRESIDENT'S HERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG I THINK
THAT'S A LEGITIMATE QUERY
JUST WHY I APPRECIATE ALEJO'S
SUGGESTION WE START BIG PICTURE
ABOUT PURPOSE AND NEED.
I WOULD IMAGINE YOU SEE ME AGAIN
MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND WE'LL GET INTO FUND SOURCE.
A PRINCIPAL FOR OUR DEPARTMENT
IN THIS ENDEAVOR. IS TO KNOCK
GORE SOMEONE ELSE'S OX.
THAT'S TRUE AS TO THE MOTOR
VEHICLE CAL IT'S ALSO TRUE TO
THE TIRE RECYCLING FUND.
WHICH SUPPORTS OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY.
IT'S WHY WE WERE SEEKING A BACK
FILL. ONE TO ONE SO THERE WOULD
NOT BE A LOSS ON THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT
BRINGS IN ABOUT THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION A YEAR IN REVENUE. AND
THAT IT'S FUND BALANCES
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED
AND FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
NOW I DON'T ARGUE THE DMV AND
CHP MAY VALUE THAT EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
BUT I WOULD PUT THAT EIGHTEEN
MILLION IN THE CONTEXT OF FUND
BALANCE THAT MAY BE AT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION.
SO WHAT IS THE NEXUS EGGS CAN
YOU CAN YOU DETAIL AND DID IT SO
MY UNDERSTANDING IS YOU
INDICATED THAT THERE ARE
VEHICLES THAT.
THEY UNFORTUNATELY OF OUR HER
HITTING WILDLIFE AND SO WE GOT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN AND THAT THAT'S THE
NEXUS OF WHY YOU CAN TAKE A
EUROPE THAT THE. THAT THE
PROPOSAL IS TO
TO DIVERT WATER VEHICLE FUNDING
TO FISH WILDLIFE.
I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS
LIKELY.
DISCUSSION PERHAPS DISAGREEMENT
OVER THE NEXUS WE ALLEGE
I APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT AGAIN.
I THINK THERE ARE AT LEAST TWO
VARIABLES THAT ESTABLISHED THE
NEXUS.
THE SINGLE BIGGEST KILLER OF
WILDLIFE IN THE STATE OUR CARS.
SECOND.
OUR GAME WARDENS.
OVERSEE AND ADMINISTER NOT AS A
PRIMARY ENTITY BUT CERTAINLY AS
A SUPPORTING ENTITY.
OF THE LAWS IN THE OPERATIONS OF
OUR ROADS.
AND HIGHWAYS.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIAN WOULD ACCEPT THAT
NEXUS.
I CAN'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIA BUT I
PERSONALLY THINK IT'S A
REASONABLE ARGUMENT.
IN TERMS OF THE A DIVERSION OF
THE. CARL MOYER FUNDS.
A.
IT'S BACK FILLED BY ONE YEAR.
WHY WOULD NOT IF IT'S GONNA BE
BACK THOUGH BY CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS WHY WOULDN'T CAP AND
TRADE FUNDS BE USED TO ADDRESS
THE SHORTFALL ORIGINALLY
INCENTIVE?
SHIFTING ALL THIS MONEY AROUND.
GOOD MORNING METAL MANIA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO JUST TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT CAP AND TRADE.
OTHER OUR LEGAL STRUCTURES
AROUND THE CAP AND TRADE FUNDS
WHERE. CAPITA NEEDS TO BE USED
SPECIFICALLY FOR ACTIVISM REDUCE
EMISSIONS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTIONS SO.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE CAP
INTRIGUED PACKAGE A LATER ON
YOU'LL SEE THAT ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS ARE RELATED TO REDUCING
EMISSIONS OR SEQUESTERING
EMISSIONS.
UP THE CRIME LAWYER PROGRAM
WHICH.
SUPPORTS CLEAN TRUCKS AND
VEHICLES. DOES HAVE THE EFFECT
OF REDUCING EMISSIONS AND SO
THEREFORE IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
USE A CAP AND TRADE THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE PROGRAMS THAT ARE ON
THE TABLE RIGHT NOW. WHILE
PERSPECTIVE DON'T NECESSARILY
RESULTING IN A EMISSION
REDUCTIONS ARE SEQUESTRATION.
ARE HOWEVER BECAUSE OF THE.
TIRES AND TIRES BEING A PROXY
TO.
.
THAT AFFECTS ON AUTOMOBILES
HAVE ON WILDLIFE AND HABITAT
IT'S A VERY A STRONG NEXUS OF
FROM A POLICY.
OKAY SO.
SO WITH GIVE ME THE NEXUS AGAIN.
I LIVE ON THE FUND THE TIRE FEE
YEAH SO TIRES ARE THE.
APART OF AUTOMOBILE USE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO AS THE DIRECTORS
MENTIONED.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL MOMENTS.
THERE'S A CLEAR.
ADVERSE EFFECT THAT AUTOMOBILE
USE HAS BOTH FROM.
WILDLIFE.
IMPACT PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS
HABITAT FIRST.
SO YOU INTO SO AND SO USING. A
OF FUNDING SOURCE THAT IS LINKED
TO AUTOMOBILE USE
WHICH HAS THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS
ON A OF THE ENVIRONMENT.
IS A.
CLEAR BOTH LEGAL IS A LEGAL USE
AS WELL AS A UP POLICY USE.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
.
AND THEN.
THE FUND'S THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY FUNDED FROM THAT
ARE MADE ENTIRELY HOLE THROUGH
THE A CAP AND TRADE FOR.
SO JUST SO I UNDERSTAND.
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S BEEN FUNDED UNDER THE
TIRE FEE THAT GET SHIFTED TO
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND THEN CAP AND TRADE.
SHIFTED TO PAY BACK THOUGH
COBBLER.
CORRECT AND THAT'S GONNA BE DONE
ONGOING BASIS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
NOW WE CAN'T TIE THE HANDS OF
THE FUTURE LEGISLATURE HOW CAN
YOU SAY THAT WE CAN.
IT'S GONNA BE DONE ONGOING I'M
MERELY REFLECTING WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
IS AND IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS THAT TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS CAN. BE
CONSIDERED ON GOING AS PART OF A
SIMPLY A BASELINE.
AND SO WHEN IT'S ADDED IN THE
BASELINE WE DON'T COME BACK
EVERY YEAR ASKING.
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING THROUGH
BCP'S
IT'S JUST PART OF THE BASELINE
AND THAT.
S. A GENERAL SENSE.
A IS A PRETTY SECURE OF FUND
WAY TO FUND A PROGRAM.
ADDED AS
MAYBE I CAN MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER
BUT I I.
I WOULD ASSUME THOUGH THAT IF
YOU ARE DEALING WITH WILDLIFE
AND WHILE HIGH WILDLIFE HABITAT
AND PRESERVATION THAT THERE IS
SOME CAP AND TRADE. TEXAS.
THERE.
TO DATE.
THE SINGLE.
DISTRIBUTION OF G. R. F. TO OUR
DEPARTMENT. IS FOCUSED ON
HABITAT RESTORATION THE ACTUAL
PHYSICAL. RESTORATION OF
WETLANDS WHICH
FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH TURNED OUT
TO BE.
ONE OF THE HIGHER CARBON
SEQUESTER THAT'S A WORD TYPE OF
LANDSCAPES.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE OF YOUR
IMPORTANCE IN THE LEGISLATURE
YOU'VE PUT ON A NEXUS TO
CONTROLLING EMISSIONS.
NOT MANAGING THE OTHER ASPECTS
OF A WARMING CLIMATE WHICH ARE
ADAPTATION RELATED.
SO WE HAVE HAD VERY LIMITED YOU
ARE A FUNDS.
THAT IS BEEN DIRECTED TO THAT
VERY CREDIBLE AND LEGITIMATE
EMISSIONS CONTROL TO WETLAND
RESTORATION.
A IS IF YOU ARE QUESTIONS WHICH
CHAIR AT IN TERMS TO THE LA SHOW
ARE THERE OTHER AVENUES OF
FUNDING I NEED YOU MENTIONED
GENERAL FUND OTHER IS IT'S MY
OUT. A MILE THE FIELD THAT CAP
AND TRADE SHOULD NOT BE ON THE
TABLE IN TERMS OF. OUR.
JUDGE US IN THE SHORTFALL.
YEAH I THINK WE WOULD PROBABLY.
CONCUR WITH
THE.
STATEMENTS OF THE ADMINISTRATION
AT LEAST RIGHT NOW GIVEN THE
LEGAL OPINIONS THAT LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL HAS PUT ON THE USE OF
GGF IN THE NEAR TERM.
WITH THE NEXUS ON EMISSIONS.
I THINK IN IN SOME OF THE
DECISIONS HAVE BEEN AND SO AND
FUTURE YEARS THERE MAY BE MORE
FLEXIBILITY OVER HOW YOU USE
THOSE FUNDS BUT. KICK COUNSELORS
A PINE THAT AND IN THE NEAR TERM
IT THAT NEXUS NEEDS TO BE BILLY
GRAHAM.
CLOSE TO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND SEQUESTRATION.
IN TERMS OF YOUR CONCERNS WITH
THE NEXUS.
HOW DO YOU DO YOU SEE A CLEAR
NEXUS IS THIS NEXUS MAKES SENSE?
I THINK AS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE SEE IN CONCEPTTHE
NEXUS FOR THE NBA SEEMS THAT
EVERYTHING THAT'S ON CONCEPT
THOUGH WELL I DON'T THINK IN
CONCEPT THE TIRE IS LESS THAT
REASONABLE TO US AND I THINK WE
WE WOULD DRIVE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THOSE TWO WHERE THAT
WHERE. IS FOR THE NBA THE
CONSTITUTION CLEARLY SAYS IT CAN
USE FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL
EFFECTS OF MOTOR VEHICLES WE
HAVE NOT YET SEEN THAT SPECIFIC
ACCOUNTING AND JUST VISION OF
WHAT WORKLOAD THE DEPARTMENT IS
UNDERTAKING AS A RESULT OF THAT
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
BOTH LEGALLY AND FROM A POLICY
BASIS TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH.
FOR THE NBA I THINK FOR THE TIRE
GIVEN THE LANGUAGE THAT'S
PROPOSED.
AND THE WAY THE TIRE FEE HAS
BEEN STRUCTURED WE
WE WE DON'T EQUATE TIRES WITH.
THE EFFECTS OF MOTOR VEHICLES
MORE BROADLY WITH WE WE WILL
LOOK AT IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
NARROWLY AND. DIP IN NEGATIVE
IMPACTS CREATED BY TIRES WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE JUST DUMPED HIM
FOR THAT YET THEN MY LAST
QUESTION IN TERMS OF SINCE IF
THE NEXUS IS THAT. WE WANT TO
PREVENT A.
A A COLLISIONS AND ACCIDENTS
BETWEEN VEHICLES AND WILDLIFE
WHICH IS
CERTAINLY IMPORTANT WHAT I HAVE
AT OF THE EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S BEING DIVERTED.
WHAT IS GOING TO BE DONE TO
PREVENT THAT?
QUESTION.
BEFORE RESPONDING.
I DON'T.
BACK THEN IT.
A.
YOU YOU YOU IN THE LEGISLATURE.
NEED TO SOLVE.
THAT PARTICULAR PROBLEM I'M
TRYING TO JUGGLE.
BUT FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH HERE'S
THAT PROBLEM.
I THINK.
IT'S POSSIBLE THE DEPARTMENT
COULD FIND MORE SECTORS TO
CHARGE FEES TO.
BUT HONESTLY THAT'S GONNA RUN TO
INDUSTRY.
IT'S GOING TO RUN A BUSINESS.
IT'S GOING TO RUN THE HUNTERS
AND ANGLERS.
AND I'M HOPING.
INSTEAD DEFINED AN ADDITIVE FUND
SOURCE WHICH HAS AN APPROPRIATE
NEXUS THAT CAN SUPPORT BENEFITS
FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THAT AND THAT ENDEAVOR.
I WILL ALSO SAY THAT.
I BELIEVE WE CAN POINT TO
SPECIFIC THINGS AND.
.
SIMON OF POSITIONS THAT RELATE
TO THE WILDLIFE COLLISION NEXUS.
I ALSO THINK IT'S TRUE THAT.
WE WERE TRANSPARENT TEN
ALLOCATING THE FIFTY MILLION IN
THE NINETY EIGHT POSITIONS. THAT
A INCREDIBLY GRANULAR LEVEL OF
DETAIL.
SO EVERYONE COULD SEE WHAT WE
WERE PROPOSING.
SOME OF THIS WORK AS DESCRIBED
WOULD OCCUR IN THE OCEAN.
BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT THERE'S
A WAY TO ENCOURAGE IT TECHNICAL
FUND SHIFT WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT.
AS AN EXAMPLE OUR WARDENS.
PERHAPS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
IT COME OFF OF OTHER FUN SOURCES
WERE USING FOR SOME OF THEIR
ACTIVITIES.
WE COULDN'T MOVE THEM TO THE M.
V. A AS AN EXAMPLE. WHICH WOULD
FREE UP OUR BUDGETING
FLEXIBILITY TO THEN USE EXISTING
SOURCES FOR THAT MARINE WORK.
SO THAT IS PART OF THE
ARCHITECTURE BEHIND. I THINK ONE
OF OUR MOST DETAILED PROPOSALS.
MISTER FUNG I AGREE THAT ONE OF
OUR NEXT STEPS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS TO DO THE
QUANTIFICATION THE WORKLOAD
JUSTIFICATION. AND PRESENT THAT
TO YOU AND STAFF I ACCEPT THAT
SO. OF IT I JUST ALSO WANTED TO
ADD THAT YOU HAD ALLUDED EARLIER
IN DISCUSSING THE MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT HOW IT SUPPORTS.
CHP AS WELL SCHEME BE IN THAT
IT'S.
IMPACT TRUE OF THE OTHER
DEPARTMENT THINK IT'S FUNDED IS
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AND SO I DON'T WANNA LOSE SIGHT
OF THE FACT THAT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. AYE AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL AGENCY THAT'S
CHARGED WITH A ADDRESSING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF
AUTOMOBILE USE IS ALREADY. A SO
THOSE ARE THE PRESIDENT TO USING
A VA FOR THOSE TYPES OF ACT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
THANK YOU SO I'LL JUST CONCLUDE
BY SAYING I KNOW THAT THERE'S A.
A A QUEST TO FIND A NEXUS THAT
IN IN MY OPINION IT IS A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TO WRAP MY HANDS
AROUND. I THINK THAT BEFORE WE
LOOK AT RAISING FEES OR.
OR THE THREAT OF RAISING FEES I
THINK WE HAVE SEE HONESTLY HAVE
TO BE. REALISTIC IN TERMS OF
LOOKING FOR FUNDS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE. WHETHER IT'S A
GENERAL FUND WHETHER IT'S
THERE'S SOME NEXUS OF FOR A CAP
AND TRADE DOLLARS THAT ARE THERE
GOING TO BE THERE. BUT IN TERMS
OF IN MY MIND AS.
AS WERE ALL ELECTED BE STEWARDS
OF THE TAXPAYER.
I'M AND TAXPAYER DOLLARS A
THERE'S A CLEAR NEXUS IN TERMS
OF CAR REGISTRATION FEES THAT
WENT.
WHEN I WHEN I PAID MY TO LEARN A
SIX DOLLARS TO AT THE DMV THAT
IT GOES TO THOSE PROGRAMS AT THE
DMV OPERATES.
CHP CARBON TERMS OF A TRYING TO
CLEAN UP OF VEHICLES AND IMPROVE
ENGINES AND AND AND WHAT AND
WHAT NOT AND THAT WHEN. UGH THE
CALL MORE PROGRAM THAT CURRENT
EXISTENCES ON BY THE TIRE AND IN
A WE WERE TOLD AT THAT THAT'S
ANY FIVE CENTS WAS GOING TO GO
TO THIS PROGRAM.
THE ALL OF A SUDDEN FROM YEAR TO
YEAR WE KEEP SHIFTING MONEY
AROUND BECAUSE THERE IS SOME.
.
NEED A TO FILL A GAP.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS BUT NOW
WHETHER IT'S DONE IN THE PAST
DOESN'T JUSTIFY THAT WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO DO IT OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN FOR FOR A VARIOUS
THINGS. AND SO THAT'S MY CONCERN
ESPECIALLY IF WE'RE GOING TO
BASICALLY.
ROB ONE AGENCY TO ANOTHER AGENCY
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PATTERSON.
UP.
I THINK IT'S ONE THING.
ARE TO BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
BECAUSE YOU CAN.
IT'S ANOTHER THING ENTIRELY.
TO DO IT WHETHER YOU OUGHT OR
OUGHT NOT TO DO IT.
AND I WILL TELL YOU MY BIG HEART
BURN IN ALL OF THIS IS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN MAKING PROMISES TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF ME I
THINK BREAKS THOSE PROMISES.
AND I THINK THAT IS A VERY VERY
SERIOUS BIG PICTURE.
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
THERE IS IN AREAS.
THAT I REPRESENT.
AND LOTS OF OTHER MEMBERS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE. THERE IS AN
UNDERCURRENT OF DISTRUST OF
GOVERNMENT AND DISTRUST.
BROUGH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THEY SEE PROMISES MADE
AND A PROMISE IS BROKEN.
THIS IS PRECISELY THE KIND OF
THING.
THAT CREATES UP MISS TRUST.
OUR I SO I MEAN THE THE POINT
YOU'RE MAKING IS WE CAN DO IT SO
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT. I DON'T
THINK YOU SHOULD BE THINKING IN
THOSE TERMS I THINK YOU SHOULD
BE THINKING IN. TERMS OF WHETHER
OR NOT THIS IS PROMISE A MAY
PROMISE KEPT IN WHETHER OR NOT
YOU OUGHT.
BUT TO DO IT.
.
SO NETANYAHU WHETHER THERE'S A.
LIMITED NEXUS OR NOT.
STRETCHING THE NEXUS IS IN MANY
WAYS JUST.
AN EXCUSE FOR DOING SOMETHING.
A.
TO PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE MONEY FROM
ONE THING OF AND AND PUT IT TO
ANOTHER AYE I FIND THIS WHOLE
EXERCISE TO BE VERY VERY
TROUBLING.
NUMBER TO THAT DAY THE CAR MORE
YOUR PROGRAM THE TIRE PROGRAM
ALL OF THAT.
HAS BEEN VERY WELL RECEIVED IT
HAS BEEN VERY VERY EFFECTIVE.
AND THE PROMISE MADE HERE IS
THAT DOWD WE'RE GONNA BACK
PHILIP THE BACKFILL IS ON GOING.
I LOOKED AT THE LANGUAGE I'VE
BEEN VERY CAREFUL ABOUT THIS AND
VERIFIED IN THE LANGUAGE OF ALL
OF THIS.
THERE IS NO ONGOING COMMITMENT.
TO BACK FILL YOU CAN'T MAKE THAT
ONGOING COMMITMENT.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TRUST.
THE WILL OF THE VERY FORCES
FACTORS THAT MAKE.
TOUCHING THE GENERAL FUND
PROBLEMATIC.
AND SO THE RISK THAT YOU SUGGEST
IN THE GENERAL FUND I THINK IS
JUST AS MUCH.
A SIGNIFICANT RISK.
IN THIS OTHER REPROACH.
AND THEN NOT.
FINALLY THE UP.
I FIND IT NOT I FIND IT
BORDERLINE.
HYPOCRITICAL.
THAT OUT THAT ON ONE ITEM.
YOU WOULD BE SO.
CAREFUL
AND PRECISE WITH RESPECT TO THE
USE OF GREENHOUSE.
GAS IS TO THE POINT THAT THAT.
FUNDS THAT YOU WOULD DIE.
CONSTRAIN THEM FROM SORT OF A
LIMITED NEXUS TEST.
WHEN IN FACT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TAKES.
AWFUL LOT OF.
.
A GREENHOUSE GAS MONEY.
OUGHT TO PAY FOR OUT OF.
HIGH SPEED RAIL THAT DOES NOT
MEET THAT NEXUS IN ANY SINGLE
POSSIBLE WAY. AND WE'VE HAD VERY
CLEAR ANALYSIS FROM THE.
.
FROM THE ARAB.
NOT FROM OUR OUR OUR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST AT THAT JUST DOES NOT
MAKE THAT NEXUS TESTS I I I
REALLY FIND THE.
.
AGAIN WE TALK ABOUT.
MEAN THIS IS SMOKE AND MIRRORS
THIS IS BUDGETING SHELL GAME.
AND PEOPLE OUT HERE IN THIS
AUDIENCE HAVE DISCOVERED AND
THEY'RE NOT HAPPY AND I IS A
SITTING MEMBER OF THIS.
.
COMMITTEE ON NOT HAPPY EITHER.
SO I JUST TO WRAP THIS UP IN AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF OF OF FOLKS WHO
WANT TO WORK. AT PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THIS ITEM.
I'VE.
IF YOU COULD RESPOND VERY
QUICKLY TO A CONCERN THAT HAS
BEEN ADDRESSED TO ME AND IN MY
OFFICE BY FOLKS WHO ARE TROUBLED
BY THE. BOTTOM.
A FUNDING SOURCES SAID THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED.
PARTICULARLY WITH THE UP OF
MOTOR VEHICLE FUND IT'S BEEN
OBSERVED THAT.
IT'S EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
RIGHT.
.
THAT THAT OPENS THE DOOR.
AND THAT AS YOUR FUNDING NEEDS
INCREASE THAT BECOMES AN EASY
PLACE TO TURN TO SO YOU MAKE THE
POINT WHICH MAKES UP. IN A
CERTAIN AMOUNT SENSE TO ME IT'S
ONLY A SMALL PORTION OF OF THAT
FUND.
I THINK THEIR ARGUMENT WOULD BE.
WILL LIKE IT BUT THAT'S TODAY
WHAT ABOUT TOMORROW SO.
I DON'T KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING
YOU CAN ADDRESS BUT I'D
APPRECIATE HEARING YOUR THOUGHTS
ON.
NOW IF YOU CAN YEAH.
I APPRECIATE NO TIME LIKE THE
PRESENT DIRECT.
I APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT WITH
EACH OF THE MEMBERS AND STAFF.
A I THINK THAT'S A FAIR CONCERN.
I THINK THAT'S A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
CONCERN.
I SUPPOSE THERE'S A WAY TO
MANAGE THAT RISK.
LIKE OUR DEPARTMENT IS WILLING
TO ENTERTAIN THE IDEA OF
REPORTING RESPONSIBILITY.
AND SYNCHRONIZATION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET BASE PROCESS
UNDERWAY.
AND FINE TUNING OUR BUDGET OVER
TIME.
I THINK I'D BE INTERESTED IN
UNDERSTANDING.
WHETHER THEIR CONDITIONS OF MY
CONTROL THAT RISK.
I I NEED A LITTLE MORE TIME TO
REFLECT ON IT CARE FOR ENOUGH
MONEY LIKE IT'S A.
I WANTED TO GET THAT OUT THERE.
BECAUSE I KNOW WE HAVE A.
.
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER PEOPLE WHO
I SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE IN SO NINE
MINUTE.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE ROLE.
BUT.
LET ME JUST SAY TO FOLKS WHO
ARE PREPARING TO STEP FORWARD.
THAT I THINK WE'VE IDENTIFIED
MOST IF NOT ALL OF THE ISSUES SO
IN YOUR COMMENT YOU MIGHT WANT
TO JUST IDENTIFY THOSE THAT YOU
AGREE WITH OR DISAGREE WITH. BUT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO MAKE THE
ARGUMENT ITSELF AGAIN.
UNLESS YOU FEEL THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEST IN
THE IN THE IN THE DISCUSSION.
LISTICLE.
BLOOM. HERE FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN. PATTERSON.
WERE OFFICIAL.
RIGHT LET'S A BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT ANTI I'M GONNA ASK THAT
YOU ALL. A TRY TO ADHERE TO A
THIRTY SECOND.
A COMMENT LIKE THAT
IF AT ALL POSSIBLE.
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF LEEWAY
ON THAT BUT YOU CAN SEE.
WE HAVE FLOOD MANY MANY PEOPLE
THERE'S ANOTHER ISSUE THAT
FOLLOWS AT THE END OF OUR GENDER
THAT'S GONNA ALSO GENERATE A LOT
OF PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS BRENDAN TO ACT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AYE
THAT'S EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM
ALL THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS WE RUN THE MORE
PROGRAM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND
YOU ALSO SHOULD HAVE ALL
RECEIVED A LETTER. FROM A
COALITION OF THOSE OPPOSED TO
THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL OUGHT
TO DIVERT OF CARL MOYER FUNDS TO
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
ALL IT'S A DIVERSE COALITION ON
THE CARL MOYER PROGRAM HAS BEEN
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL NOT PROVEN.
COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM AND AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR AIR
POLLUTION CONSIST CONTROL
STRATEGY SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. I'M.
WE ARE WERE PART OF A COALITION
ALONG WITH MANY OF THE FEE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SIGNED THE
LETTER A THAT YOU HAVE.
TO EXTEND THE TIRE FEE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THEM WHERE PROGRAM
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT
WAS IN TWENTY THIRTEEN IS PART
OF AB EIGHT. AND MANY IN THIS
LEGISLATURE VOTED FOR THAT BILL
WAS A TWO THIRDS VOTE BILL AND
THERE WAS I ACTUALLY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THAT.
.
THAT CARRIED THAT THE FUNDING
SOURCE THROUGH TWENTY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
PROVIDING CERTAINTY OF FUNDING
IS IMPORTANT FOR THEM WHERE
PROGRAM WE THINK THIS PROPOSAL
ACTUALLY UNDERMINES THE PROGRAM
BY CALLING INTO QUESTION THE
CERTAINTY OF THAT FUNDING.
THEN BACK FILLING FROM THE CAP
AND TRADE FUNDING I THINK IS
ALSO A DOUBLE HIT BECAUSE OF WE
BELIEVE THAT THE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON. A
THAT ARE CLIMATE MEETING HER
CLIMATE GOALS AND OUR AIR
QUALITY CALLS AND SO I WE URGE
YOU TO AT REJECT THE PROPOSAL TO
DIVERT THAT FUNDING FROM. FROM
OTHER COLUMN WHERE PROGRAM AND
THAT WE SINCERELY APPRECIATE
YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MY NAME IS
KEN DELFINO AND I'M THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE.
I'VE BEEN THE DIRECTOR OF ONE
DEFENDERS WHILE I FOR THE LAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS IN THE LAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS I'VE WORKED ON
THE ISSUE OF TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO STABILIZE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S OF FUNDING SITUATION
I'VE WATCHED VARIOUS EFFORTS
BUDGET STABILIZE THE FUND.
GENERAL FUND WAS USED THE LAST
TIME AROUND THERE WAS THE BUDGET
A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN THE
PRESERVATION FUND. AND AS IT HAS
BEEN POINTED OUT WE ARE BACK
HERE AGAIN WHICH IS A REASON WHY
GENERAL FUND IS NOT A GOOD WAY
OF ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES.
WE.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
HAS BEEN PUT FORWARD BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THERE'LL BE A
NUMBER OF OTHER STAKEHOLDERS OF
THAT WILL BE UP HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AS WELL.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
PRESERVATION FUND STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT I'M AS NOTED THERE BEEN
ONGOING EFFORTS TO DO YOU DEAL
WITH THAT ALUM AND WE CANNOT FEE
OUR WAY OUT OF THIS PROBLEM
RIGHT NOW.
AND WITH RESPECT TO THE.
ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES THAT BEEN.
IDENTIFIED BY DIRECT DIRECTOR
BONHAM TALKED ABOUT THEM AS
ENHANCEMENTS.
OF THE DEPARTMENT'S ACTIVITIES I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THE ERROR
MISSION CRITICAL ACTIVITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED. THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN FUNDED BECAUSE OF
MANDATES THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED
ON THE DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT
TO UNDERTAKE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION MARINE CONSERVATION
ENFORCEMENT BUT THEN NO FUNDS
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO THOSE
ACTIVITIES.
SO.
I WOULD JUST SIMPLY ASK
THAT WHILE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT FUNDS SOURCE I
THINK THAT THERE IS STRONG
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE NEED. AND
FOR THE ITEMS THAT.
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE FUNDED AND I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN. AND CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FOR
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE FUN
SOURCES THAT IN ON IT IDENTIFIED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI ELEANOR TEAS ON BEHALF THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
AUTHORITY AND PENINSULA OPEN
SPACE TRUST IN SUPPORT OF THE
ITEM. IN PARTICULAR WE SUPPORT
THE INCLUDED FUNDING TO INCREASE
THE DEPARTMENT'S WORK ON HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY THINK IF. PERFECT
THANK YOU.
IF YOUR BREVITY.
WELL I MEAN I WENT OUT ON THE
BACK IF YOU'RE SHORT. THAT HELP.
WELL THEY MEET ON THE WITHOUT ON
CALIFORNIA I WOULD ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE AT DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE. AND ALSO ADD THAT OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND CALIFORNIA'S
VOTERS HAVE.
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT IN THIS.
FUNDING SOURCE I. TRY TO DO
THAT.
LIKE ARE MY COLLEAGUES THAT WE
WE FULLY SUPPORT WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING THIS IS ON
GOING ISSUE THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR YEARS AND IT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WERE A GROUP
IT'S BECOME A HALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THIS
AUGMENTATION AS OUTLINED BY THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE NEEDS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO MEET THEIR A
REQUIREMENT. CALIFORNIA GAME OR
SOME THE MOST UNDERPAID LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THE STATE
IN THIS WOULD JUST BE ONE STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION HELP
THAT.
AND SO MEMBER FONG ALL I'M HAPPY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIAN I DO THINK THEY WILL
GET THE NEXUS BETWEEN VEHICLES
AND HIGHWAYS IN BOTH LOSSA
HABITAT LOSS OF WILDLIFE WHITE
TO DO IS DRIVE A HIGHWAY
CALIFORNIA. AND SEE THE MASSIVE
CASUALTIES OF OF TRADERS ALONG
THE ROADSIDE AND YOU CAN YOU CAN
GET IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF OF A
NUMBER OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
CLIENTS THE COTTON INDUSTRY
CITRUS INDUSTRY RICE AND OTHERS.
UP WE MAKE NO JUDGMENT ABOUT THE
NEED FOR THE DEPARTMENT'S.
BUDGET
I AM IN FACT I BELIEVE IF YOU
WERE TO ASK MANY OF OUR BOARD
MEMBERS AND MEMBERS WITH AN ARC
ARE ASSOCIATIONS. THEY WOULD
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF A STRONG AND
HEALTHY DEPARTMENT
WHAT WE DISAGREE WITH IS THE
MOVEMENT OF THE AB EIGHT FUNDS
ARE FROM THE KORAN WHERE PROGRAM
WE ALSO RELY ON THOSE TO
SIGNIFICANT BASIS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN BASS. VALLEY ONLY TO
CLEAN THE AIR BUT TO MEET OUR
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS FOR CLEAN
AIR REQUIREMENTS AND SO WE
OPPOSED THAT.
EXCEPTION OF THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THOMAS LAWSON
CALIFORNIA AFTER GAS VEHICLE
COALITION I STAND HERE
REPRESENTING OUR TWENTY FIVE
MEMBER COMPANIES WHO A FUEL
SUPPORT AND WHO ARE.
MEMBERS OF THE PROVIDE FOR
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FLEETS
AND WE ARE YOU KNOW OPPOSED TO
THE BOOK THE BUDGET ACTION
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE CALL MORE
YOUR PROGRAM.
SOCIAL PROGRAM GOES A LONG WAY
AND HELPING PROVIDE INCENTIVES
IT CLEANER TRUCKS ON THE ROAD.
AND WE THINK.
IN THIS TIME WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO MEET VERY AGGRESSIVE CLEAN
AIR GOALS HAVING SOME FISCAL
UNCERTAINTY IS NOT A GOOD IDEA.
SO WE SUPPORT THE CALL MORE
PROGRAM AND WE ARE OPPOSED THIS
PARTICULAR BUT ACTION THINKING.
RULES PLAN COLLINS WITH THE
MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION. ON A
MOUNTAIN LION IS KILLED ON
CALIFORNIA'S ROADS AND FREEWAYS
ABOUT ONCE EVERY THREE DAYS IF
YOU PUT INTO CONTEXT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES THAT. GIVEN
THE AVAILABLE HABITAT THERE
MAYBE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
MOUNTAIN LIONS IN THE STATE.
THAT'S A REALLY HIGH NUMBER OF
MOUNT LINE'S KILLED NOW TAKE
THAT AND AND MULTIPLY THAT OUT
THROUGH ALL OF THE OTHER SPECIES
THAT ARE IMPACTED ON OUR STATE'S
ROADS. AND I THINK THE NEXUS
BECOMES QUITE CLEAR I ALSO THINK
THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
WILDLIFE AND AND ITS NEXUS TO IT
TO THEIR ROADS. LOOK AT THE
LICENSE PLATES THAT CALIFORNIANS
HAVE SUPPORTED ALL CONNECTED
MANY CONNECTED TO WILDLIFE OF
THE STATE.
.
SO WE ARE AND I'M SUPPORT OF THE
ENTIRE AMENDED BUDGET AS I
OUTLINED BY THE DEPARTMENT. AND
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONSIDER I'M
AS YOU TAKE YOUR DRIVE HOME. I
LOOKING AT THE SIDE OF THE ROAD
AND CONSIDER THE IMPACT THAT OUR
ROADS AND DO YOU HAVE ON
WILDLIFE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE'S ANY
BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO METRO AIR QUALITY
DISTRICT ALSO OPPOSED TO THE
DIVERSION OF THE COMA FUNDS
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF OF SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL THE AMERICAN SPORT
FISHING ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
TROUT. THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
GUIDES AND SPORTSMEN'S AND THE
GRASSLAND WATER DISTRICT.
ALSO THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION
WHICH WANTS TO SPECIFICALLY
THANK THE DEPARTMENT.
FOR THE CONVERSATION RELATIVE TO
THIS BUDGET ITEM ABOUT STAFFING
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON GARRETT'S MIDDLE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND
GAME WARDENS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR DFW IS
A CRITICAL FIRST STEP TO ALIGN
DEPARTMENT OF FUNDING WITH
LEGISLATIVE AND CONSERVATION
POLICIES.
AND TO MAINTAIN CALIFORNIA'S
LEADING ROLE IN WILDLIFE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CONSERVATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIMOTHY BELOW
ALSO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT.
FISHING GAME WARDEN ASSOCIATION
FOR TOO LONG CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
CREATING NEW CONSERVATION
REGULATIONS WITHOUT BALANCING
THEM WITH ENFORCEMENT CAPACITY.
THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS TO CHANGE
THAT.
BY FUNDING ENFORCEMENT OF THE
STATE CONSERVATION PRIORITIES
SPECIFICALLY MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING
POACHING AND MUCH MUCH MORE
THINK IF.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEFFREY GOLDBERG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL.
AS MISTER FINO SAID.
THE SUIT SO CALLED
AUGMENTATIONS ARE ACTUALLY.
CRITICAL FUNCTIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THE RETENTION.
.
RECRUITMENT AND REACTIVATION
PROGRAM THEY ARE THREE.
I BELIEVE IS A CRITICAL WAY OF
BRINGING A MORE PEOPLE.
INTO PAYING THE FEES AND AND DUH
ENJOYING THE RECREATION THAT'S
AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME AS AT
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION.
I'VE SERVED ON THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY GROUP FOR THE STRATEGIC
VISION PROCESS AND I'M WELL
AWARE OF THE CHALLENGES THE
DEPARTMENT FACE WITH ITS BUDGET.
I'M AND RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
I WOULD SAY FIRST THAT WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE TRANSFER
OF THE TIRE FEE FUNDS OVER TO
THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET BECAUSE
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. OF THE CAR
WHERE PROGRAM AND ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT WILL HAVE
ON THE CRIME WHERE PROGRAM.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GO THROUGH THE
MISSION BASED BUDGETING PROCESS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IS COMPLETING BEFORE WE MAKE ANY
LONG TERM FUNDING DECISIONS AT
THE DEPARTMENT THERE NEEDS TO BE
A LOOK AT THE PRIORITIES OF
ACTIONS AND HOW CAN WE IMPROVE.
ON OPERATIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT
BEFORE WE MAKE THESE FUNDING
DECISIONS CHECK GUARANTEED WITH.
ACTUAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
EVERY REPRESENT OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FARMERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE DIALOGUE HERE TODAY WE DO
YOU OPPOSE THE REDIRECTION OF
THE FUNDS FROM CARL MOYER. ADD
TO DFW AND RESPECTFULLY ASK A
CONSIDERATION OF REDUCTION OF
THAT PARTICULAR BUDGET ITEM
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I MATTHEW OUT
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE
ALSO A WOOD DECK OF THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY. ACT OF COLLEAGUES
WHEN REGARDING THE CAR MORE
FUNDING DIVERSION WELL WE OPPOSE
THAT BUDGET ITEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON BIANCA PETALED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS
WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL AND
THAT IS ON BEHALF OF STATE
SCIENTISTS ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTISTS AND BIOLOGISTS. THAT
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MARK FRIENDS TO
MAKE ON BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND WE'RE IN THAT SO
CALLED TWEENER POSITION
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT DEPARTMENTS
GOALS HERE TO INCREASE THEIR
FUNDING. LONGTIME ARAB PARTNERS
WITH THEM A LOT OF THE WORK THAT
WE DO FOR AND HABITAT PURPOSES.
BUT WE DO ADD SHARE THE CONCERNS
REGARDING THE DIVERSION OF THE
CARL MOYER PROGRAM WHERE BEEN
STRONG SUPPORTERS OF THAT
PROGRAMMING AND TAKE INTENDED
PURPOSES THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CORRINE REALLY
WOULD SEE WORLD WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL.
CYRIL'S THE STATE'S LARGEST
RESCUE AND REHABILITATION
FACILITY FROM RAIN MAMMALS AND
BETTER DATA CLEANER OCEAN BETTER
INFORMATION ON SPECIES HEALTHIER
SPECIES. IN THE OCEAN MEANS
FEWER ANIMALS ARE GONNA END UP
STARVING AND DEHYDRATED ON THE
BEACHES.
AND FEWER ANIMALS IT WILL NEED
RESCUING THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EMILY
SEVERITY DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
AND I'D LIKE TO SECOND OF MY
COLLEAGUE KIM IL FINOS OUT
COMMENTS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL. AND ALSO I AM
TWENTY SIX YEARS OLD AND ALSO AN
AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN I LIKE TO
THINK I DO THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD.
UNDERSTAND AND GET OUT AND THINK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS APRIL
WAKEMAN WITH THE SPORT FISHING
CONCERT.
CONSERVANCY.
ALL.
WILDLIFE AND ITS HABITAT.
S. VERY IMPORTANT CALIFORNIANS I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE A
PROMISE THAT NOT ONLY CAN I
ENJOY IT FOR MY CHILDREN. AND MY
GRANDCHILDREN. NEED TO BE ABLE
TO ENJOY THE WILDLIFE AND
HABITATS
IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SANDY ELLSWORTH
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE FOUND ARE.
FOR MANY THE PREVIOUSLY STATED
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT LONG
TERM AND STIFF SUSTAIN FUNDING
FOR DFW.
AND WHILE THE PROPOSED BUT THAT
BUDGET SUPPORTS A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS WE WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THE PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE OF INVESTMENTS IN
MARINE FISHERIES MANAGEMENT AND
ARENA RELATED LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE ALSO SHARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROPOSED FEE TRANSFER BECAUSE OF
IMPACTS TO THE CARL MOYER
PROGRAM BUT WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO HOLD ITEM OPEN
AND EXPLORE DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES.
SO THE DEPARTMENT CAN MANAGE
CALIFORNIA'S FISH AND WILDLIFE
RESOURCES FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS
THANK YOU.
VETERAN GREG HOMES WITH THOSE
CONSERVANCY A WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT MODERN STABLE
MANAGEMENT EFFICIENT WILDLIFE
AND ECOSYSTEMS.
MERITS THE.
BOTH THE PRIORITY AND THE
STABILITY REFLECTED IN THE
ADMINISTRATIONS OF BUDGET
PROPOSAL SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
IT. THANK YOU.
TOM OUT OF SOME OF THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
RIGHT NOT TO SPEAK AGAINST THE
NEED FOR MORE FUNDING AT THE
DEPARTMENT BUT CONCERNED OPPOSED
TO THE TIRE FEET DIVERSION. A
THOUGHT THAT YOU HAVEN'T THIRD
HEARD ON THE NEXUS ISSUE.
ARE ON THAT ISSUE.
.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT ITS
CARS THAT WREAKED SUCH HAVOC ON
OUR WILDLIFE'S NOT THE TIRES ON
THOSE CARS.
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
AARON READ REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HIGHWAY PATROLMAN.
A FIRST FOLLOWED ME SAY WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST RESPECT FOR THE
SCIENTISTS THAT WORK IT FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
WE SUPPORT THEM GETTING THE
FUNDING BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THE
NBA'S AN APPROPRIATE SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR.
DEPARTMENT
OF WE WOULD SUPPORT ANY OTHER
SOURCES.
THE GENERAL FUND IS PROVIDED
ONLY A SMALL PORTION OF THEIR
BUDGET IT SEEMS KIND OF CRAZY
THAT WE DON'T LOOK TOWARDS AT
SOURCE SINCE THERE'S A HUGE
BUDGET SURPLUS.
THIS YEAR GRANTED THEIR YEARS
IT'S WIENER BUT DURING THE LEAN
YEARS HE DIDN'T GO THROUGH ANY
LAYOFFS NO EMPLOYEES WERE LAID
OFF. OF THAT THEY DID SPACE CUTS
THAT'S FOR SURE SO WE SUPPORT
THEM BEING MADE WHOLE BUT THE
NBA COUNT IS VERY TENTATIVE LET
ME JUST SAY MY FORTY YEARS. OF
REPRESENTING THE HIGHWAY PATROL
ASSOCIATION.
ALMOST ALL OF THOSE YEARS THE
VOTE REQUIRED WAS TWO THIRDS
VOTE AND THE THE RESPONSIBILITY
FELL TO THE ASSOCIATION TO TRY
TO INCREASE THAT. AMOUNT A YEAR
AFTER YEAR AND IT WAS A HEAVY
LIFT.
AND IS ONCE AGAIN BECOME A HEAVY
LIFT BECAUSE A CAR TAX IS
INCREASING WITH THE PASSAGE OF
SB ONE WE NOW HAVE AN ADDED TAX
IN ADDITION TO THE TWELVE CENTS
PER GALLON. WE HAVE AN ADDED TAX
ON CARS IN ADDITION TO THE
VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEE SO
THERE'S REALLY. A THREE
DIFFERENT FUNDS TO GET THE NBA A
LICENSE OF MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT.
THE VLF VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
WHICH IS A PERSONAL PROPERTY
TAXPAYER CAR IN THE THIRD TAXES
PART OF SP ONE.
SO IT'S BECOME A MUCH HARDER
LIFT IF I MAY JUST QUOTE TWO
SHORT SENTENCES FROM YOUR
ANALYSIS.
ON PAGE.
EIGHTEEN.
WHERE DISCUSSES THE NBA CAO
THE SECOND PARAGRAPH SAYS
FURTHER THIS ACCOUNT HAS BEEN
UNDER PRESSURE IN RECENT YEARS
AND WOULD HAVE A PROJECTED
SHORTFALL?
IF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DID NOT
INCLUDE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AND PROPOSALS TO SHIFT
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
PREVIOUSLY FUNDED. FROM THE NBA.
TO LEASE REVENUE BONDS.
THESE AT THIS ADDED PRESSURE ON
THE NBA.
COULD POTENTIALLY RESULT
INCREASING FEES ON MOTORS IT
WILL RESULT INCREASING FEES WILL
HAVE TO COME BACK AND GET A
VEHICLE. A.
BLF FOR AN MBA INCREASE AND WILL
PROBABLY HAVE TO DO IT NEXT THIS
YEAR.
OR NO LATER THAN NEXT
BECAUSE THAT AND ALSO THE LEAST
REVENUE BONDS WILL COST HAS OVER
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN INTEREST.
OVER THE LIFE OF FINANCING THESE
PROJECTS
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
OPPOSED TO THAT. SOURCE OF
FUNDING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN
LION FOUNDATION DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT OF ASSUME.
AND
SO AS A PERSON I HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED AS A STAKEHOLDER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT FOR THE ENTIRETY
OF MY CAREER HERE INCLUDING
SPENDING MORE THAN A THOUSAND
HOURS. ENGAGED IN THE VISION
PROCESS WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
DESCRIBED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN. AND I THINK IT'S BECAUSE OF
THE WORK DONE OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS BY THOSE STAKEHOLDERS TO
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER'S NEEDS
AND PRIORITIES ARE SHARED VALUES
WITH RESPECT OFFICIAL MY LIFE.
AND BECAUSE OF THE WORK THE
DEPARTMENT HAS DONE TO WORK WITH
US AND MAKE PROGRESS ON OUR
VISION THAT YOU HAVE A LETTER
AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE IT ALL GET
IT TO YOU. THAT INCLUDES THE
MOST DESPERATE SET OF
ORGANIZATIONS I'VE EVER SEEN
WILLING TO ALIGN THEIR LOGOS AND
I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT I'VE
NEVER SEEN THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND THE
HUMANE SOCIETY UNITED STATES. ON
THE SAME LETTER SO TO WHAT I'VE
HEARD TODAY I'VE HEARD ALMOST
NEAR UNANIMITY OF SUPPORT FOR A
NEED FOR SUSTAINABLE.
FUNDING AND I'VE HEARD A LARGE
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT FOR THE WAY
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS CRAFTED OF
THE PROPOSED AUGMENTATION THE
PRIORITIES THAT HE SAID IN THAT
SO I BEGIN ON BEHALF I HOPE I
HAVEN'T OF ALL THESE GROUPS.
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO CARE
ABOUT CLEAN AIR IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE AMONG THEM. HOW CAN WE BE
HELPFUL IN HELPING SOUTH SHORE
UP INSISTING THE TIRE RECYCLING
FEE INTO THE FUTURE BEYOND
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IN ROLL US IN
THAT EFFORT? LET'S FIGURE OUT
HOW TO FIND SOMETHING THAT WE
ALL AGREE IS A PASSING AND LONG
OVERDUE PARTY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THINK YOU.
JEFF SERIES ON HALF THE U. S.
TIRE MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION
LOWER SYMPATHETIC THE
DEPARTMENT'S POSITION DON'T
BELIEVE THIS THE APPROPRIATE AND
A SOURCE TO FUND IT. IS THE
POWER OF CALIFORNIA TIRE
RECYCLING FEE MANY THE WHOLE
INTENT WAS TO ADDRESS AND OF USE
WHAT HAPPENS TIRES AT THE END OF
THEIR LIFE. SELF OR SYMPATHETIC
THIS IS THE WRONG SOURCE IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DEBBY
BURNHAM WITH FRIENDS OF FISHING
GAME AND I ALONG WITH JENNIFER
SPENT THAT THOUSAND HOURS IS ONE
OF THE ORIGINAL STAKEHOLDERS IN
THIS PROCESS.
I REPRESENT.
HUNTERS AND FISHERMEN AND I
FIND MYSELF IN THE UNIQUE
POSITION OF AGREEING WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE THAT WE
CAN'T FEE OUR WAY OUT OF THIS.
I WAS UP ON ON THE SUB
COMMITTEE THAT DEALT WITH
UNFUNDED MANDATES AND I BELIEVE
THAT THIS BUDGET. ARM BEGINS TO
ALIGN THE.
PRIORITIES OF THE LEGISLATURE
WITH THE FUNDING SOURCES
NECESSARY TO CARRY OUT. THOSE
BUT PRIORITIES AND.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BUDGET
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BILL GAINES ON
BEHALF OF FIFTEEN DIFFERENT
FISHING AND HUNTING
ORGANIZATIONS HERE TO TRADE TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR THE DEPARTMENT FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
PART OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
SERVICE'S TRUSTEE OF OUR PLANT
ANIMAL AND A WILDLIFE RESOURCES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS YES
HUNDREDS AND ANGLERS HAVE SERVED
AS OUR PRIMARY FUNDING SOURCE
FOR MANY MANY YEARS WE DO
BELIEVE IT'S TIME THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. HELP TO PICK UP
THE LOTUS CALIFORNIA GROWS IN
CLIMATE CHANGE SLOWLY CREEPS
UPON US.
IN REGARDS TO ROADS OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT ROAD KILLS
WHICH IS DEFINITELY A VERY
SERIOUS IMPACT ON WILDLIFE.
BUT I'VE HEARD ANYBODY MENTION
THE FRAGMENTATION THAT ROADS DUE
TO HABITAT CORRIDORS ANIMAL
MIGRATIONS AND SO FORTH THERE'S
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT THERE IS
WELL TO OUR WILDLIFE.
AND FINALLY HE IN REGARDS
HUNTERS AND ANGLERS WE WOULD
HAVE TO STRONGLY OPPOSE ANY FEE
OR TAX THAT WAS PLACED UPON THE
COMMUNITY THAT HAS ALREADY
PAYING FAR MORE THEIR FAIR SHARE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT'S ACTIVITIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI WILL BEAR WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WE
WERE A CO SPONSOR OF.
AB EIGHT.
THAT PUT THE TIRE FEEDBACK IN
PLACE OF WERE OPPOSED TO THE
PROVISION OR THE PROPOSAL TO
DIVERT THE TIRE FEE WAY FROM
CALL MORE AIR WHICH IS A
CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH A PROGRAM
THAT. IS HELPING CALIFORNIA
CLEAN UP ITS AIR WE HAVE THE
WORST AIR POLLUTION THE COUNTRY.
TO SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE. AND ALSO ON THE ON OF THE
BACK FILLING ISSUE THE JEWS
EUROPE IS ALREADY PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR MAJOR
CUTS THE CLEAN TRUCK PROGRAM.
AND SO WE THINK THAT THIS HAS A
COMPOUNDING EFFECT ON TAKING
AWAY AVAILABLE RESOURCES FOR
CLEAN AIR PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KORABL SOMEHOW OF
CAL START I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES AT
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CAPPED HOA. THAT'S AGAINST FEW
COALITION AND OTHERS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DAVID
GOLDENBERG ON THE MANAGER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SEA URCHIN
COMMISSION.
I SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL A IT HAS BEEN A STATE
BEFORE BY BY COLLEAGUES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY IT'S
RARE. THAT THE FISHING COMMUNITY
AND ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY
COMES TOGETHER AND THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE RARE OPPORTUNITIES. I
WILL SAY IS ANOTHER.
PART THAT LAST YEAR WE WERE WE
APPEARED HERE BEFORE YOU BECAUSE
IT WAS A THIRTEEN HUNDRED
PERCENT.
PROPOSAL INCREASE FOR LETTING
TAXES AND AT A TIME WHEN WE
COULD REALLY AFFORD IT. THE.
FISHERY THAT I REPRESENT IS AND
HAS REQUESTED A AT DISASTER
ASSISTANCE THROUGH GOVERNOR
BROWN IT'S PENDING. APPROVAL AT
THE.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL LOWEST
SARDINES AND SAM AS WELL AND SO.
IF IF YOU DON'T DO THIS THAT
WILL BE BACK HERE AND THEY BE
TRYNA TAKE IT AT OF THE
FISHERMEN. AS THEIR POCKETS AND
THE CAN LEAST AFFORD IT SO WE
THANK YOU WE ALSO THINK THAT.
THE OTHER FISHERIES AND THE
NATURE OR THE RESOURCES OF THE
PEOPLE AND THE THOSE SHOULD BE
UNBORN BY THE PEOPLE AS WELL AND
IN HARMONY. WITH THE WITH THE
USERS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SILVIUS ALICIA ON BEHALF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY UNIFIE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
WE URGE YOU TO REJECT THIS
REDIRECTION OF TIRE FEE FUNDING
THE DISTRICT IS HOME TO TWENTY
OF THE STATE'S TOP THIRTY MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
CLEANING UP THE AIR IS A
PRIORITY FOR THE DISTRICT IN THE
CARL MOYER FUNDING HAS BEEN
CRITICAL IN HELPING US TO
ACHIEVE CLEANER AIR IN. THE
VALLEY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO AYE TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION ON THE OR. ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO REJECT THIS
REDUCTION FUNDING ON BEHALF OF
THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION OUR INDUSTRY MEMBERS
ALSO USE CARL MOYER FUNDING.
AND.
FOR EQUIPMENT UPGRADES.
AND THIS COMES AT A TIME WHEN
THE STATE HAS INDICATED THAT A
CLEANER GOODS MOVEMENT IS THAT
DIRECTION THAT THEY WANT TO GO
IN AND A PRIORITY SO AGAIN. WE
ASK YOU TO REJECT THIS FUNDING
REDIRECTION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NICK
BUCK ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME WARDENS
ASSOCIATION.
I WANNA THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL MOTTO LIFE.
GAME WARDENS ARE CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST STATEWIDE PEACE OFFICERS.
AND HAVE BEEN PROTECTING OUR
VALUABLE NOW TO RESOURCES AND
PUBLIC SAFETY SINCE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE.
THIS STARTS TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
TOWARD A FIX.
FOR A DECADES LONG ISSUE FOR MY
ENTIRE DEPARTMENT.
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT IF NOT
THIS
WORK WITH US AND ALL THESE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS YOU HEAR THE
SUPPORT.
YOU SEE THE LETTERS
UP TO FIND SOME OTHER WAYS TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOE DIVINE
FROM CLIMATE VISORS ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
WARDENS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE
IT MOVES THE NEEDLE TOWARDS
FUNDING SOME OF THE STATE'S
CONSERVATION PRIORITIES. AND.
YOU KNOW IT HELPS MOVE THE
NEEDLE AND GIVE US SOME THE
THINGS WE NEED HELP DO OUR JOB
WILL BE BETTER. THANK YOU
TRANSPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON PALM BASED NOT ON
BEHALF OF HIS OF OPPOSITE FOREST
TRUST AND WE'RE ALSO STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF FIXING DFW IS BUDGET
ONCE AND FOR ALL IF THE DIRECTOR
AND. THE UNUSUAL.
ALLIANCE OF GROUPS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF A PROPOSAL OF REALLY
DONE A GOOD JOB OF. ARTICULATING
THE CHALLENGE I'VE WON A
FLASHBACK TO WHEN I FIRST ARE
WORKING ON DFW IS BUDGET IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO IT HAS BEEN A
CHRONIC PROBLEM. THE MOST
DYSFUNCTIONAL BUDGET AT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY FOR THE
LAST FIFTEEN OR MORE YEARS AND I
REALLY URGE US TO YOU KNOW TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO.
RECTIFY THESE ONGOING STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS THIS YEAR THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SITE
LOOKS FOR SOME HALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY BUT ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND THIS AFTERNOON. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED I PROPOSAL BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN THE RIGHT AT FIRST STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. YOU
HISTORICALLY CFW HAS BEEN
WOEFULLY UNDERFUNDED.
AND SUBJECTED TO FRANKLY AN
ONGOING SUSTAIN THAT SORT
STARVATION DIET.
WHICH A AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS
TASK OF PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S
THAT'S RESOURCES ARE OFTEN LEFT
FIGHTING FOR SCRAPS DURING THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. THAT WE
CAN ALL CERTAINLY ARGUE ABOUT
THE PREFERRED FUNDING MECHANISM
BUT NO ONE I THINK NO ONE
DISAGREES.
IT WOULD NEED TO FULLY FUND US
DEPARTMENT AN EXCEPTION
IMPORTANT WORK THANKS VERY MUCH.
I'M JANE SANTORUM FROM THE
JILLIAN MOUNTAIN LION PROJECT.
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS POSTAL.
I FROM THE GOVERNOR. OF AND.
THIS PROBLEM OF OF BUDGET
DEFICIT.
HAS GONE ON LONG ENOUGH AND NOW
IT'S TIME TO GET CREATIVE. IF WE
WERE GONNA COME UP WITH ANOTHER
SOLUTION I THINK WE WOULD HAVE
COME UP WITH THAT. ARE OVER THE
YEARS.
AND A IT'S GREATLY NEEDED AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT PASS
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CRAZY THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS.
FOR THIS PARTICULAR ITEM THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS DO
SUPPORT THE OVERALL OBJECTIVES
INVOLVED OR INCORPORATED INTO
THAT AT.
BUDGET CHANGE OPPOSE ALL HOWEVER
WE DO SUPPORT STAFFS
RECOMMENDATION TO KEEP THE ITEM
OPEN JUST TO ALLOW FOR MORE TIME
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE RIGHT
MIX OF FUNDING AND STAFFING DO
RESPONSIBLY SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE FTA A APPROPRIATE TO FINAL
CONTENT BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO
KEEP THIS ITEM. OPENED A AND TO
TAKE SOME TIME TO CONSIDER ALL
THE COMMENTS ON THE TESTIMONY
HEARD TODAY AND THAT WE HAVE ONE
MORE ITEM FOR. DIRECTOR BOTTOM I
THINK MISTER PATTERSON WANT TO
ADD HUNDRED AND YET VERY
QUICKLY.
PERSONAL MISTER BOTTOM.
I AGREE WITH EVERYBODY HERE
SAYS THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT TO
GET THE SKY KIND OF. A.
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING I JUST HAVE
SOUGHT SUCH STRONG OBJECTIONS TO
THE MANNER IN WHICH THEY'RE
GOING ABOUT IT. SO I'M GONNA
JOIN WITH EVERYBODY ELSE WHO
SAYS THIS NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
I ALSO WANT TO SHOW YOU THAT
THERE'S ALL KINDER GENTLER SIDE
TO ME IF YOU DON'T MIND. I'M
GLAD TO HEAR I REALLY AM
APPRECIATIVE. THAT YOUR STAFF
HAS SUPPORTED AN EXTENDED HE
KINGS RIVER FISHERIES MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM. SO ADDITIONAL TEN YEARS
BEYOND ITS EXPIRATION DATE IT'S
VERY SUCCESSFUL IN OUR REGION WE
APPRECIATE IT A GREAT DEAL AND I
DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
ME MR PATTERSON I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE A KINDER GENTLER SIDE.
A AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THIS
MORNING.
OUR OFFICE
THROUGH THE SIGNATURE OF THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF OUR SPUR.
SINCE BOTH YOU AND MR FUNG THE
RESPONSE LETTER TO YOUR QUERIES
ABOUT S. B. EIGHT SIXTY ONE.
WOULD BE GLAD TO SCHEDULE ON THE
SIDE OF FOLLOWING BRIEFING WE
COULD COME BY AND WALK YOU
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE DETAILS.
THANK YOU.
AND ON ISSUE SIX DIRECTOR YOU
HAVE SOME VERY VERY VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS AND YES IT'S HOLD OPEN.
SO.
IT'S A REQUEST FOR ALMOST FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS OF REINCE
PERSIBA AUTHORITY.
AND POSITIONS WHICH WE WOULD
THEN NEGOTIATE A CONTRACT FOR
SERVICES WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES.
TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE AND
OVERSIGHT MANAGEMENT OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECTS RELATED TO
SPECIES ISSUES.
THERE'S A TON OF WORK.
AND IT'S A HOLD OPEN.
IT'S ALL IN THERE GREAT THANK
YOU ALEJO NO CONSENT.
PERFECT
AND THAT FINANCE NOTHING GREAT
DATA ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT
ITEM.
A LOAN COMMENTER.
YOU KNOW.
WE.
THIS ONE.
YEAH ADDITIONAL TIME TO WORK
WITH DEPARTMENT AT FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO ENSURE THAT THAT I'M
RECOMMENDED AT MAMA STAFFING IS
APPROPRIATE TO SUPPORT THAT I'M
ACTIONS RELATED THE STATE WATER
PROJECT THINK GREAT THANK YOU AS
WITH ALL OF OUR ITEMS TODAY WILL
HOLD THAT OPEN. I APPRECIATE TO.
ABOUT YOUR COMMENTS IN YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY THANK YOU SO
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU OUR NEXT
ITEM IS.
ISSUE SEVEN UNDER DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES WERE GONNA
WELCOME THE.
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
BOARD TO PRESENT THIS ITEM. AND.
THEN FOLLOWING THAT WE'LL HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES TO PRESENT ON ISSUES
EIGHT THROUGH TEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LESLIE
GALLAGHER IN THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOD PROTECTION BOARD.
AND I JUST LIKE TO START BY
HARKENING BACK TO WHAT SECRETARY
LAIRD SAID THIS MORNING HIGH
CALIFORNIA IS A PLACE OF NATURAL
DISASTERS. AND CERTAINLY FOR
THOSE OF US WHO LIVE IN THE
FLOOD WORLD EVERY NOVEMBER WE
KIND OF DO THE US AND SAY GEE I
REALLY HOPE WE DON'T HAVE A BAD
FLIGHT YEAR.
I HOPE WE DON'T GET IN
ATMOSPHERIC RIVER THAT HITS US
WHERE THE LEVEES ARE WEAKEST.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE FLOOD
BOARD AS WELL AS THE DIVISION OF
FLOOD MANAGEMENT AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD TO
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM.
SO THAT WE DO NOT HAVE TO LIVE
WITH THAT UNCERTAINTY EVERY
YEAR.
WITH OUR PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
IT'S A VERY MODEST PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU. IT'S A A PCP DOES TO
TRANSFER ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE PROP
PROPOSITION ONE THE FUNDING OF
RICH THE GENERAL FUND. TO
SUPPORT TEN EXISTING POSITIONS.
YOUR STAFF ACCURATELY DESCRIBED
THE BOARD'S GENERAL FUND REQUEST
THIS YEAR.
THESE EXISTING POSITIONSWORK TO
IMPLEMENT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOD PROTECTION PLAN UPDATED
LAST SUMMER AND INCLUDE
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING LEGAL
AND SUPPORT POSITIONS.
AS NOTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN TWENTY TWELVE
THE PETITION THE POSITIONS THAT
WERE FUNDED BY ONE II ARE
PERMANENT AND NECESSARY FOR
ONGOING OPERATIONS AND THE PLAN
DOES HAVE A THIRTY YEAR ROLLING
IMPLEMENTATION.
THEY NEED TO DO STILL EXIST.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND
APPROVAL AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU. ANNIA COMMENTS FROM
LA ISLANDS YES THANK YOU.
AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA WE DO
RECOMMEND APPROVING THIS
PROPOSAL HOWEVER WE ALSO
RECOMMEND SUB THAT YOU ADOPT
SOME ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE OUR MAIN
CONCERN IS THAT YOU APPROVED
SOME POSITIONS LAST YEAR WITH
THREE YEARS OF LIMITED TERM
FUNDING FOR THE. FOR THE BOARD
THIS PROPOSAL IS ONLY TWO YEARS
OF LIMIT TERM FUNDING SO AFTER
TWO YEARS THEY'LL HAVE NINETEEN
POSITIONS WITHOUT FUNDING PERSON
WE WILL COME BACK BEFORE YOU.
FOR FUNDING I THINK THE
INTENTION BEHIND THAT WAS THAT
THEY LOOK FOR OTHER OPTIONS FOR
GENERATING REVENUES TO SUPPORT
SOME OF THAT ACTIVITIES OF THE
BOARD WE THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR YOU TO GET A STATUS
UPDATE. ON THOSE REVENUE
GENERATION ACTIVITIES IN THE
COMING YEAR BEFORE YOU FACE THE
DECISION OF HOW TO FUND THOSE
POSITIONS AGAIN.
THANK YOU EROTIC FREMONT WITH
THAT.
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
I JUST KNOW THE MINISTRATIONS
DOESN'T HAVE ANY ISSUES WITH
PROVIDING AN UPDATE THROUGH
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
AND NO SUPPORT THIRTY IN THE
PROCESS.
OF WORKING ON THAT AS AGREED
UPON BY THROUGH LIMITED TERMS
AND.
NICE WHEN EVERYBODY'S ALL IN
AGREEMENT SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
TO ANY QUESTIONS IS ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE SEVEN.
BUT GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF ROBERT GORE FROM THE
SACRAMENTO AREA OF FLOOD CONTROL
IT AUTHORITY ARM AND TOOK
WELCOME GROUP. OF WE ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH LETTERS YOU
RECEIVED FROM THE OF FLOOD
PROTECTION CAUCUS.
OF ON THE EIGHTH AND PRIOR TO
THAT THE CENTRAL VALLEY OF FLOOD
CONTROL ASSOCIATION. A
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING A TO
APPROPRIATE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS ARE A FOR FOR FLOOD
CONTROL WE POINT OUT THAT SAFE
KID NOW REPRESENTS THE NATION'S
NUMBER ONE.
AT RISK OF FLIGHT AREA AND AND
WE MAKE THIS REQUEST TO FURTHER
PROTECT.
OF A PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH.
WENDY RIGOROUS REPRESENTING
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES ARE AQUA LIKE TO OF
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ITEM.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND TO WITHOUT WILL HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN AND ASK GOOD
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES TO
STEP FORWARD TO HANDLE ITEMS ARE
ISSUES IT THROUGH TOWN.
AND TO A IF. I MIGHT ASK AS PART
OF YOUR PRESENTATION IF YOU
COULD GIVE US A BRIEF.
UPDATE ON THE THE EFFORTS
SURROUNDING KNOW YOUR FULL DAM
OF THE GREAT.
BELOW THEM WILL TAKE THESE ITEMS
COLLECTIVELY IN HERE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE THREE ON A THREE
TEN. OKAY. A GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS CARL IN A MESS AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
I DO KNOW YOU HAVE A FULL AGENDA
AND WOULD LIKE US TO PRESENT
SOME SPECIFIC DETAIL RELATING TO
OUR TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET. BUT IF I MAY
I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY PROVIDE YOU
AN OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT.
THE MISSION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES IS TO MANAGE AND
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S WATER
RESOURCES.
AN UNDERTAKING OUR WORK TO
ACHIEVE THIS TO ACHIEVE THIS THE
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES OVER THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE AND MAINTAINS
OFFICES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WE MAINTAIN DIVISION OFFICES IN
RED BLUFF.
SACRAMENTO FRESNO AND GLENDALE.
THOUGH THE STATE WATER PROJECT
HAS FACILITIES IN THROUGHOUT
NORTHERN CENTRAL AND CALIFORNIA
IN THE COASTAL AREAS THESE
FACILITIES ARE ALL MANAGED FROM
OUR FIELD DIVISIONS LOCATED IN
OROVILLE BYRON GUSTINE
BAKERSFIELD AND CASTAIC.
OUR RESPONSIBILITIES INVOLVED
ENSURING PUBLIC SAFETY THROUGH
OUR DAM SAFETY IN OUR FLOOD
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS.
GUIDING AND PROMOTING STATEWIDE
WATER MANAGEMENT EFFORTS THROUGH
THE PRODUCTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATER PLANT. IN OUR INTEGRATED
REGIONAL WATER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM.
ASSISTING IN WATER USE
EFFICIENCY EFFORTS THE ROBUST
WATER CONSERVATION PROGRAM AND
THROUGH OUR ROLE IN IMPLEMENTING
GROUNDWATER SIXTEEN ABILITY.
AND FINALLY ENSURING IN
COOPERATION WITH OUR SISTER
AGENCIES OF THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE LONG TERM
VIABILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S BAY
DELTA THROUGH CONTINUED
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION.
IMPROVE SCIENTIFIC UNDERSTANDING
AN APPROPRIATE MANAGEMENT OF THE
RESOURCE.
FINALLY WE ALSO OPERATE THE
STATE WATER PROJECT IT'S A
PROJECT THAT PROVIDES DRINKING
WATER TO MORE THAN TWENTY SIX
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. AND
IRRIGATION WATER TO SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
AGRICULTURAL LAND.
AND RELATING TO THIS LAST
RESPONSIBILITY ON THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE MOMENT SURROGATE TO
UPDATE YOU ON WHERE WE ARE WITH
OUR OROVILLE. OF REPAIR AND
RECOVERY EFFORT PLEASE THANK
YOU.
SO AS OF NOVEMBER FIRST TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WORK ON THE MAIN
SPILLWAY WAS COMPLETED FOR PHASE
ONE. OF THAT ENSURED THAT THE
SPILLWAY COULD HANDLE FLOWS THIS
WINTER SHOULD WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY USE IT.
WORK HAS CONTINUED THROUGHOUT
THE WINTER TO FURTHER ARMOR
WHAT'S CALLED THE EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY.
IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR CREWS
COMPLETED THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
SECANT PILE WALL THAT'S DRILLED
INTO THE BEDROOM BEDROCK AT
DEPTHS OF THIRTY FIVE TO SIXTY
FIVE FEET. THIS WILL STOP UPHILL
ROSEN IF THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY
AS EVER NEEDED AGAIN.
UP OROVILLE RESERVOIR IS BEING
OPERATED AT LOWER SURFACED LEVEL
TO FURTHER REDUCE THE RISK.
OF PRECIPITATION AND SNOW MELTS
AHEAD THAT COULD AFFECT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
CONSTRUCTION ON THE MAIN
SPILLWAY WILL CONTINUE IN MAY
DEPENDING ON THE WEATHER. ALSO
WHILE WE LOOK LIKE THE RAIN WE
HOPE IT STOPS AT JUST THE RIGHT
TIME TO ENABLE US TO GET OUT
THERE AND GET THOSE FLOOD
FACILITIES.
BACK ON TRACK.
THAT WORK IS GOING TO INCLUDE
THE DEMOLITION AND
RECONSTRUCTION OF THE UPPERMOST
PORTION OF THE SPILLWAY. FOUGHT
TO BRING IT INTO THE FINAL A
DESIGN.
CREWS WILL ALSO ADD ABOUT TWO
AND A HALF FEET OF STRUCTURAL
CONCRETE ON TOP THE MIDDLE
SECTION OF THIS BILL WAY. OF
THAT'S WHERE WE LAID THE RULER
CONTACTED CONCRETE LAST SEASON
AND.
AND WILL ALSO CONSTRUCT
PERMANENT WALLS ALL ALONG THE
SIDE OF THE.
THE SPILLWAY.
DURING THE SECOND PHASE OF
CONSTRUCTION CREWS WILL ALSO
CONSTRUCTED SPLASH PATTON
BUTTRESS ON THE EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY. AND THE DOWNHILL SLOPE
TOOK TO BETTER BOLSTER THAT THAT
SPILLWAY WILL HAVE THE SAME.
GENERAL RESTRICTIONS ABOUT
GETTING THAT WORK DONE A IN
ADVANCE OF THE FLOOD CONTROL
SEASON OF THAT BEGINS ON ON
NOVEMBER FIRST.
FINALLY.
BECAUSE IT ALSO RELATES TO
OROVILLE HAVE THE STATE WATER
PROJECT IN ALL ASPECTS OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S MISSION. I WANT TO
GIVE YOU A BRIEF UPDATE ON THE
STATE WIDE WATER CONDITIONS
OTHER BEEN MANY QUESTIONS
BREWING OVER THE PAST. FEW
MONTHS ABOUT THE LIKELIHOOD OF A
RETURN TO DROUGHT.
THAT WE HAVE MOST RECENTLY BEEN
EXPERIENCING A BIT OF
PRECIPITATION.
AS YOU KNOW IT'S THE WINTER
MONTHS FROM DECEMBER THROUGH
FEBRUARY THAT NORMALLY PROVIDE
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S ANNUAL
PRECIPITATION. AND IT'S THE
PRIMARY TIME PERIOD FOR THE
GROWTH OF OUR SNOW PACK.
US SO FAR FOR THIS WATER YEAR OF
THIS WINTER RANKS IN THE BOTTOM
TEN AND WETNESS AND IN THE TOP
TEN IN WARMTH.
CONDITIONS ARE DRIER STILL IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE MANY
BASINS HAVE ACCUMULATED ONLY
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THEIR
NORMAL PRECIPITATION.
STREAM FLOW IS ALSO BELOW NORMAL
TWO DO TO THE VERY DRY WINTER.
OUR SNOW PACK IS CURRENTLY ABOUT
A ONE THIRD JUST OVER ONE THIRD
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT. OF AN
AVERAGE WINTER SNOWPACK AND THAT
NORMALLY PEAKS ON THE FIRST OF
APRIL.
PLEASE TRY CONDITIONS ARE
PARTIALLY OFFSET BY LAST YEAR'S
ABUNDANT PRECIPITATION.
WE HAVE A LOT OF WATER IN
STORAGE WITH THE EXCEPTION OF OF
ORVILLE AT WHICH WE'VE OPERATED
AT AN ARTIFICIALLY LOW LEVEL
THAN WE WOULD OTHERWISE
TYPICALLY DO.
.
HISTORICALLY THERE HAVE BEEN
INSTANCES WHERE A WET MARCH I
REALLY OFFSETS A DRY CONDITIONS
LEADING UP TO IT.
FOR THIS PARTICULAR YEAR WHILE
OF THE FIRST TWO WEEKS OF MARCH
HAVE BEEN WET.
IT'S UNLIKELY THAT WE'RE GOING
TO REPEAT THE MIRACLE MARCH OF
THE NINETEEN NINETIES THAT
BROUGHT US OUT OF THAT DROUGHT.
BUT.
WE DO WELCOME THE PRECIPITATION
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT.
OUT.
TWO MORE WEEKS OF WET WEATHER
WILL BRING US OUT OF THAT BOTTOM
TEN DRIVE WATER YEARS BUT IT'S
JUST SIMPLY TOO SOON TO TELL.
WITH THAT.
.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE SPRING
ULTIMATELY PROVIDES THE
DEPARTMENT'S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO TRACK THOSE HYDROLOGICAL
CONDITIONS AS DEMAND FOR WATER
PICKS UP. AND WE ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIANS TO
CONTINUE CONTINUE TO CONSERVE
OUR WATER RESOURCES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE THESE BRIEF OF OF
OVERARCHING COMMENTS UNLESS YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I HAVE WITH
ME. OUR NEW DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE STATE WATER PROJECTS AND OUR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR FLOOD
PROTECTION AND INTEGRATED
REGIONAL WATER MANAGEMENT WITH
ME TO DESCRIBE. BUDGET PROPOSALS
IN MORE DETAIL.
DON'T GIVE UP PLEASE PROCEED.
BUT A GOOD AFTERNOON ERIC COPE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
I'LL BE ADDRESSING ISSUES EIGHT
AND NINE.
AND I THINK YOU'LL TAKE UP
NUMBER TEN. THE ISSUE IT IS A
PROPOSAL REQUESTING A TOTAL OF
THREE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
VARIOUS BOND FUNDS.
TO CLOSE OUT A LOCAL ASSISTANCE
GRANT PROGRAM RELATED TO
FLUTTERS REDUCTION.
THAT FACILITATE MORE EFFECTIVE
TRIBAL PARTICIPATION IN
INTEGRATED WATER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS.
BUT QUARTER GRANT PROGRAM WAS
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND TO HELP FUND PROJECTS
STATEWIDE THAT EXPAND. PLUG
CORRIDORS AND PRESERVE
AGRICULTURAL AND OR WILDLIFE
HABITAT.
PROPOSAL REQUESTS A
REAPPROPRIATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AT A NEWS PROPOSITION
FIFTY FOUR FUNDS THAT ALREADY
EARMARKED IN THE BARN LOFT FOR
THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM.
THIS IS AND HAS BEEN IT'S
SUCCESSFUL AND WELL RECEIVED
PROGRAM OVER THE YEARS. WE'RE
REQUESTING THESE REMAINING FUNDS
TO ADD TO EXISTING FUNDS FOR A
FINAL LE GRAND SOLICITATION
PROPOSAL.
LATER THIS YEAR.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO REQUESTS FIVE
AND THIRTY THOUSAND THE
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN FUNDS TO
SUPPORT STAFF. WHILE WE DO THAT
SOLICITATION AND CLOSE OUT THE
PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION THIS PROPOSAL
REQUEST SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS
FOR GRANTS OR CONTRACTS TO
FACILITATE INCREASED
PARTICIPATION. BY TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS OR COMMUNITIES AND
REGIONAL WATER MANAGEMENT
GROUPS.
I'M ADDITIONAL OUR REGION
ASSISTANCE IS NEEDED TO BUILD
COLLABORATION. AND THE CAPACITY
FOR THE TRIBES TO PARTICIPATE IN
OUR PROGRAMS.
FUNDS MAY ALSO INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES TO ADVANCE PROJECTS
THAT MEET THE WATER MANAGEMENT
NEEDS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES.
SO THAT WAS ISSUE EIGHT.
ISSUE NINE IS IN REGARDS TO THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER RESTORATION
PROGRAM.
THAT'S.
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER REST REST OR A
RIVER PROPOSALS COVER THREE
YEAR.
OF TIME PERIOD I REQUEST SIFTING
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY.
TO RECEIVE FUNDS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY AND FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION A REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY TO.
FOR FUNDS TO RUBY RECEIVED FROM
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
WORK TO BE ACCOMPLISHED BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
THESE FUNDS WILL BE USED TO
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT A COURT
APPROVED SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT TO
RESTORE THE HUNDRED FIFTY MILE
REACH OF SAN JOAQUIN RIVER TO
HELP RETURN.
MY MIGRATORY SALMON TO THE RIVER
SYSTEM.
THIS WILL HELP.
TO CONTINUE THAT RESTORATION
WORK AND MAINTAIN FISH
POPULATIONS IN THE MAIN STEM OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER. AND AT
THE SAME TIME REDUCE OR AVOID
ANY.
ADVERSE FLOOD RISKS AS WELL AS
IMPROVE THE PARKWAY HABITAT
AREAS IN THE FRESNO AREA.
AND THAT'S ALL I HAD ON THOSE
TWO ITEMS. PICK YOU WE HAVE OF
SOME NOT. COMMENTS ON ISSUE TEN.
YEAH. AFTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU
TODAY BUT A JOLA DESMOND STATE
WATER PROJECT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SINCE JULY.
OUR REQUEST FOR THE SEVENTY
FOUR POSITIONS ARE THE BASIC
CORE IS JUST AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AND PUTTING
US IN A POSITION THAT WE CAN
MODERNIZE AND SUSTAIN. THE STATE
WATER PROJECTS SO THAT IT CAN
MEET ITS WRITTEN NEEDED
RELIABILITY AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO OUT OF THAT WE'RE REQUESTING
POSITIONS TO. BE ABLE TO HANDLE
ALL THE ENGINEERING AND THE
STUDIES THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR
THE AGING INFRASTRUCTURES DAM
SAFETY BEING A. BIG COMPONENT OF
THAT BUT NO DIFFERENT THEN THE
ACT WOULD DUCT
PIPELINES ROTATING EQUIPMENT
SUCH AS THE PUMPS AND GENERATORS
REQUIRED TO MOVE WATER. SO THESE
POSITIONS WILL ULTIMATELY BE FOR
ENGINEERING DESIGN AND THEN A
LARGE POOR AND THEN A PORTION OF
IT. ABOUT TWENTY ONE POSITIONS
OR FOR A NEW OR AVAIL.
OROVILLE CONSTRUCTION OFFICE
NOT THAT IT WILL BE A NEW
OROVILLE A RESERVE OR YOU KNOW
SPILLWAY CONSTRUCTION ONLY
OFFICE IT'S AN OFFICE TO HANDLE.
CONSTRUCTION IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THAT THE STATE THERE ARE
DAMS ABOVE ORVILLE AND THAT NO
OROVILLE ITSELF AND IN SOME OF
THE REGION OFFICES AND INCLUDING
FLOOD. SO THAT OFFICES WILL
ALLOW US TO HAVE A CONSTRUCTION
OFFICE IN THIS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. TO HANDLE THE
PROJECT DOWN THERE ONE IN
SACRAMENTO WOOD HANDLES THE
SACRAMENTO'S.
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY TYPE
PROJECTS AND THEN ORVILLE. NOW
THE OTHER POSITIONS ARE FOR A
YOU KNOW THE ENGINEERING DESIGN
DAM SAFETY WE DO HAVE NEW AND.
REQUIREMENTS ON THAT FROM DE SO
DE AND FOR. SO THAT ALONE IS
GOING TO IS GOING TO RESULT IN
MORE DANCE SAFETY PROJECTS BUT
ON OUR PLATE TODAY WE HAVE
ALREADY SUBSIDES WORK WE'RE
DOING ON THE ACT WITHOUT
PIPELINE ASSESSMENTS TO DO AND
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS THERE. SO
THESE THESE ARE POSITIONS ARE
CORE TO OUR MISSION OF TRYING TO
SUSTAIN THE STATE WATER PROJECT
AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
GREAT THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS SET UP PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUES O. AYE THROUGH THAT'S
FOR LA OPENING MOMENTS FAVORITE
AND THAT STEP FORWARD IF YOU
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT WILL. WILL
BE GETTING TO YOU JUST A SECOND
SAVAGES EIGHT NINE A
CONTINUATIONS OF EXISTING
ACTIVITIES WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS FAIR THIS ISSUE TEN I
THINK WE DREW THE SAME
CONCLUSIONS AS IS NOTED IN YOUR
STAFF. OCT COMMENTS WHERE
CLEARLY THERE'S THERE'S WORKLOAD
FOR THE STATE WATER PROJECT FROM
AGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND AND
INCREASE DAM SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
GENERALLY THE WORKLOAD SEEM
REASONABLE I THINK ARE ARE ONLY
QUESTIONS WERE REALLY. AS
REFLECTING YOUR STAFF COMMENTS
ABOUT THE TIMING OF THE WORK IN
THE OROVILLE AREA RELATED TO THE
FOR CREE LICENSING THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT SO HOLDING
THIS OPEN WILL ALLOW YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON. THE
PROGRESS OF THOSE AGREEMENTS
OVER THE COMING MONTHS.
THANK YOU BERMAN FINANCE THAT
THINK SO I WILL HEAR PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW.
CRAZY THOMPSON WITH THE STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS.
.
FOR THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET ITEM
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS ARE
GENERALLY IN SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NUMBER TEN.
BUT WE DO SUPPORT THAT
RECOMMENDATION TO KEEP THE ITEM
OPENED TO LOOK AT LONGER SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE OUR DIALOGUE
WITH YOU TO. WORK THROUGH THE
STAFFING AS WELL AS THE TIMING
OF THE STAFF AT AS WHETHER BE
PERMANENT SHORT TERM AND AT.
JUST THE OVERALL NEED SO AND
AGAIN SUPPORT THE OVER ARCHING
NEED AT THAT PROPOSAL BAD WE ASK
FOR MORE TIME THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE BAKER
WITH THEIR IN WRITTEN ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT WE REPRESENT THE
ENGINEERS THAT WORK AT THEIR
APARTMENT AND WE AGREE WITH THE.
ADMINISTRATION THAT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL ENGINEERING POSITIONS
NEEDED TO DO THE A DM SAFETY
INSPECTIONS AND CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT. AND DESIGN OF THE
AGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOR
THIS REASON SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL HAVE AS WE WILL
HOLD THAT OPENED UP ALL THOSE
ITEMS OPEN AS WE TRANSITION TO
OUR NEXT ITEM ISSUE ELEVEN.
THERE ARE ABOUT A HUNDRED
PEOPLE OUTSIDE WHO ARE I THINK
MOST OF THEM WAITING FOR ISSUE
TWELFTH.
.
BUT IF YOU'RE.
FINISHED WITH YOUR BUSINESS HERE
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ROOM
FOR AS MANY OF THEM AS POSSIBLE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BELIEVE IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO.
AND TO A.
SO WITH THIS SIR.
ISSUE ELEVEN I'M HOPING TO
UNDERSCORE THE DIRE WATER
CHALLENGES IN THE STATE.
OF THAT WEEK THAT WE FACE THAT
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROPOSAL WHICH IS BEING
CONSIDERED BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
SEEKS TO RESOLVE SIMILAR WATER
CHALLENGES HOWEVER IT WOULD NOT
SOLVE MANY OF THE ASSOCIATED
IMMEDIATE NEEDS MANY COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM DRIED
WELLS. AND FAILING SEPTIC
SYSTEMS AND I'D LIKE TO INVITE A
FEW STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED AND
AFFECTED BY THIS CRISIS TO
PRESENT ON THIS ISSUE OF OUR
YVES RT SET DOWN WE HAVE. JESSE
US NEITHER WITHOUT SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES.
STEPHANIE BA I GUESS WITH THE
RURAL COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION. AND TO.
SUSAN QUEEN A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MY NAME AGAIN IS JESSIE SNYDER
AND WITH SELF HELP ENTERPRISES
AND WHERE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES THE
EIGHT COUNTIES OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND WE'RE HERE
TO STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BUDGET
REQUEST FOR SOME EMERGENCY.
WATER FUNDS TO SUPPORT IT A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT EFFORTS.
SOUTH OF ENTERPRISES HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE PRIMARY ORGANIZATIONS
RESPONDING TO DROUGHT CONDITIONS
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS WITH STATE
OH YES AND LOCAL OAS AGENCIES.
AND AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT FUNDING
AND DID AS A RESULT OF THE
DROUGHT BEING DECLARED OVER WE
TOOK OVER MOST OF THOSE PROGRAMS
DIRECTLY. WE'VE BEEN RECEIVING
FUNDS FOR THE PAST TWELVE
MONTHS.
TO CONTINUE TO FILL EMERGENCY
WATER TANKS THAT ARE AN INTERIM
SOLUTION THAT ALLOW FOLKS LIKE
SUSAN QUEEN SITTING TO MY LEFT
HERE TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES
WHILE THEY WORK TOWARD A
PERMANENT SOLUTION. THE CURRENT
FUNDING ENDS JUNE THIRTIETH
WHERE BARELY GOING TO CRAWL
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE WITH
SUFFICIENT FUNDS. ARE TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE FOLKS WHO
STILL NEED THOSE TANKS
SO I'M HERE ASKING FOR A AN
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION OF FUNDS
FOR THIS COMING YEAR TO CONTINUE
TO FILL THOSE ESSENTIAL. INTERIM
WATER TANKS.
I IN ADDITION WE'RE WORKING TO
REPLACE THOSE FAILED WATER WELLS
AND WHETHER THAT'S WITH NEW
WELLS OR CONNECTIONS TO
COMMUNITY SYSTEMS WHETHER
EXISTING OR NEW.
THAT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE
PROPOSAL AND IT TAKES A LOT OF
TIME WORKING THROUGH IT FAMILY
BY FAMILY. AND.
AS OF JUNE THIRTIETH.
WE WILL STILL HAVE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FAMILIES ON OUR WAITING
LIST FOR FUNDING AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY OVERSUBSCRIBED WE DO
NOT HAVE ENOUGH FUNDING TO MEET
THE CURRENT LEVEL OF NEED. AND
THAT'S IF WE DON'T GET
ADDITIONAL APPLICATIONS WHICH
I'M SURE WE WILL BECAUSE WELLS
DO CONTINUE TO FAIL.
SO I'M ALSO HERE TO REQUEST
FUNDING TO HELP WITH.
REPLACING THOSE WATER WELLS AS
WELL AS RESPONDING TO SEPTIC
TANK EMERGENCIES WHICH PRESENTE
TERRIBLE PUBLIC HEALTH HAZARD.
AND ARE OFTEN EXPERIENCED BY THE
VERY SAME PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE
WELL FAILURES.
I LIKE TO PASS THE BATON NOW TO
SUSAN QUEEN TO MY LEFT TO TULARE
COUNTY RESIDENTS LIVING IN THE
CITY OF PORTABLE.
BOB I THOUGHT SUSAN QUEEN I LIVE
VIA IN PORTABLE SOUTH OF THE
CITY LIMITS I'M NOT IN THE CITY.
.
I'D WANT TO PUT A FACE ON A
PERSON WHO WENT TO WASH OUR
HANDS AND THERE WAS NO WATER AND
HAS THAT BEEN ANY SINCE AUGUST
OF TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
UMMM I IMMEDIATELY APPLIED AND
GOT HELP OUT WATER. OF TOOK
ABOUT TWO MONTHS TO GET THE TANK
AND THEY BEGIN GIVING ME AND NOT
THEY GIVE THE AT THE AT THAT
TIME WERE ALLOCATED FIFTY
GALLONS PER DAY PER PERSON.
AND THAT WAS A STABLE. ITEM.
THEY HAVE SINCE WHEN THEY WHEN
INTO THEM. AND HANDED OVER TO
SELF HELP ITSELF HELP DIDN'T
HAVE THE FUNDS DID TO MAINTAIN
THAT THEY DROPPED US TO THIRTY
GALLONS A DAY. THAT IS BARELY
SUSTAINABLE.
I LOST ALL MY PLANTS OUTSIDE OF
LOS I TRY TO KEEP TREE ALIVE I.
.
JUST YOU CAN'T WATCH IT EXPLODED
CLOSE I MEAN IT'S IT'S BARELY.
MAKING IT. I'M.
I HAVE BEEN WAITING BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN TOLD SINCE THE BEGINNING
THAT THERE ARE GRANTS.
POSSIBLE TO DEEPEN MY WELL ARE
TOOK UP TO A M.. ANTIQUE WELL I
LIVE IN A MIKE GREAT UNCLES
PARENTS HOUSE BILL EIGHTEEN
EIGHTIES AND THERE'S SOME THINGS
ON THE PROPERTY THAT HAVE BEEN
USED FOR DARN NEAR THAT LONG.
AND.
.
SO I BEEN WAITING BECAUSE I
DIDN'T I DON'T HAVE FUNDS SO I
DIDN'T WANNA TAKE OUT THE LOAN
AND HAVE IT. DONE AND THEN FIND
OUT THERE WAS A GRAND ABIDE
WAITED. AND NOW I'M IN DEBT WHEN
MY KIDS AGAIN PAID OFF.
.
SO I THAT'S MY BIGGEST THING IS
JUST TO ACTUALLY PUT A FACE ON A
PERSON AND I ASK YOU IN ALL OF
YOUR FUNDING.
PLEASE PUT PEOPLE FIRST.
I KNOW WE JUST HAD A LOT OF
OTHER ISSUES WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES WOULD LOVE THE
ENVIRONMENT WE LOVE THE ANIMALS
BUT.
I JUST WANT THE COMMITTEE TO
THINK OF PEOPLE AND THEIR
IMMEDIATE NEEDS AB WATERS PRETTY
BIG ONE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMBER CARE WITH
DO YOU RURAL COMMUNITY
ASSISTANCE CORPORATION.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US THIS
AFTERNOON I JUST WANNA GIVE YOU
A BRIEF HISTORY OF WHAT OUR
CECE'S BEEN DOING.
HISTORICALLY TO HELP WITH THIS
PROBLEM.
WE ORIGINALLY GOT FUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OTHER MY
OTHER AGENCIES IS WALL TO FIND A
PILOT PROGRAM TO CREATE A.
I'M WATER BOTTLE FILLING STATION
ACCESS AND WATER QUALITY.
PROGRAM FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE ORIGINAL
PILOT PROGRAM WAS IN KERN COUNTY
AND.
TULARE COUNTY.
I'M I'M SORRY KERN COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND WE'VE
CENTS.
MOVED TO.
I'M EXPAND THE PROGRAM
STATEWIDE.
PART OF THE CURRENT SITUATION
WITH ITS CURRENT DRINKING WATER
IN SCHOOLS FUNDING WE HAVE MOVED
TO SIX COUNT SIXTEEN COUNTIES
INCLUDING SISKIYOU FROM OUR
NORTHERN BORDER ALTHOUGH IT'S
IMPERIAL AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
I'M TWENTY SEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS
FIFTY SEVEN SCHOOLS AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY SERVING SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
STUDENTS WITH THAT PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM IMPLANTS WATER
QUALITY AND ACCESS IS CHEAP
ISSUES
TO THE SCHOOL SITES AND HOPES TO
FUND WHAT BOTH FILLING STATIONS
WATER QUALITY IN TERMS
SOLUTIONS.
EXAGGERATES HELP SUPPORT THOSE
SCHOOLS.
AND ACCESS REFERS TO THE NEED TO
ADDRESS WATER INFRASTRUCTURE IN
SCHOOLS CONDITIONS ADA
COMPLIANCE AND SOME SITES
INSTALLING WATER FOUNTAINS FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
ARE UNMET NEEDS.
ARE AS FOLLOWS.
NEW MANDATORY LEAD TESTING IS
GREAT STEP FORWARD BUT WHAT TO
SCHOOLS DO WHEN THEY FIND THE
PROBLEMS WHERE THEY DO WHEN THEY
FIND THE CONTAMINATION.
I'M CURRENTLY OF THEIR AUTHORS
VERY LITTLE FUNDING TO MOVE TO
IMPLEMENTATION TO IN TERM
SOLUTIONS AND TO LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS.
LARGER DISTRICTS ARE OPT TO USE
MOST OF THIS THIS CURRENT
FUNDING.
I'M THERE WILL STILL BE A NEED
FOR SMALL DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TO CONTINUE TO BE
FUNDED.
ANOTHER UNDERFUNDED ISSUE IS THE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH WE
CONTINUE TO SEE THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF SCHOOLS THAT AREN'T.
I'M APPLYING FOR THIS PROGRAM
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE WORD
OUT.
THERE'S THEY HAVE LOW STAFF SO
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO GO OUT AND SEEK
FUNDING LIKE MUCH SMALL MUCH
LARGER DISTRICTS HAVE THE THE
ABILITY TO DO. SO HAVING A HARD
TIME ACTUALLY GETTING OUT THERE
AND AND LETTING THE SCHOOLS KNOW
THAT THIS FUNDING IS AVAILABLE.
SO WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
YOU KNOW COLD CALLING CALLING
SCHOOLS DIRECTLY IN LETTING THEM
KNOW THAT THIS FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE AND HELPING THEM TO
GET ACCESS TO THE CURRENT
FUNDING.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
CONTINUE WITH THE DIRECT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO REACH
OUT TO THESE COMMUNITIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE ISSUES GET
SOLVED.
MAKE IT.
UP GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR BLOOM AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS EILEEN SO BACK I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. I'M AND WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU
TODAY.
ABOUT THIS INFORMATION ITEM AND
THE THREE TOPICS.
YOU'VE LOST A.
FOR.
SUMP DATES IN PROGRESS.
ON WHAT THE STATE WATER PORTS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO.
SO WITH RESPECT TO EMERGENCY
DRINKING WATER SINCE THE
DECLARATION OF THE DROUGHT
EMERGENCY AND TWENTY FOURTEEN
THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS FUNDED
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
EMERGENCY DRINKING WATER
PROJECTS.
THE TOTAL COST OF AROUND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS
TO ADDRESS BOTH WATER SORT
SHORTAGES AND CONTAMINATION.
OF THE PROJECTS THAT WERE FUNDED
INCLUDED WELL RIP REPAIR AND
REPLACEMENT HOLD WATER.
EMERGENCY INNER TIES TREATMENT
SYSTEMS AND BOTTLED WATER.
DURING THE DROUGHT WE
COORDINATED OUR FUNDING EFFORTS
CLOSELY WITH DEPARTMENT OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND PART OF
WATER RESOURCES.
AND WE REALLY WANT TO SHOUT OUT
LOCAL AGENCIES IN OUR NONPROFIT
TIME PARTNERS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE I'M
COMMUNITY THEY WERE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO IDENTIFYING SPECIFIC
NEEDS. AND TO PROVIDE AND THE
ACTUAL FUNDING TO THE IMPACTED.
COMMUNITIES AND HOUSEHOLDS AND
INEFFICIENT.
AND FAIR MANNER.
I'M IN SOME COMMUNITIES THE NEED
FOR BOTTLED WATER OR HAULED
WATER HAS BEEN AND WILL BE
ONGOING FOR MANY YEARS.
I'M.
PERMANENT SOLUTIONS.
.
BASS A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES SUCH
AS THE COMPLEX CONSOLIDATION
PROPHECIES AND THE LACK OF
TECHNICAL MANAGERIAL OR
FINANCIAL CAPACITY OF
COMMUNITIES. TO OPERATE AND
MAINTAIN SYSTEMS
A CHAIR MARCUS IS GOING TO TOUCH
ON ON ON THESE ISSUES IN THE
NEXT PRESENTATION I'M COMING
BEFORE YOU. UP TODAY.
TO SUPPORT TIME SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS AND INDIVIDUAL
HOUSEHOLDS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF THE STATE WATER
BOARD STARTED A PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE WELL REPLACEMENT AND
REPAIR.
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANT
FUNDS TO THREE NON PROFITS AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND WE RECENTLY
PUT AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TOWARD PORTS THAT
PROGRAM.
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET
ELECT BUDGET ACT GENERAL FUNDS
ON THAT WERE APPROPRIATE FOR
THAT PURPOSE.
I'M YOU'VE HEARD TODAY FROM THE
NON PROFITS ABOUT AND WHAT THE
DEMAND I'M FOR THOSE FUNDS TIME
HAS BEEN.
WELL THE CLEAN UP AN ABATEMENT
FUN CAN BE USED TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE ONGOING URGENT DRINKING
WATER NEEDS. THAT ACCOUNT IS
USED TO FUND OTHER IMPORTANT.
PROJECTS THAT INCLUDES AND.
.
PROJECTS TO ADDRESS WATER
QUALITY IMPACTS DO DUE TO RECENT
WILD FLOWER FIRE WILD FIRES IN
OUR STATE. I'M SHOULD THERE BE
ANOTHER DROUGHT OR ANY OTHER
UNFORESEEN EMERGENCY.
SITUATIONS IT MAY BE DIFFICULT
FOR US TO TO MEET ALL EMERGENCY
NEEDS FROM THE CLEAN UP AN
ABATEMENT ACCOUNT.
TURNING TO THE ISSUE EVERY
PARENT REPLACEMENT A FAILING
SEPTIC SYSTEMS.
STATE WATER BOARD AGREES THAT
SUCH SYSTEMS AND CAN BE A
SIGNIFICANT GROUND WATER QUALITY
PROGRAM.
AND PUBLIC HEALTH HEALTH THREAT.
IN FACT IN TWENTY TWELVE WE
ADOPTED THEM EIGHT.
A.
THE ON SITE WASTE WATER
TREATMENT SYSTEM POLICY.
TO PROVIDE THE POLICY AND
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FOR
ADDRESSING THOSE THREATS.
I'M IT FORMALIZES A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN LOCAL AGENCIES AND OUR
REGIONAL WATER BECAUSE WATER.
QUALITY CONTROL BOARDS AND
ESTABLISHES MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS TO DEVELOP A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SYSTEMS
IMPACTS ON WATER QUALITY.
AND TO ALLOW WHAT LOCAL AGENCIES
TO COME UP WITH A PLAN.
THAT WE ARE STILL IN THE.
PROCESS OF.
.
DEVELOPING A COMPREHENSIVE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT BUT NEVER THE LESS
THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS
PROVIDED FUNDING TO CONVERT
INDIVIDUAL SEPTIC SYSTEMS.
TO CENTRALIZE WAIT WASTEWATER
COLLECTION AND TREATMENT SYSTEMS
AND SEVERAL COMMUNITIES.
OUR FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM IS
AVAILABLE THROUGH BOTH ARE CLEAN
WATER STATE CLEAN WATER STATE
REVOLVING FUND. AND PROPOSITION
ONE GRANT DOLLARS. UP FINALLY
ON.
THE LAST ISSUE WE WERE ASKED TO
DISCUSS IS OUR DRINKING WATER
FOR SCHOOLS PROGRAM AS YOU KNOW.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ESTABLISH THE DRINKING WATER FOR
SCHOOLS PROGRAM. AN ADDITIONAL
HALF MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
APPLICANTS.
THIS PROGRAM IS DIFFERENT FOR US
BECAUSE IT INVOLVES NOT ONLY. ON
PROVIDING SAFE WATER FOR SCHOOLS
BUT ALSO.
EXCEPT HOW ACCESSIBLE THE WATER
IS FOR STUDENTS.
SO WE ADOPTED GUIDELINES IN MAY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND HER AND
BEGAN THE PROCESS FOR SOLICITING
PROJECTS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WE'VE CONDUCTED I'M WORKSHOPS
AND.
OUTREACH SINCE WE HAVE TIME.
RESERVE THIS INITIAL APPLICATION
PERIOD FOR US SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHICH
HAVE THE MOST CHALLENGE. AND
PUTTING TOGETHER AND GRANTS AND
PROPOSALS AS HAS BEEN NOTED.
AND WE.
HAVE.
ASSIGNED TWENTY SIX TECHNICAL
I'M.
ASSISTANCE AND. I RESPONDED TO
TWENTY SIX TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
REQUESTS IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
ARM PROPOSALS BY THOSE I'M
ENTITIES. WE EXPECT THE FIRST
APPLICATIONS FOR FUNDING TOOK A
BRIBE THIS MONTH.
WE'RE SEEING AN INCREASE IN
REQUESTS FOR BOTTLED WATER FROM
SCHOOLS AS A RESULT OF TESTING.
TESTING RESULTS FOR ONE TWO
THREE TCP AND LETTER COMING IN.
AND AS WE.
AS WE MOVE FURTHER FURTHER AND
FURTHER AND THAT PROCESS WE AND
EXPECT.
THAT MORE SCHOOLS WILL NEED TO
TREAT FOR LEAD CONTAMINATION.
SINCE THIS PROGRAM IS JUST
GETTING STARTED AND THE EXTENT
OF THE POTENTIAL CONNECT
CONTAMINATIONS XIN CONCERNS ARE
JUST BEING IDENTIFIED WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A CLEAR AND NOTION OF
THE DEMANDS BUT I I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT. THEY ARE THERE.
THANK YOU AND FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
PICK YOU THINK YOU FOR THE VERY
ILLUMINATING PRESENTATIONS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
DICE.
I'M I'VE JUST LEARNED THAT OF
THERE'S ANOTHER COMMITTEE THAT
EXPECTS TO HAVE THIS ROOM IN
ABOUT TEN MINUTES WERE TRYING TO
WORK THAT OUT.
I AND I WANT TO MOVE AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY.
FORWARD AS WE CAN INTO OUR NEXT
ITEM IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THIS INFORMATIONAL ITEM.
THANK A OKAY.
WE DO HAVE A LITTLE.
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS AS CONCISE AS
POSSIBLE I KNOW YOU WANNA BE
HEARD ON THE NEXT ISSUE TO.
JONATHAN NELSON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET ITEM IS A
COMPLIMENT TO THE NEXT ITEM
THINKING.
MY CLAIBORNE OF LEADERSHIP A
SHIP COUNSEL AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS ITEM AND JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THAT DROUGHT ISN'T
OVER IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WORKING WITH NEARLY DRY WELLS
AND CARRUTHERS AND FRESNO COUNTY
SO THERE'S A NEED THANKS.
SHE ONLY FLAYED GOING HEAR
REPRESENTING POLICY LINK ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT I AM ALSO HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING MYSELF AS A
PARENT YOU KNOW YOU S. THE WHERE
WE HAVE HAD A SERIOUS LEAD
PROBLEM IN OUR SCHOOLS. AND WE
KNOW THIS.
PROPOSAL IS A DROP IN THE
BUCKET COMPARED TO WHAT WE
EXPECT SCHOOLS WILL NEED.
BUT WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE.
SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR ALL OF
OUR CHILDREN HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS SERVE VERY
APPRECIATED AND VERY
INFORMATIVE.
OUR LAST ISSUE IS ISSUE TWELVE.
WHEN WILL THIS DATA.
HAD RIGHT INTO IT. BEARING IN
MIND AGAIN THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF.
OF PEOPLE WHO'D LIKE TO ADD
THEIR COMMENTS.
HONDA WHAT IS PROVEN TO BE A
SOMEWHAT TRAVERSAL PROPOSAL FROM
THE GOVERNOR.
WELCOME DIRECTOR MARCUS
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN. YOU COULD
MAKE.
YOUR PRESENT A BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION OF THE GREAT.
TERRIFIC.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON HAPPY RAINY
DAY.
AND THE DAY IT'S RAINING IS A
HAPPY DAY.
AYE THEY ALSO IT'S PIE NAY
WHICH IS TOTALLY ALSO AND I WON
PRO THEIR.
RIVER THAT MEANS.
IT I'M VERY GLAD TO BE BACK FOR
THIS NEXT PHASE IN OUR JOINT
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THE ACCESS OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO CLEAN SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
AND TO IMPLEMENT CALIFORNIA'S
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER POLICY.
WITH ME TODAY IS GERM
POLYGAMISTS ARE DEPUTY DIRECTOR%
FOR THE DRINKING WATER PROGRAM
WHO IS A VETERAN DIRECTOR OF OUR
DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE OTHERS IN THE
AUDIENCE TO ASSIST WITH YOUR
QUESTIONS INCLUDING LESLIE
LOUDON THE CURRENT DIRECTOR WHO
YOU JUST SAW.
SINCE PASSAGE OF THE HUMAN
RIGHTS WATER ACT IN YOUR
DIRECTION TO AGENCIES TO
CONSIDER THAT POLICY AND ALL
THAT WE DO WE'VE MADE SOME
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS.
WITH YOUR HELP.
AS YOU KNOW OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE WORKED
WITH THE GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED
THE BOARD WITH NEW TOOLS AND
AUTHORITIES. TO ADDRESS SAFE
DRINKING WATER PROBLEMS.
STARTING IN JULY TWENTY FOURTEEN
TRANSFERRING THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
THE STATE WATER BOARD. TO ALLOW
FOR ONE AGENCY TO BE RESPONSIBLE
SOURCE TO TAP DIVIDE ONE STOP
SHOPPING FOR COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. FOR THEIR FUNDING
NEEDS AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
SINCE THAT TIME FOR EXAMPLE THE
PROP ONE
CAPITAL FUNDING FOR DRINKING
WATER AND WASTEWATER TREATMENT
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND THE ABILITY TO USE THOSE
DOLLARS FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AS WELL.
THE CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF
SUSTAINABLE WATER SOLUTIONS TO
FOCUS ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR NEEDS. THE
AUTHORITY TO ORDER CONSOLIDATION
OF SMALL SYSTEMS WITH LARGER
SYSTEMS AND THE TOOLS TO HELP
WITH VOLUNTARYCONSOLIDATION.
LIMITATIONS ON THE ABILITY.
CREATE THE PROLIFERATION OF NEW
CYSTS SMALLER SYSTEMS.
THE ABILITY TO HELP PROVIDE
DRINKING WATER ASSISTANCE TO
SMALLER COMMUNITIES IN DOMESTIC
WELL OWNERS IN CERTAIN CASES.
PARTICULARLY GOING TO THE
DROUGHT EAST PORTABLE IS PERHAPS
THE BEST EXAMPLE OF THIS AND ONE
WHERE WE NOW HAVE STE CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER FLOWING INTO
HUNDREDS OF HOMES. THAT WITHOUT
WATER AND ALL DURING THE DROUGHT
LET ALONE WITHOUT CLEAN WATER
FOR MUCH LONGER TIME. AND YOU
GAVE US THE ABILITY BUT NOT YET
THE FUNDING TO HIRE AN
ADMINISTRATOR TO MANAGE
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS. THAT
SIMPLY LACK THE MANAGERIAL
TECHNICAL OR FINANCIAL ABILITY
TO MANAGE THOSE TREATMENT
FACILITY SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR ALL OF THAT AND BECAUSE OF
THOSE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP
MANY COMMUNITIES AND ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF HELPING MORE MANY
MORE. WE SPEND ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION IN GRANTS
AND LOANS TO HELP SCORES OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WILL
CONTINUE TO USE THESE TOOLS IN
COMBINATION AS WE CAN THERE MANY
MORE WE CAN'T HELP.
WITHOUT OR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE FUNDING SOURCE.
SO DESPITE OUR EFFORTS MANY
LOCAL WATER SYSTEMS IN THE STATE
PARTICULARLY SERVING SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER THEIR
CUSTOMERS AND WE HAVE OVER THREE
HUNDRED SYSTEMS THAT ARE UNDER
OUR BASIC JURISDICTION THAT'S.
THOSE WHO SERVE OVER TWENTY FIVE
FOR SIXTY DAYS OR MORE PER YEAR.
WE'VE UNTIL MANY MORE THAT ARE
SMALLER THAN THAT.
IT FIT LETTER BELOW OUR
TRADITIONAL LEGAL JURISDICTION
OF COURSE WE HAVE MANY MORE
WITH.
DOMESTIC WELLS THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP
THOUSANDS MORE SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN THAT WE COULD HAVE
BEFORE. BUT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS
IN MANY MANY COMMUNITIES ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA NOT JUST IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. STILL DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN RELIABLE
DRINKING WATER UP WHICH TOO MANY
OF US IS THE PREEMINENT WATER
ISSUE OF OUR TIME. AND ONE THAT
WE AS CALIFORNIANS CAN
ABSOLUTELY DO SOMETHING ABOUT.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING AND THERE'S A
LOT MORE WE CAN DO TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND HAVE A GREAT TEAM
OF HIGHLY MOTIVATED AND TALENTED
PEOPLE WHO ARE PASSIONATE ABOUT
MAKING THAT DIFFERENCE.
BUT WE CAN'T DO WITHOUT MORE
HELP SO WE'RE BACK FOR THAT
HELP.
AS I'VE TAKEN PAINS TO FLAG EACH
TIME I'VE BEEN HERE SINCE WE
CONTEMPLATED BRINGING THE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM OVER. THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT REMAINING
CHALLENGE WILL BE THE LACK OF A
STABLE FUNDING SOURCE FOR LONG
TERM. OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE
FOR DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE JUST SIMPLY
LIMITS THE ABILITY TO ACCESS THE
ADDITIONAL CAPITAL COSTS FOR
HUNDREDS OF SMALL SYSTEMS AND
DOMESTIC WELLS.
AND THEY CAN'T BE CONSOLIDATED
IT IT IT'S FOR LARGER SYSTEM BUT
ALSO HINDERS OUR ABILITY TO
CONSOLIDATE.
COMMUNITIES CAN'T AFFORD TO
MAINTAIN THEIR OWN SYSTEM AND
THEY'RE CURRENTLY SERVING
DRINKING WATER THAT DOESN'T MEET
HEALTH STANDARDS.
WILL MOVE AHEAD BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE AND WE
HAVE TO GO IN I KNOW YOU'VE
LOOKED AT THIS ISSUE BEFORE.
KEY THING THERE IS WITHOUT THE
O. N. M. WE CAN'T USE THE
ADMINISTRATOR AUTHORITY YOU'VE
GIVEN US THAT NOT ONLY CAN HELP
MANAGE. EXISTING SYSTEMS WE CAN
HELP
TO FACILITATE THE CONSOLIDATION
PROJECT PROCESS WHICH WE WANT TO
DO MUCH MORE OF.
SO BACK TO ASK FOR HELP WITH THE
BIGGEST MISSING PIECE WHICH IS
TO MAKE. THE PUBLIC POLICY
CHOICE AND IT IS A CHOICE.
THAT WE IS CALIFORNIANS.
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
AND THAT IS THE INTEREST OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO ASSURE THAT WE
ALL HAVE ACCESS.
CLEAN SAFE AND AFFORDABLE WATER
BY GIVING US THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THAT STABLE FUNDING FOR
OPERATION TO MAKE.
TO ADDRESS THIS CHALLENGE THE
GOVERNOR'S FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET.
CONTAINS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ESTABLISHING A NEW SPECIAL FUND
FOR THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
ASSIST COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
PAYING FOR SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM COSTS OF OBTAINING ACCESS
TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
STATUTORY LANGUAGE CONSISTENT
WITH THE POLICY FRAMEWORK OF S.
B. SIX TWENTY THREE INTRODUCED
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN LEGISLATIVE SESSION. TO
ESTABLISH A PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES GRANTS LOANS AND
ADMINISTRATOR CONTRACTS OR
SERVICES TO ASSIST ELIGIBLE
COMMUNITIES AND HOUSEHOLDS IN
SECURING ACCESS TO SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING. DRINKING
WATER THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
ACCELERATE OUR CONSOLIDATION AND
OTHER EFFORTS. AND MOVE TOWARDS
THE MOST EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS FOR THE MOST
COMMUNITIES.
PARTICULAR BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
FOR FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR THE
STATE WATER BOARD IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
TO TAKE OUR INITIAL STEPS
TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
NEW PROGRAM. INCLUDING ONE
pDEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING FEE
COLLECTION SYSTEMS TO CONDUCTING
AN ASSESSMENT TO ESTIMATE THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING NEEDED TO
ASSIST WATER SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE.
AND THREE DEVELOPING AND MAKING
AVAILABLE A MAP OF HIGH RISK
AQUIFER'S USES DRINKING WATER
SOURCES TO BE ABLE TO TARGET OUR
RESOURCES MOST EFFECTIVELY.
YOU HAVE THE BILL BEFORE YOU AND
YOUR STAFF SUMMARIES AND ALL THE
OTHER FOLKS HERE SOMEWHAT
SUMMARIZE ALL THE DETAIL.
I'M JUST HOPING THAT TODAY
YOU'LL HEAR BUSTED DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT THE OBJECTIVE TO DO THIS
TODAY. AND MORE PERHAPS ABOUT
THE DETAILS WHICH I URGE YOU
SIMPLY TO DECIDE AS SOON AS YOU
POSSIBLY CAN. AND DECIDE TO MOVE
FORWARD EVERY YEAR EVERY MONTH
EVERY WEEK EVERY DAY WE GO
WITHOUT THIS FUNDING PEOPLE
CAN'T TURN ON THEIR TAPS WITHOUT
FEARS THAT WE COULD HAVE HELPED.
WITH THAT FUNDING.
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO SAY AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T THINK IT'S
WAITING TO SAY IT'S ALL STOP
THERE AND I KNOW HAVE OVERDONE
IT IN PREVIOUS I'M HEARING SO AS
I SAID I. USED UP ALL MY LETTERS
MAYBE TWO YEARS AGO I CAN'T
REMEMBER WHEN THAT WAS SO HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY. QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE OF COURSE ALONG WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND OTHERS
THANK YOU FOR THE A
PRESENTATION.
WE HAVE US SOME COMMENTS FROM
ALEJO. THANK YOU CHAU MIGHT WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND.
WHO WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE FACES
A POLICY DECISION HERE ABOUT
WHETHER TO INCREASE CHARGES ON
CERTAIN PRODUCTS AND CONSUMERS
IN ORDER AND TO IMPLEMENT A NEW
PROGRAM? AND WE'VE IDENTIFIED
THREE ISSUES FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER AS IT DELIBERATES
OVER IT THIS POLICY DECISION.
ABOUT WHAT THE CONSISTENCY WITH
THE STATE'S HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
POLICY. UNCERTAINTY MATT
ESTIMATED REVENUES AND COSTS IN
THE PROGRAM.
AND ALSO CONSISTENCY WITH THE
POLLUTER PAYS PRINCIPLE SOME
SKIN GOV AT THESE BRIEFLY.
I'M WE BELIEVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT WITH THIS
STATE STATUTORY POLICY THAT
EVERY HUMAN BEING HAS THE RIGHT
TO SAFE CLEAN AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE WATER. FIVE FOR ANY
CONCEPTION AND THE PROPOSAL
WOULD MAKE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER MORE WIDELY
AVAILABLE.
BY THROUGHOUT THE STATE LARGELY
BY PROVIDING FUNDING FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
ACTIVITIES FOR WATER TREATMENT
SYSTEMS. AND SECOND THAT WERE
FOUND THAT THERE'S UNCERTAINTY
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE PROPOSED
REVENUES WILL FULLY ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM. AND IN LARGE PART THIS
IS BECAUSE THE EXTENT OF THE
PROBLEM IS HIGHLY UNCERTAIN
GIVEN THE LACK OF DATA ABOUT THE
NUMBER SMALLER WATER SYSTEMS AND
DOMESTIC WELLS AND. THAT FELT TO
PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING WATER BUT
WE KNOW THAT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD IS PART
OF THE PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE TO
PREPARE AN ANNUAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENT WHICH WOULD. PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE WITH GREATER
CERTAINTY ABOUT THE SCENE IN THE
FUTURE.
THERE'S ALSO UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
THE MATTER OF REVENUE THAT WILL
BE GENERATED UNDER THE PROPOSAL
I PARTICULARLY FROM AGRICULTURAL
ENTITIES THAT BUDGET TRAILER
LEGISLATION ALLOWS. THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
JUST ADD THAT. THE RATE PAYER
CHARGES DOWNWARD AT THE FUNDING
I PROVIDED EXCEEDS FEATURES
DEMANDS.
FOR FOR THE FUNDS ARE THERE IF
THE DEMAND EXCEEDS DEFINING THE
FUTURE ANY INCREASE IN CHARGE TO
HAVE TO BE APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. TO DOES PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY ON THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING MAINLY TO MOVE IT DOWN
OR UP AT REQUIRE VOTER THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE IT UP IF
DEMAND. EXCEEDED THE MATTER
REVENUES THAT ARE PROVIDED UNDER
THE PROPOSAL AND FUTURE. AND
FINALLY.
THIS PROPOSAL MIGHT NOT FULLY
IMPLEMENT THE POLLUTER PAYS
PRINCIPLE IN THE POLLUTED PAYS
PRINCIPLE IS A CONCEPT THAT
THOSE ENTITIES THAT CAUSE
ENVIRONMENTAL HARM.
SHOULD BE RESPONSIVE FOR THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH CLEANING
AND AT THAT CONTAMINATION
TRACTION ADDRESSING THE HARM
DONE.
AND NEEDS PHYSICALLY HERE I'M
TALKING ABOUT NITRATE
CONTAMINATION IN THE GROUND. AND
I IT'S NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR THAT
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT WOULD
BE PROVIDED UNDER THE PROPOSAL
BY AGRICULTURAL ENTITIES WOULD
BE SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE
NIGHT TING NITRATE
CONTAMINATION.
THAT IS COMING FROM THOSE
ENTITIES AND ALSO IT'S NOT
CERTAIN THAT SOME OF THE NITRATE
CONTAMINATION THIS LEGACY
CONTAMINATION FROM GOING BACK
DECADES AND SAID THE PEOPLE THAT
I AM. CURRENT AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCERS DIDN'T BECAUSE THAT
BUT SOME OF THAT FINDS THAT
THERE I WOULD PROVIDE.
THROUGH THESE OUTSIDE THE MAC IN
OUR CHARGE MECHANISMS WOULD BE
USED TO CLEAN UP THAT LEGACY
CONTAMINATION SO THOSE ARE THE
TWO REASONS WE FELT THAT IT
MIGHT NOT FULLY IMPLEMENT THE
POLLUTER PAYS PRINCIPLE. OTHERS
CLOSE BY NOTING THAT THERE IS A
BILL US
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY THREE
THAT DOES LARGELY THE SAME. THAT
THAT SAME THING DISCS UP
PROPOSAL DIES AND IT'S WAS A
LAST HEARD IN ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NO COMMENTS OF ANY QUESTIONS
MISTER BOND.
I HAVE A QUICK BROAD QUESTION.
FIDELIO IS IS IN TERMS OF OTHER
ALTERNATIVES IN TERMS OF HOW TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM SHORT OF
SIX ONE THREE IS THERE.
MAIN DECIDED BALLING THEIR ANY
OTHER COULD HAVE IDEAS.
YEAH AND NOT THAT THEY WERE
AWARE OF IT AT THIS TIME A
EXCITEMENT IT SPECIFICALLY IN
TERMS OF HOW TO FUND IT.
DIDN'T NOT THAT THAT WE'VE SEEN
IDENTIFIED ANOTHER LEGISLATION.
GREAT SO WELL LETS SO.
.
A ASK A ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD ON
THIS ISSUE TO BEGIN TO LINE UP
AND FOUND STEP FORWARD. AS YOU
CAN SEE THERE ARE.
A GOOD MANY OF YOU I'M GOING TO
AS WE DID WITHOUT PRIOR ITEM ASK
YOU ALL. TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
AS CONCISE AS POSSIBLE UP PLEASE
RECOGNIZE THAT I THINK.
WE'VE HEARD THE ARGUMENTS FOR
AND AGAINST.
SO I DON'T THINK YOU NEED TO
ACTUALLY MAKE THOSE ARGUMENTS
SAID TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS.
AT FOCUSED ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORTER OPPOSE AND TO A
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AS NECESSARY
AND IF YOU CAN HOLD YOUR
COMMENTS TO THIRTY SECONDS MANY
DID. IN THE PREVIOUS ITEM A FEW
DIDN'T.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE IT GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN LIMON THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG. I'M I'M
WENDY RIVERBOATS WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES ARE AQUA. A WE
REPRESENT OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES AND
OUT WATER PROVIDERS THAT
RELIABLY DELIVER NINETY PERCENT.
OF THE STATE'S DEVELOPED WATER
ON RESPECTFULLY WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING THIS ISSUE OF THE
POSSIBILITY OF A WATER TAX
WITHIN A POLICY BILL OR OF A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL FOR THE PAST
YEAR. OUR ASSOCIATION HAS GONE
ON RECORD IN OPPOSITION SEVERAL
VENUES BUT ON TODAY WE JUST LIKE
TO BRIEFLY FOCUS OUR COMMENTS ON
WHAT WE CAN SUPPORT. AND TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG IS IT A
QUESTION JUST NOW WE SUPPORT A
CREDIBLE AN EQUITABLE FUNDING
MIX AND ALTERNATE. THAT A
INCLUDES ONGOING FEDERAL SAFE
DRINKING WATER STATE REVOLVING
FUND DOLLARS RELIABLE GENERAL
OBLIGATION WATER BOND MONEY
FOCUSED NITRATE ASSESSMENTS AND
THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND TO
CREATE A FUNDING SOURCE. AS AS
FOR INSTANCE UP PROTECTED INS
AND SECURITY ENDOWMENT FUND OR
SOME TYPE.
OF OF FUN LIKE THAT THAT'S
PROTECTED TO PAY THE OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS THAT WE DO
AGREE WITH CHAIRMAN MARKETS ON
THE OBJECTIVE WE DON'T AGREE
WITH THE MEANS AT THIS POINT. WE
FEEL THAT WE NEED THIS BALLOTS
FUNDING PORTFOLIO PACKAGE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER IN
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO IT. OUR PROPOSAL
SEEKS AN ANNUAL SOME OF THIRTY
FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND ITEM TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM THAT REALLY WE AGREE
TEARS AT THE SOCIAL FABRIC.
WITHIN SOME OF THESE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITHIN
CALIFORNIA THE GENERAL FUNDS
LARGEST REVENUE SOURCE IS THE
STATE'S PROGRESSIVE PERSONAL
INCOME TAX.
HAVING THIS PURPOSE WE THINK IS
THE HIGHEST AND BEST USE OF THE
GENERAL FUND AND AT THIS POINT
IS A REALLY STILL A QUESTION AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE USING.
GENERAL FUND FOR THIS PURPOSE WE
SUPPORT THE CRITICAL ISSUE BEING
RESPECTED ON THAT THIS ISSUES
RESPECTED WITHIN THE LEGISLATIVE
POLICY. COMMITTEE PROCESS WERE
MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR INPUT
ON IT AND AMENDMENTS AND
TRANSPARENCY PREDICTABLY EXIST
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS FACT
FAST TRACKED ON BUDGET TRAILER
BILL PROCESS. IS THE APPROPRIATE
HOME FOR A STATE WHITEWATER
TALKS TO BE VETTED THE WATER TAX
HAS YET TO BE HEARD IN A REGULAR
POLICY BILL HEARING I WOULD LIKE
TO REMIND. THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
WE SUPPORT THE REALITY THAT THIS
WATER TAXES IN FACT ATTACKS
WHICH REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS
SUPERMAJORITY VOTE REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THE CONCEPT OCCURS AND A
BUDGET. SUBCOMMITTEE THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS OR AND REGULAR
LEGISLATION
SO WHAT STANDING IN THE WAY OF
AN UNPRECEDENTED COALITION. A
SUPPORT FOR A REAL ALTERNATIVE
FUNDING PACKAGE AND I THINK THE
STATEWIDE WATER TAX PROPOSAL
BEING HURT RIGHT NOW IN THIS
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. IS THAT IS
THAT IS WHAT STANDING IN THE WAY
REALLY ULTIMATELY OF A
SUCCESSFUL RESOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM WHY CAN'T WE WORK
TOGETHER. WHY CAN'T WE TRY
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND
SUPPORTER ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
PACKAGE TO OBTAIN WHAT IS REMAIN
ELUSIVE TO THIS POINT? UP ADMITS
THE INSISTENT GOT HAVE WATER TAX
GOTTA WATER TALKS ANSWER TO
EVERY THOUGHTFUL FUNDING PACKAGE
QUESTION THAT WE'VE POSTS WE
APPRECIATE CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU ARE ONE THING I FORGOT
TO MENTION THAT I IS THAT TO A
WE ARE HOLDING THIS ITEM OPEN.
UP FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
LANGUAGE BECAUSE YOU'RE HERE.
FOR THE FOR THE FIRST TIME AND
THAT MEANS WE WILL NOT BE MAKING
A DECISION ON THIS ITEM TODAY
WHICH ALLOWS US FURTHER TIME TO
CONSIDER YOUR COMMENTS THAT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO US.
AND TO A THE ITEM WILL BE
RESCHEDULED AGAIN FOR ANOTHER
HEARING.
A SOMETIME BEFORE WE.
A FINISH OUR OF BUDGET PROCESS
HERE IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DANIEL BLAST
WITH CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION OUR
MEMBERS DELIVER WATER TO OVER
SEVENTY PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS
I WILL ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
AQUA AND AND WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THIS.
A BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL AND
THE.
.
TRAILER BILL BUT WE DO OPPOSE
WATER TAX BEING IS PART OF THE
FUNDING PACKAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MARINO.
MARINA HERON WITH THE IRVINE
RANCH WATER DISTRICT WE ARE
MEMBERS OF OCT ONE SCENE YOU A
AND AGREE WITH STATEMENTS OF MY
PREDECESSORS.
WE REALIZE THAT THIS IS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED BUT WE THINK IT'S A.
BAD IDEA TO IMPOSE A PRECEDENT
OF TAXING WATER THAT IS USED BY
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TREATS
BURKE A* FROM EGO CONSULT ON
BEHALF OF SERIES.
I JUST WANNA SAY THAT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CREATION
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE WATER DRINKING
WATER FUND THROUGH THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET PROCESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SHANNON COULD
TOOL WITH THE SOUTH TAHOE PUBLIC
UTILITY DISTRICT. WE SERVE
FOURTEEN THOUSAND WATER
CUSTOMERS IN THE TAHOE BASIN AND
ARE MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS A
ROUGHLY THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
WE SEE THIS BILL AS A SIPHON
FROM DOLLARS FROM OUR COMMUNITY
EFFORTS.
TO IMPROVE OUR SYSTEM LOCALLY.
AYE WE OPPOSE HOW THIS BILL IS
PAID FOR AND SUPPORT OCAS
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARK EMERSON I'M A
DIRECTOR WITH THE CARMICHAEL
WATER DISTRICT JUST TIME
NORTHEAST OF US SACRAMENTO.
AYE MY IN A WE ARE OPPOSED
ANALYST'S AMENDED.
ON THIS PARTICULAR LEGISLATION.
BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE A VERY
UNFAIR.
IT WILL WOULD CREATE A BURDEN
ON A LOCAL WATER AGENCIES THERE
SOME TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
COMMUNITY WATER PLUS THE
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS. BY IN
THE STATE CALIFORNIA AND FOR
THEM TO HAVE TO RAMP UP.
AND.
A PUT A A TAX OR SPECIFY TAX ON
THE BILL WOULD BE A VERY A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL BURDEN ON EACH ONE
OF THESE WATER SYSTEMS THAT CAN
BE. THE MONEY BETTER SPENT IN
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEMS OF EACH
ONE OF THESE WATER SERVICES. I I
HAVE NO PROBLEM AND.
THE.
DIRECTION THE CHAIR WOMAN.
MARCUS HAD HAS.
NAY HAS LAID OUT BEFORE YOU AND
I WOULD AGREE BUT IT'S THE
FUNDING MECHANISM OF USING THE
WATER SYSTEMS.
THAT IS INHERENTLY INEFFICIENT
OF THERE OTHER WAYS OF DOING IT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KURT
CLOYD ON THE GENERAL MANAGER OF
HIDDEN VALLEY COMMUNITY SERVICES
DISTRICT OF A LAKE COUNTY. LAKE
COUNTY IS ONE OF THE POOREST
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE A LOT OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND SEVERELY JUST
MANAGEMENT IS UP THERE. AND IN
HOLE.
IN THE WAY IT IS CURRENTLY LAID
OUT WRITTEN.
THIS WOULD ACTUALLY HINDER
THOSE INDIVIDUAL SO WE TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH AQUA AND.
STRONGLY.
OF.
LOOK AT THIS AS AS A BILL THAT.
.
UNLESS IT IS.
RE WRITTEN OTHER WE WOULD HAVE
TO OPPOSE.
AARON EVANS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES I BELIEVE
BELIEVES IN THEM THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF CLEAN DRINKING
WATER AND SUPPORTS MUCH OF
WHAT'S IN THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL. HOWEVER WHERE WE PART WAYS
WITH THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
IS IN THE FUNDING SOLUTION.
I'VE THE LEAGUE AFTER DELIVERED
OF PROCESS THE LEAGUE TOOK
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
SEEKING ELIMINATION OF THE WATER
TAX THANK YOU.
FILLING ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL AND FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE DRINKING WATER THANK
YOU.
MONNING TERASA BEHALF THE CITIES
OF SANTA ROSA AND BURBANK WE
WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF CMU AN AQUA AND LIKE.
MANY BEFORE ME WE WOULD OPPOSE
THE WATER TAX BUT TO BELIEVE IN
THE THE GOAL OF WHERE WE'RE
GOING AND TRYING TO HELP THOSE
WHO. NEED TO COMMUNITIES.
THE IN FOR SHARK CAMERAS WATER
DISTRICT.
CHAIR BLOOM.
MEMBERS.
WELL WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THE PROBLEM
WITH THIS THAT THIS BILL
PROPORCIONAR RESULTS FROM A
FUNDAMENTAL FAILURE OF
GOVERNANCE
NOT A SIMPLE LACK OF FUNDS AND
WE URGE YOU TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM FIRST BEFORE IMPOSING A
TAX ON RESIDENTS TO PROVIDE
SUBSIDIES. IN PERPETUITY TO
FAILING SYSTEMS.
HARLEM HEAT ON IT WITH A LOT OF
ON CALIFORNIA WAS STRONG SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE JUST AN OLD
FIELD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION WE DO
NOT YET HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL.
BUT AS A COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
DOES NOTE.
THERE IS SOME DISCUSSION ON
LANGUAGE RELATED TO NON DAIRY
CONFINED ANIMAL FACILITIES AND
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. ON.
THE TELNET ABOUT LANGUAGE SO WE
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM THAT PROCESS
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
UNITED DAIRYMAN.
MY ORGANIZATION THERE PRESENTS
A REALLY UNDERSTANDS THERE'S A
CRITICAL PROBLEM TO SOLVE AND
HAVE STEPPED UP. AYE FINANCIALLY
TO HELP SOLVE ANY TIME TO TALK
ABOUT HAD THE DAIRY INDUSTRY
CONTRIBUTING TO. A SOLUTION LIKE
THIS IT'S A TOUGH DEBATE AND
TURN AWAY BUT. HOW THE
ORGANIZATIONS PROACTIVE IN AND
SIGN TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM AND
SOLVE IT IMMEDIATELY AND
THEREFORE WE'RE SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU?
WELL MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT
MORAN WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL IT'S BEFORE YOU
TODAY THANK YOU.
HI I'M GAIL DEL HAT WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARIZONA COLORADO NEW
MEXICO. BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS AND
WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU THANK YOU.
THAT AFTERNOON TURNED MEMBERS
TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
FARMERS ALSO A VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNMENT'S.
PROPOSAL ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL CALIFORNIA PRESSURED
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION ALL IN SUPPORT OF A
PROPOSAL.
HELLO MY NAME IS LINDA WILKENS
AND I LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY OF
MCKINNEY TRACK AND TULARE
COUNTY.
AND THAT I WOULD URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THEM THE. THE LAW THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME BECAUSE WE KNOW
RATHER IN A TO PERCENT OF ITS
INDUSTRIOUS IMPROVING OF.
INDEPENDENCE GOOD DENTAL BORDER
THIS BILL WHEN YOU CAN BE
MCGUIRE. FIGURE.
ONE OF PUBLIC NOTICES THE
READINESS RICARDO WITNESSED THEM
MOST. SIFT THROUGH THE CREEK
ANOTHER NORTH THEM. ARE LEFT TO
FEND WITH PROBLEMS THE STRUGGLE.
MINKA ADVENTURE TO COME THOUGH
THAT THE MANY BINGO BUCK MOST
SUBWAY ECONOMIST DAVID.
SEE NICE THEN I ASK THEM
LISTLESS AND BECOME A SECOND US
UP.
NOT A COMPANION UP LITTLE ITEMS
THAT I LOOK AT THEM SEMESTER
LEFT.
TO HAVE SOMEBODY WHO CAN
TRANSLATE PLEASE.
I WAS TRYING TO SEND AM THE WITH
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND I'M
GONNA HELP TRANSLATE FOR SOME OF
OUR PARTNERS.
OKAY THE TWO WOMEN THAT JUST
PASSED BY THERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THEY'RE
COMING FROM AND RANCHO AND.
PORTERVILLE.
IN A MINUTE THE SEVENTH SOLO
DEALING WITH ACKERMAN ENTIRELY
NOT ANY CUANDO THE FRESNO.
MY NAME IS HE'S OF ABSOLUTE I
COME FROM FRESNO COUNTY.
MAPLE YET IS THE PLACE THAT BUT
GUESS WHAT YOU LIKE AND RESPECT
ONLY THEN WAS THE COMMITTED OUT
THE AND ABSENT EQUAL LEVEL.
COME TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITIES OF OURS
OUR COMMUNITY WATER HAS ARSENIC
THIS THE THE MOST WHEN A
CELESTIAL I LET REPRESSIVE.
KNOWN OF INDEPENDENT I MUST.
WE A LONG TERM SOLUTION ON A
BANDAID.
THANK YOU.
BERMAN OF ANGLER LATHAM REMAIN.
AMERICAN A PLAIN COLA. I WORK
QUITE SCENIC AND.
KENNETH ABOUT SECOND KNOWN
OLYMPIAN HERSELF POINTING AT
LIMPET LEVEL PUBLIC AS I WON.
IT WAS A PLATE OF MARK LOOK AT
THAT BUMP THEM ANOTHER.
MY NAME IS MIGHT NOT HAVE
ANOTHER COME FROM TONY BUILT
HERE IN SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
BECAUSE OUR WATER IS
CONTAMINATED.
MEAN NUMBER HAS GONE SO LONG
THAT I THINK EVEN WILL THEY LET
THE NUVEEN.
EVEN IN ONE SECOND US UP WE
INCLUDED THAT ALLOW A PARTICULAR
WORK AT THE NEW MOST IF I'M
ECONOMY NEVER HE'S NOT AUSTIN
BECOMES SUCK IT UP AND. THAT'S
JUST BROKE DOWN.
CONSUELO ON THE OTHER COMING
FROM TONY BILL SHE'S HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OR GO TO OUR
COMMUNITY INTRIGUED HER WATER.
HE LET OUT CHAU FROM HIS BORDERS
WELL. AMONG SO HERE TO SUPPORT
OR US FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AND SAY MY IDEA YOU BUTTE
ALONE OR LEAVE US COME AND JOIN
US AND DRINK OF WATER.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND MY NAME'S
DOPING IN THAT I KNOW AND I'M
FROM TULARE CALIFORNIA AND THAT.
AND I WOULD I LIKE THE BEAT THAT
SUPPORT.
ARE THESE BILL.
IF NOT YOU CAN AND DRINK OUR
WATER.
WHEN A SPOT OF ANYTHING NUMBERS
MILLION MEN THAT THE NEW MESSIAH
COMES UP WHEN YOU CALL THEM NOT
ONE.
MY NAME IS MANY MEN THIS I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT FOR THE I'M
ASKING FOR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WHAT CAN HOW DOES THE PLUMBING
WAS KIND OF A?
BECAUSE NO SUPPORT COMES OUR
WAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SHE ONLY
FLEE THOUGH I'M HERE
REPRESENTING POLICY LINCOLN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
OPPOSE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
I'M GONNA GO NEXT.
SO SOME OF THEM I WITH COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL. IF NOT DRINK OUR WATER
THANK YOU.
YOU ARE NOT TAKING TANA FOR YOU
THE COUNTY WATER AGENCY AND ALSO
EAST VALLEY WATER DISTRICT HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE VERY
CREDIBLE AND THOUGHTFUL AQUA
ALTERNATIVE TO RESOLVE THIS
PROBLEM. BUT IN ST US STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE CONCEPT A
WATER TAXI THANK YOU.
HELLO NICOLE CAN UNITS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS THE SCOTTS MIRACLE.
GRO COMPANY WE REPRESENT THE
URBAN NON AG USES A FERTILIZER
THOSE MANUFACTURERS.
THE UC DAVIS NITRATE REPORT
SHOWED THAT.
LESS THAN ONE PERCENT OF THE
CONTRIBUTIONS NITRATE
CONTAMINATION CAME FROM NON OUT
URBAN YOU SAYS HOWEVER THE MAIL
INCREASE ASSESSMENT WOULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT OUR
COMPANIES.
MUCH HIGHER THAN THAT SO.
WELL WE DEFINITELY APPRECIATE
THE THE CONCERN IN THE ISSUE I'M
ON A FIND A A GOOD WAY AND AN
EQUITABLE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THIS TIME PROPOSAL THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON RECEIVE THOMPSON
WITH METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE
SUPPORT THE OVER ARCHING.
OBJECTIVE OF THE PROPOSAL
HOWEVER WE ARE AT BECAUSE OF LOS
AND MENDED WITH THE WITH THE
SPECIFICS AS TO HOW TO FUND THE
PROGRAM SO WE LOOK FOR TO POOR
DISCUSSIONS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KANTOR DIJO GO
WITH THE GLOCK A GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF FRESNO.
THE UNITED WATER CONSERVATION
DISTRICT ENDS ON SEVEN WATER
AGENCY IN ALAMEDA AND.
ALAMEDA COUNTIES.
WE DO AGREE THAT THERE IS A
NEED FOR A SAFE DRINKING WATER
BUT WE OPPOSE THE WATER TAX WE
DO THINK WE AGREE WITH THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG THAT THERE
ARE ALTERNATIVES OUT THERE THAT
SHOULD BE VETTED. AND WE HOPE
THAT WHEN THIS COMES UP AGAIN IN
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WE DO HAVE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO A COMMENT
AT THAT POINT TO.
CAPTION AND CAROLYN JENSEN WITH
KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
OUT LESSONS WATER DISTRICT AND
THE MOJAVE WATER AGENCY. A IN
SUPPORT OF THE AQUA.
HER ALTERNATIVE AND AND
OPPOSITION TILL WATER TAX THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RON DAVIS ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. OF
WOULD LIKE TO INCORPORATE BY
REFERENCE THE COMMENTS OF BOTH
AQUA CMU WAY WE CERTAINLY AGREE
THAT THERE'S AN ISSUE THAT
SHOULD BE RESOLVED. BUT WE WANT
TO DISCUSS FURTHER SOME
ALTERNATIVE MECHANISMS FOR
FUNDING THAT SOLUTION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER ADDED
JOHN O'MALLEY REPRESENTING A
MISSILE WATER DISTRICT WE AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH THE
AMENDMENTS SUPPORTED BY. OUR
AQUA AND WHO ARE OPPOSED THE
WATER TAX THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED ANALYST ON MORE
OR LESS RESTORED MY NAME IS
DAVID MORALES CUBA CONVEYOR NAM
SAW SUCH SUPPORT THAT WILL NOT
ALLOW WHAT. WE SUPPORTERS.
WITH THE WATER ISSUES.
HISTOLOGICAL FEES IN OPAL
ASSEMBLY THAW THE MODEST I WILL
DISCUSS LUCY. WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL OR DRINK THIS CONTAMINATED
WATER THINK YOU.
ONE LAST ITEM NUMBERS ON THAT
AMEND THIS AFTERNOON
FUNDAMENTALIST THEN GO THAT PART
OF YOUR COUNTY FOR NOT COME FROM
PORTERVILLE CALIFORNIA EEK
ELEVEN HAVE A STEP BUT I
NOT A BATTLE THAT BEING. PLEASE
SUPPORT US IN THIS BILL IT THAT
MAKES IT I SEE LET'S GET THEM
WITH A SANNYASI NOT WHAT AND
POPULAR MEDINA AND ME A LOT. AND
I ALSO WANT TO TELL YOU THAT MY
BY WELL IS DRY HE'S BEEN DRY FOR
THREE YEARS. HE DOESN'T VIDAK AS
IN MY HIM ON STANISLAUS AMONG US
IN IOWA IN SELECT LIST VOTED IN.
JUST ONE WEEK WITHOUT WATER.
INTO A TWO HOUSEHOLDS GODS YES
THANK YOU.
JOHN AT THE NELSON WITH THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH AN
UNPRECEDENTED COALITION OF OVER
ONE HUNDRED OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
SOME OF WHICH ARE HERE TODAY.
AS WE'VE ALREADY HEARD.
WE MUST GIVE THIS DRINKING WATER
CRISIS. WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS ISSUE FOR
YEARS AND YEARS WHILE FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN TRAIN TOXIC WATER.
WE ASK THAT THIS LEGISLATURE ACT
THIS YEARAND SUPPORT OF THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUN.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE TO DO WE.
MICE FROM BY SALIA.
NASA DO SUPPORT.
THIS BILL.
WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
I AM AND ABOUT A FROM MY
CELLULAR AND NASTY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. REJECT THIS WATER.
MY NAME.
LAYMEN'S ARMIES SACK I CAN FORM
PART OF THEY'LL AND.
AND ALSO VOIGTS IS URGING LA
ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ONE US THAT THIS MINIMALIST
WANNA MAKE BONE AINDA. MANDALIT
BOTTLE BICU REPORTER BILL.
THE BENGAL CUP OIL IN THE. HERB
BILLION.
YOU SEEN LOAN WILL SOON BE
TAUGHT THE WANT OF THIS POWER. I
BUDGET TO SUPPORT THIS BILL OR
IF NOT PLEASE I'M BY YOU TO
DRINK THIS WATER THING KILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS IMAM
IN THE UNITED PAMPER MEANS HE AT
POLITICO KNEE. AND I AM SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE HIS TIME YEAH
OUT COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED A WILL WATER CLEAN WATER
AND AFRO WHAT.
WE'VE WITNESSED THAT THEN THE
NUMBER LA THERE THAT BY MY
YOU'VE WRITTEN FOR THE BETTER
KNOWN MY NAME ISN'T ENOUGH OF
MY.
EVEN THINK THOUGH THAT IT SAID
RELAT IS TO LET THEM WILL MEAN
THAT MUCH IN THIS THAT ACT IN
THE MOST I WORK ON THEM YOU HAVE
YOU KNOW I'M COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF.
BUT MACINNES THAT MIGHT BE
MISTER.
TULARE.
IN THIS IS IT THAT MOST UP OIL.
CAN A SAILING A BY THAT'D BE TO
PUT THAT THEY ALSO MOST BUT SAW
LAST MORE BODIES WILL NEED TO
SUPPORT BECAUSE WE ARE VERY LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY.
YEAH WENT THAT WE JUST PISS ON
US FORM TRANSIT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF THAT BECAUSE OF CANCER.
THE.
I MEAN.
BUT SAW NOTHING LAWYER ADDED
SEVEN.
IF IF BAD THE MUST HAVE A PUMP I
MEAN THAT IT OUT IN MY COMMUNITY
WE HAVE ARSENIC AND SO MY WATER
IS REALLY CONTAMINATED.
THANK YOU.
PA HELLO AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE.
MONEY DRUG OR SEE I COME FROM
THE CITY OF PORT OF ALL
CALIFORNIA.
AYE ENDURANCE OF FILE AND I'M
ALSO WITH THE.
.
WITH SHEILA.
I'M ASKING A GUY SUPPORT THIS
OUR WATER BILL FOR.
FOR SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER AND IF NOT THEN I AM LIKE
YOU OUGHT TO DRINK. THIS WATER
THAT ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
FORCED TO LIVE WITH ON A DAILY
BASIS THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS BENNY KORANA
I'M A MEMBER CHILLA AND FROM THE
BEAUTIFUL CITY OF LINDSAY
CALIFORNIA.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL OF PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL OR.
DRINK THE WATER IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
HELLO MY NAME IS LIKE THE CELL
LOPEZ I AM A RESIDENT FROM WHAT
ABOUT A CALIFORNIA AND I COME
HERE AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF MY
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS ARE
REPRESENTATIVE. OF THE AMERICAN
FRIENDS SERVICE COMMITTEE AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS OF
PROPOSAL. AND IT.
IT OTHERWISE WE DO INVITE YOU TO
GOING TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
DRINK THE WATER THAT ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE DRINKING
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M MY NAME IS DANNY
UPPING A LOSS AND I AM SURE THAT
I'M HERE AS CHINA'S CENTRAL THE
ORGANIZER AND I LIVE IN THE CITY
A PORTABLE.
WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER.
BECAUSE RESPONSES POLICY
ADVOCATE WHICHEVER THE COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS AYE AFTER
A REPRESENTING OUR MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE AS THE
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
HI MY NAME IS EDGAR AND FROM
TULARE AND I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL BUDGET MY WATER.
HI MY NAME MARIN. OWN. ASKING US
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HE MY NAME OF ONE TEN. AND
DROWNED DAY LARRY AND I TURN TO
PUT THEIR BELL.
HI MY NAME IS FRANCIS NOW FOR
TULARE.
SUPPORT THIS BILL URGING A
WIDER.
BELOW ME NUMBERS CHRIS THOUGHT
CHVEZ.
BIGGEST ABOUT THOMAS EVEN THOUGH
THE LAW THROUGH A PORTAL VEAL.
THE FILM THEY'RE DOING OF THAT
POSSIBLY VITAL AND I COME FROM
THE CITY OF PORTERVILLE ON THAT
PRIVATE WILL HONOR.
HE COMMAND MOM.
PURPLISH COUPLE UNIT WOULD BE
OWNED LE IS BE.
SIX SIX TWENTY THREE.
OR OR KNOWING THAT THE MOTHER
THOU ABOUT IT AS IF NOTHING ELSE
AND LONGEST.
AND AYE COM WELL TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AS WE SIX
TWENTY THREE AND DON'T DRINK
THIS WATER TO MAKE MAKES IT OUT
TO STAY HEALTHY. MAKE SURE
YOU'RE HEALTHY.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KATHY HILTON AND
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND I WOULD
JUST URGE YOU AS TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. OR DRINK THIS
WATER THINKING.
HELLO MY NAME'S DOT JOSHUA
CAMACHO DOCTOR REVEREND MINISTER
OF CIVIL RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS
NOT SUPPORT HIS BILL. THANK YOU
WATER SUPPLY RIGHT THANK YOU.
IT IS TIME BUT AGAIN AND.
I WILL LET YOU TODAY SUPPORT IS
BEYOND AND I WE'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR YEARS FOR THIS APPOINTEES
PROPOSAL SO THAT. THE TIME IS
NOW.
IN NINETEEN YOU NEED TO DO THE
JOB. ENOUGH TO TAKE YOUR DAYS IS
MORE COMMUNITIES ARE. PLEASE A.
TAKE CONSIDERATION AND THE
HILTON AND INDELIBLE CONDITION
OF THESE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU AND.
IF YOU GIVEN SUPPORT HIS BILL.
PLEASED
DURING HIS BILL VISIT WATER AND
YOU CAN.
YOU CAN FEEL THE DIFFERENCE.
THANK YOU.
I'M HI MY NAME'S CHARLOTTE Y. I
NAY LIVE IN SACRAMENTO AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT. THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BELT OR TO
DRINK THIS WATER THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CAESAR
I LIVE IN VICE ELIA AND I'M HERE
TO STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. OR ELSE IT WOULD BE A
GREAT DISSERVICE TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IF NOT GO AHEAD AND
DRINK THIS WATER THANK YOU.
NO THE OTHERS WILL NOTICE
SOMEONE I KNOW. THE LITTLE LUCK
BONUS OF REAL GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS HE ONE OF MY GUN OUT AND
NOT COME FROM THE COMMUNITIES TO
BILL.
IS THERE A CONDUCTOR LOT A THEN
GOV A SINGLE AUTHOR VOTER THAT
THEY HAVE BUT YET IF THEY THE.
POLICE SUPPORT THIS BILL LOOK AT
THE ANIMALS.
BUT I WOULDN'T THAT MEAN THAT
YOU KNOW I THINK IT GET ENOUGH
THE MODEST THAT WOULDN'T THAT
MEAN HIGHER BECAUSE OUR WATER IS
CONTAMINATED IN NOBODY WANTS TO
DRINK CONTAMINATED WATER.
AND WHATEVER JUSTICE THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M GETTING A GUY YET
THOUGH AND I COME FROM BY
CELLULAR. AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL OR DRINK OR
CONTAMINATED WATER.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREA PEDROSA
AND I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. IT IS UNFAIR THAT TWO WEEK
PAY WATER BILL AND IN TURN HAVE
TO OUT SOURCE OUR WATER BECAUSE
THE WATER IS CONTAMINATED SO.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KIMBERLY TIME
FROM TULARE I AM IN SIXTH GRADE.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL OR
DRINK OUR WATER BIG.
HI MY NAME IS MALIKA LOPEZ I'M
INSIST GREAT I'M FROM TO LARRY
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL OUR
DRINK OUR WATER THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME WAS NEVER
KIND I COULD I LIVE IN TO LARRY.
I ASKED I SUPPORT BILL OR DRINK
OUR WATER.
IN THE NUMBER IF I DON'T THINK
ON THAT IT ASKED.
THIS LIVING WILL THE LEAN SICK
LEAVE AND WAR GET BUT EVEN THIS
DIVISION WE.
MY NAME IS A DIFFICULT TASK I
COME FROM LINDSAY AND I ASKED
WHAT TO WHO ARE FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
IT IS.
ME AT ONE. AROUSED HERE'S MY
WATER.
THANK YOU.
HELLO HELLO MY NAME IS TEMPAT NO
I COME FROM AMONG WOMEN
CALIFORNIA I'M ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AT THAT IS
BECAUSE THE TO TAXATION A FROM
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE WITH
SEEN HERE. ASKING YOUR FOR CLEAN
WATER.
AS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS JIM LEACH A
SEPARATE IN A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS AT FOR THE
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT.
WE SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL WE.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE IN FAVOR ALSO
THE AQUA AMENDMENTS WHEN
OPPOSING LESS AMEND ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
WHEN I START LISTENING ON THE
LITTLE SUBTLE PUTS IT BIGELOW
BECAUSE HE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RUSSELL OPPOSITE I COME FROM
BAKERSFIELD.
EVEN GOT CARE LESS WHO THEN MUST
THE MOST I GUESS CALIFORNIA UP
WILLIAMS CONTINENT I WOULD MEAN
PEAK THE MOB. WHICH IS THAT I
WAS BUT THAT THERE.
AND I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
AND THINK YOU'RE MUCH FREE
ATTENTION.
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN THE STARTOF
THIS ME NUMBER EIGHTY BLANCA
PRODUCE CLETUS CAMPESINOS.
BUT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BLANCA
I WOULD LEADERS CAMPESINOS.
EVEN WITHOUT THE APPLE YOUNG BUT
BONUS PERSONAS THAT THAT IS
COMPETING THIS GUITAR HOW MOST
IN THE PLUMAS THAT BUT ISN'T
THIS AN ACT OF REPRESENTING ALL
THE FARMWORKERS THAT COULD NOT
BE HERE TODAY.
BUT I PAID THIS HOUSE DAYS
COOPER FOULED ON THOSE HOT BOY
IMPOTENT A PROPOSED TOPIC AT
ALL.
IDEA I WON BEAM PIA AND I ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL ALSO
THERE'S CLEAN SAFE SAFE AND
CLEAN WATER. BUT I
THOUGHTLESSNESS COLONIA IF FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES BASED AUGUST I
WAS IN THE LOAN THIS THOU
CALIFORNIA GAYS WHO NAME OF
MONEY BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A VERY
RATES ESTATE WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA.
IN IT IS A MUST IS TO MUCHO MAS
LET US IF WE THIS OF THIS AND
MUCH MORE THANK YOU.
GEN UP WAS ALL ABOUT THEM FROM
SOLANO COUNTY AND I HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO LIVE IN TULARE
COUNTY.
APPEAR A BIT A LOT IS TO LIKE
DRINK WATER DISMISSED NET.
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT THEM
BECAUSE YOU GUYS REPRESENT US.
AND THEY'RE ASKING YOU GUYS TO
SUPPORT HIS BILL THIS BILL NEED
TO GET HAN THIS BILL NEEDS TO
GET DONE AND WE CAN MAKE THAT
WE'RE NOT MICHIGAN WERE
CALIFORNIA.
WE TAKE YOUR THE PEOPLE IN
HE WE WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
GIVING PEOPLE SOMETHING THAT A
CARD WRITTEN WHAT ARE AT A SUCH
AS THAT EVERY M. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS WATER IN THESE PEOPLE
GOING HAVE DRINKING WATER.
AND WE'RE CERTAIN THAT YOU KNOW
IN OFFICE TO DISCUSS ARE WE
GOING TO CLEAN THESE PEOPLE
WATER WE'RE NOT MICHIGAN WHAT
CALIFORNIA WE GET THINGS DONE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S ALL
ABSENT I WISH YOU GUYS WOULD
JUST TAKE IT EASY AND I'M.
A DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THESE
PEOPLE YOU KNOW I'M NOT WHAT IS
FINE.
BUT I COULD I COULD IMAGINE WHAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH.
AND WE KNOW I KNOW IT WAS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD IS WELL AS YOU GUYS
NAY WOOD IT'S UP WITH SOMETHING
WOULD GET DONE.
FAST
WE'RE NOT MISHKIN WOULD
CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA WE GET
THINGS DONE. YOU KNOW THAT'S ALL
A MESS AND YOU GOT TO BE DOING A
GREAT JOB DOING WHAT YOU GUYS
DON'T DISS GET THIS HALIBUT THIS
IS WATER THIS IS NOT. CAR TO
CLOSE THIS IS WATER THINGS THAT
PEOPLE NEED TO DRINK THINK WE
NEED TO SIX HOURS TO GET CLEAN.
AND WHEN CALIFORNIA NGUYEN
IMPORT RECALL LEAN IN. BAHAMAS
WIN CALIFORNIA AND WE TALK ABOUT
GIVES MONEY TO CLEAN WATER.
YOU GENERALLY CAN GET THIS JOB
DONE.
AND I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE CAPABLE
OF GETTING IT DONE ALL I ASK YOU
DO GET IT DONE. THANK.
WHEN ESTABLISH HI EVERYONE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BUT THE
DAHLE ALLEN I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
I'M ALSO HERE AS A MEMBER.
A PERSON BORN AND RAISED IN THE
EASTERN COULD TELL ABOUT THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I JUST
WANNA.
REALLY HIGHLIGHT FOR THE FOLKS
FROM MY COMMUNITY THAT ARE
UNABLE TO BE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
OF THE TRANSPORTATION OR
DISPENSED. BUT HOW CRUCIAL THIS.
WATER BUT A WATER.
PROPOSAL.
AND FUND IS SO CRUCIAL TO MY
COMMUNITY YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
COMPETE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
TRAILER PARKS THAT ON A DAILY
BASIS ARE.
NEED TO MITIGATE WITH
CONTAMINANTS LIKE CHRONIC A
CHROME SIX AND OURS TO MAKE.
THAT REGARDLESS OF YOU WHY IF
YOU BUY A WATER BOTTLE OR WATER
YOU STILL HAVE TO SHOWER WITH
THIS WATER.
INDICES ON A DAILY BASIS IS THE
ISSUE THAT COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
HAVE TO DEAL WITH EVERY DAY AND
FOR THIS REALLY HIGHLIGHTING THE
EASTERN PATELLA BADLY MAKE ARE
NO SHORT COMMUNITY. COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE UNINCORPORATED AND MANY
TIMES ARE NOT REPRESENTED AT THE
STATE LEVEL SO WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AND PEACE.
I AM HERE WE SUPPORT.
FOR THIS A PROPOSAL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOE
FEENEY UP THOUGH I COME
REPRESENTING OUR LITTLE TALK.
FROM TO THEIR COUNTY SEVERAL.
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU GUYS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. I WAS
SAW I'VE BEEN I'VE LIVED MOST OF
MY LIFE THEIR RACE DAUGHTERS I
HAVE GRANDKIDS. AND I WOULD ASK
YOU GUYS TO PUT YOURSELF IN OUR
SHOES FOR A LITTLE WHILE AND
HAVE YOUR KIDS OR YOUR GRANDKIDS
DRINK THIS CONTAMINATED WATER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
FINANCED BY THE BASE YOU ALSO
MIGHT BE ON MY SKIN DAM SHARE
EVENT WHAT BUT I DID WHAT I NAY.
I IT BY STATE TOWARD GAY AND
LIVE HOW MANY I MEAN FROM MY
WORK THEY SPECIAL NUYS BECOMES.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MAY NAME IS GROSSLY LA MUST GET
A AND I'M COME FROM A SET AND I
GOT GOOD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IN MY FAMILY THERE'S
BEEN CASES OF CANCER.
THAT'S.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS W.
HOURS I'M HERE.
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO I MUST HERE
ON BEHALF OF SAY HA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND WE ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL OR
DRINK THIS WATER.
WHEN I STARTED THIS MEAN THEM
BUT IT'S WILL EVEN GO THERE
CUANDO THAT PUT IN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JULIA
NAM COMPONENT FRESNO COUNTY.
MAYBE IN THE LOUIS AT THOSE
CUANDO ME COURT ASSUME KEPT BOY
IN THE WILL AND ABILITY PC BUT
NOTHING TO SUPPORT INTERNAL SO.
I ASKED ONE OF MY HEART TO PRE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR AND VIA MY
MAINLY SUPPORT US.
WHAT'S UP FOR YOU. THIS SEPARATE
WITH A LITTLE FORM THOSE.
BUT AND IF IF YOU GOT IT I'M
WANTING BICU ELEVEN RUN ONLY
FIFTY POUNDS FILIPINO COOKBOOK A
MICROPHONE COUPLE UNITS BUT WERE
BORED. GLASS IF
RELUCTANTLY AND PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS FUN.
WE'D REALLY NEED IT AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION.
LINDA THREATEN A NUMBER IF IT
ENDED UP THIS HILL BUT AFTERNOON
MY NAME AS IT ENDED UP AS YELLOW
MANGO THE OAKLAND ALL THE FED
NOT A.
BELA E. APPLE YOUR LAPTOP
POLITICAL THAT NOVEL.
I I COME FROM FRESNO COUNTY AND
I'M SUPPORTING THE GOVERNOR'S.
BILL.
KID GIVE THEM LITTLE AYE WELL
WITHIN THE CLINTON THAT THEIR
LOVE AFFAIR NICKEL. HE HERE I
THINK I'M ASSEMBLY AND I'M SURE
THAT.
ARE WE WANT TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND WE
DON'T WANT ARSENIC IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHEN WE DON'T WANT
NO MORE CONTAMINANTS THINK YOU.
WHEN I THOUGHT OF THIS MAY
NOTICE A LADY IN THAT JOB
RECEIVING ON THAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SILLY I
CHVEZ AND I COME FROM OUR BEEN.
HAVING ONE AS HE LOOKED UP A
FIVE ON A SOUTH KOREAN BUT THE
FASTEST THEY'VE EVEN.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN SUCKING COME
ON THAT IT JUST THEN THE MONGOLS
NIECE WAS THAT IT JUST A LOVELY
COASTAL SPOKE.
I ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE EVERYBODY HAS THE
SAME RIGHT NO MATTER.
IT GIVES STATUS.
NOTICE IT BECAUSE AS LONG AS MY
ALLOWANCE AND REGIONAL OR POOR
WATER IS THE SAME.
BUT DIPLOMACY WHILE IN PROCESS
BUT FIVE ONE UP FOR YOU.
WE PAY THE SAME PRICE SO PRE
SUPPORTERS THAT.
WHEN A SERVICEMAN NUMBERS WORK
ON A TRAVIS BINGO THE LESS YOU
HAVE ADDED ME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOT
THE LOOK CHVEZ AND I COME FROM
SENIOR MARVIN. MENTAL UP A LIST
OF HUBBLE CAN ASSEMBLY IN A LA
REPORTS THAT ISOLATIONISM
PEOPLE.
I ASK I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT AS WE SIX THIRTY THREE.
IT OPENS THEM IN THE HOPE OF
CARE AND ATTACKS ON AND COULD
HAVE A CHILLING QUE LAUE AS WELL
THAT ACTUAL WHEN MONO ALLOW ONE
ON. LINE THAT I LEFT AT LEAST
THAT IT WAS A BOOK ALONG WITH
SIMPLY NINE.
IN COURT I MEAN I LIKE I SAID
LIVE ANNUAL SHEILA WAS A
CONSUMER BUT I.
BUT AT THE LOS BUT NOT QUITE
GIFTED OF INTELLECT AND ISIS IS
YEAH BUT IT I WILL ALLOW ONE BUT
A BAY THIS.
BUT THE SUPPLE YOUNG SYLLABLES.
ZOMBIE DOT GET THEM AND ASKED
HOW OFTEN I MEAN THAT I GOT YOU.
I ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL OUR WATER IS THE NATCHEZ
NATURAL.
WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND SO
THAT'S WHY I'M BRINGING WATER BY
HERE WITH ME.
BY THE SUPPORT THIS BILL OR
DRINK OF WATER.
WHEN US FEATHERS ME NUMBER SOME
THAT I'VE C. M..
BUT IF NEWMAN ASUNDER GARCIA
EVEN LET UP ONLY THAT IT UP
THERE HAVE THEM THOUGH THAT THE
LEADING AND I COME FROM THEIR
COMMUNITY OF POPULAR INTO LAKE
COUNTY.
E. MAIL UP OR YEAH AND THE.
AS THEY BEGIN.
I'M HERE SUPPORT THIS BILL ICANN
I WAS GO STAND MUST UP WILL YOU
END.
GOING TO A WE WANT YOUR SUPPORT.
YOU SEE NOW BUT KNOW MINIMIZE
THAT I WAS IF NOT PLEASE DRINK
OUR WATER.
AND I THINK YOU.
WHEN THE THOUGHTLESS.
NUMBER WHATEVER HAVE ALREADY
BEEN LONG GONE THAT THE LEADING
ANOTHER NEWMAN IS GOING ABOUT
WILL NOT COME TO THE PHONE I
COME FROM THERE OUT TO LAKE
COUNTY MEDICAMENT I PLAY BILL.
BLAME YOU BRING UP A AND THEY
SAID BEING.
YES BUT I'M UP IN THE SUPPORT
YET.
EVE BUT HOW ARE OF THE LAW THEM
AND IF I WORK WITH THEM ENOUGH.
REFERENCE.
WELL I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL I HOPE YOU SUPPORT US AS
WELL IN PLEASE DON'T DRINK THIS
CONTAMINATED WATER.
HELLO WHEN IT'S NOT AS MINIMAL
IDEA MOMENTS. BUT AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MONEY I WILL MISS YOU
THEN GO ON A PLANE YOU.
BUT THEY JUST UP WILLIAM COHEN
IS THE VIEW. LIKE COME FROM
BLAME TO YOU TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT US IN THIS BILL.
POR QUE MOVED THAT LOW WITH THEM
A COME ON TO ME NOW RIGHT ON THE
HEELS OF THAT AMONG WHICH'LL.
BECAUSE THE WATER'S CONTAMINATED
AND OUR CHILDREN ARE GETTING
SICK.
YEAH BUT AS I LOOK THEM UP IN
THE ESTEP YOU. BUT I CAN ASSURE
YOU WITHIN THE.
SEE GIVEN MONTH NSA SUBTLE AB
LIST MCDORMAND PARA ONE AND
THAT'S WHY I'M CLEAR TO ME NOW
WORD AND IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE.
YOUR VIEWERS HEALTHY PRISON
DRINK FROM THIS WATER MUCH
AGGRESSIVE THANK YOU.
OKAY. WELL THAT THE OTHER THE
MYSTIC ORIENTAL SO GOOD
AFTERNOON LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
ESTO ES THOUGH OF SADDAM ON THE
FAMILIAR AT THE LITTLE THIS.
THIS IS THE WATER THE MY FAMILY
DRINKS EVERY DAY SAY.
THE GOVERNMENT CONVINCES THEM
WAS A LITTLE BIT THOUGHT BUT
BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL SOMETIMES
WERE IN THE HOSPITAL BECAUSE OF
THE WATER.
THIS IS THE MOST BUT IS NOT THE
MOST THROUGH THIS. WE NEED
PEOPLE LIKE YOU.
DID ON SUPPORT.
BUT A BULLET FOR ME YES.
LIZ THOUGH THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT OTHER FAMILIES FROM THIS
STATE.
WHAT IS THE LITTLE DINNER IS
LORTON LONG BEEN THE APPEAL AS
PART OF THOSE?
BECAUSE THIS IS FOR EVERYONE.
PAYMENT OF US DISCIPLES THANK
YOU.
BUT AFTER.
WHEN I STARTED THERE NUMBER WHO
WENT IN THE ONCE DAHLE.
THEN GO THEIR LUCK WITH THAT A
LEAN NOT A.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WHO
WOULD YOU KNOW AND SALAS AND I
COME FROM THE COMMUNITY OF
WIENER. WHEN HE PRETTY WELL
THERE ONE DOLLAR FOR THEN.
FOR.
FRESNO COUNTY.
EVEN THE THAT ONE STATE IF IF.
FOR THE PIN A PHOTO OF AYE YI.
YEAH WITHOUT MOVING WENT THAT I
KNOW.
I GOT HERE BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN.
IN THIS STRUGGLE FOR MORE THAN
FIFTY YEARS.
THERE ARE NONE OF THEM IN MY I
AWAY WHO FEAR QUAN TOLD OF LEFT
ON TIME ENOUGH YOU ON THIS.
DRINKING THE SAME DIRTY WATER
WITH ALL THESE CONTAMINANTS.
HE LEFT THE OTTO THE FOUR FIVE
OR.
AND I ASK ALL OF YOU.
OKAY I IF MUCHO.
FINK WENT BACK ON YOUR.
OKAY OKAY YOUR THING WILL
MENDOZA PUT CAL YOUR
PROFESSIONAL LOOKING UP BY
FAILING TO THINK WENT ON YOUR ID
DOMANDA FIT THOSE.
AND I HAVE FIFTY YEARS DRINKING
THAT WATER.
IT DOESN'T MATHIS IT BEFORE YOU
WITHOUT GIVING UP FOR YET DOLAN
OF PROJECT THE FIFTH THING DONE.
BY CALIFORNIA MUCHO PHILIP WAY
THAT I AFFAIRS JOEL BRIEFLY BY
THE MEN THINK IN THIS ARTICLE
MONEY THAT. KIANA YEAH WELCOME
ONE ME VIA. BETTER AFIQ IF
YOU'RE UP ON OUR LEFT AS SHE CAN
OKAY MORE TOUGH FOR ME THAT YOU
CAN.
AND ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
NOT ONLY FOR ME BUT FOR ALL
THAT DAY THE COMMUNITIES KNOW
THE FAMILIES KNOW THE CHILDREN
IN THIS COMMUNITIES.
THOUGH THEM LAUGH.
NO THEIR WHOLE A FOOL IF BUFFY
FEELIN UP WHAT YOU KNOW CUANDO
THAT OF PROJECT OF GUY GOT THERE
THE NETTLE FACULTY FOR I LEAVE
THIS IN YOUR HAVE. YOUR HANDS
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS PROJECT AND
OTHER PROJECTS THAT ARE IN THE
FUTURE FOR FOUR DAYS FOR
CALIFORNIA. ILLEGALLY LEVITT
FIFTY THAT WOULD ASK YOUR
DOCTOR.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN.
WHEN THE STOLEN NUMBERS
POLITICAL SCIENTISTS THEN WILL
PLAY UP THE PROPUESTAS. LEFTISM
MY NEEDINESS.
MY NAME IS ABOUT A SCIENTIST AND
I COME HERE TO SUPPORT.
AS WE SIX ANYBODY.
BECAUSE I THINK YOU.
WIENER STARTED NOTICES HIM
MENDOZA BUT AFTER NEWMAN IS A
WOMAN DOES NOT.
RINGO AT ONE DOLLAR LIMIT SAN A
GOVERNMENT THAT COUNTY.
I BELIEVE THIS ALLOTMENT DECAY
UP ORGANISED ANY EFFECT ON.
THE BEAT IS THE SW. BUT ACTED
BOSSIP BROUGHT THE PUT GET SOME
KIND OF THE COLOR SCHEMES BY
YELLOW.
YES AND I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. BECAUSE WE
WERE STRUGGLING FOR A VERY LONG
TIME
YUP WHAT A SICK ELECTRIC WITH
BOREDOM. CYSTITIS ON THE COURT
CORNYN LA WORK ON COMEY NOT A.
MEMBER OF THE AGRICULTURE.
AIDS AND LET THE WATER WC FOR
AGRICULTURE IS IS.
WHERE DO ANYTHING THAT WATER?
HE TOLD SCHOOL MAY MELISSA
COLOSTOMY MOST WILL FIGHT THOSE
PROBLEMS FOR ME THAT THIS SITE
WHEN YOU SINGLE PASTA.
AND IF WITH A LITTLE LESS
CERTAIN COWS BUT AT THE LARA.
THE APPLE RELAX YOU REMEMBERED
THAT WE THE SAME FRUITS IN THE
SAME VEGETABLES.
WITHOUT WATER IT'S ALL IN THE
FUTURE IS NOT BE A PROBLEM.
THAT'S IT BUT FUN THINGS LONGEST
BATTLE GAVE.
INDIA NUMBER HOBBLED.
WHAT IS MOST ON THE CITY THOUGH
THESE?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND ARE
NECESSITIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DIANA
HERNANDEZ AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT BILL SIX TWENTY THREE.
AND ART MY COMMUNITY OF
RIVERDALE AND THEN THERE. I'M
HERE BECAUSE I.
SURVIVED CANCER BUT LOST SIX OF
MY FRIENDS.
TO THE ARSENIC AND OTHER
CHEMICALS FOUND IN THE WATER SO.
I PLEAD THAT YOU GUYS SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND PASSAGE SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE CLEAN SAFE WATER
WITCHES BRIGHT.
HUMAN RIGHTS FOR US AND ALSO FOR
YOU TO TAKE IN CONSIDERATION TO.
HELP SUPPORT OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
PRIVATE WELLS
BECAUSE JUST IMAGINE IF YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY WATER IN WERE
GIVEN. AS.
LITTLE WATER AND EVERYBODY HAD
TO TAKE A BATH WITH THE SAME
WATER BECAUSE YOU HAD TO RECYCLE
AND SAVE YOUR WATER.
THANK YOU.
ONE A THOUGHT MANILA OVER A
HUNDRED AND OTHER LINDA.
GOT TO GO MONEY WAS NOT A CAR
BEHIND IT NOT COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF NE'ER.
I THINK THEN THE STRANGLEHOLD
LISTA FOR FINISH THE PRIVILEGED.
TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MIGUEL
QUARRY ANIMATE FOURTH GENERATION
FARMER DOWN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND I'M HERE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR THE SPELL. THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS FRANCISCO LLOPIS
I'M COMING FROM FOR IS NOT.
TO ASK YOU GUYS ARE.
LIKE I WANT TO SAY THAT.
I THINK WE NEED SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
SO WE CAN LIVE LONGER FIFTEEN
YEARS OR MORE.
AND I HOPE WE GET MORE MONEY.
S. SO IT'LL HAVE TO COME BACK.
EVERY YEAR ONCE MORE.
THANK YOU.
I AND PHOEBE SCENE WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL BUT I'M ALSO
ON BEHALF OF ME FAMILIA VOTE THE
AND ARVIN CST. AND WE SOME
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL I THINK WE.
ARE MOSTLY HERE TO STATE WHAT
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM. KNOWS
AND WHAT I THINK EVERYBODY WHO'S
TESTIFIED HERE TODAY KNOWS WHICH
IS AT THE GENERAL FUND IS NOT
APPROPRIATE FUNDING SOURCE TO
FUND THIS ON GOING. HOME THIS
THIS NEED.
ANYBODY WHO'S HONEST AND
BELIEVES THAT WE HAVE A PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER. AND KNOWS THAT WE NEED TO
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE KNOWS
THAT THIS IS A SOLUTION THANK
YOU.
SCHOOL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SIDE DAVID
WOLF PARA JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION THANKS FOR ADDING ME
ACT CUT IN LINE HERE.
MEMBERS WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU
KEEP THE BUDGET ITEM OPEN AND
OBVIOUSLY TO EVENTUALLY OPPOSE
IT.
AS WE'VE JUST HEARD AND WE
CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM SO MANY
PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY.
CLEAN WATER ESPECIALLY IN
CENTRAL VALLEY IS A SERIOUS AND
VITAL CONCERN THAT NEEDS
ADDRESSING I THINK EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM AGREES WITH THAT AND
WE CERTAINLY SYMPATHIZE WITH IT.
BUT LET'S BE CLEAR. ATTACKS ON A
PUBLIC RESOURCE THAT IS
IMPERATIVE TO LIFE
IS ABSOLUTELY WITHOUT PRECEDENT
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE. AND
ANYWHERE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF THERE ISN'T SUFFICIENT MONEY
IN THE GENERAL FUND TO ENSURE
THAT ROUGHLY ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
I HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND POLITICIANS
ARE TRULY LOST THE ABILITY TO
PRIORITIZE WHAT IS MOST
IMPORTANT IN OUR BUDGET.
MEMBERS QUITE FRANKLY IT'S
EMBARRASSING THAT CAP AND TRADE
MONEY IS GOING TO FUND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES.
FOR WE CONFRONT A PROBLEM THAT
IS ORDERLY LIFE AND DEATH.
AND MEMBERS THAT'S ESPECIALLY
TRUE BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
WAYS
TO DEAL WITH THIS PROBLEM AND
WHAT IS THIS ITEM IN THE BUDGET
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS I BELIEVE MAYBE
EVEN A LITTLE BIT LAST.
THERE'S SO MANY WAYS WE CAN
FUND THIS
THERE'S EXISTING STATE AND
FEDERAL PROGRAMS THERE'S
PROPOSITION ONE BOND DOLLARS.
AND OF COURSE AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THIS ABOUT A BILLION OF
EXISTING CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS
THE CAN BE USED. DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM. AND FINALLY AS I'M SURE
AQUA AND SOME OF THE OTHER LOCAL
WATER AGENCIES HAVE ADDRESSED
HERE TODAY. IS THE QUESTION OF
LOCAL CONTROL.
THIS STATEWIDE TAX WOULD
REPRESENT A DIVERSION OF LOCAL
RAPE PARA DOLLARS
TUNE OUT OF CONTROL STATE
BUREAUCRACY THAT HAS WILL LITTLE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
MEMBERS WE KNOW WHAT LOCAL WATER
AGENCIES BY AND LARGE ARE GOING
TO DO WITH THE MONEY THAT RATE
PAYERS GIVE THAT. WE DON'T HAVE
THAT SAME ASSURANCE WITH THE
STATE SIR FOR ALL THOSE REASONS
AGAIN WOULD ASK THAT YOU HOLD
THE ITEM OPEN AND UP. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VANESSA I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO AND
I'M HERE BECAUSE I WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO JUST FINALIZE
THESE PROBLEM YOU HAVE ON YOUR
HANDS. AND I'M SURE THAT PEOPLE
WILL BE AGREED TO PAT TO PAY
NINETY SEVEN CENTS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M ENORMOUSLY DISTRICT
PLUMAS HUNCHES OF ENGLAND THIS
PROP MAURY. CHARACTER OPINION IS
THE LEAD.
HE GET THEM IN THIS DROUGHT.
HI MY NAME IS LOUIS TANGISAN NAM
GUY I COME FROM THE COMMUNITY
STRATHMORE AND I ASKED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL OR DRINKS
WATER.
HI MY NAME IS RECONCILED JUST
IPHONE TO LEARN IT.
BOB PLEASE SUPPORT W. OR DRINKIN
MY WATER.
AND LASTLY ARE MY NAME IS DANIEL
JIMENEZ IE WORK FOR THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING MORE THAN ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
SEVEN A FOR THE DRINKING WATER.
AND AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AYE OR DRINK OF WATER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M JIM LINDBERGH ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU THANK.
TIME DAMMIT MELON NOW
REPRESENTING HELIX WATER
DISTRICT WE HAVE CONSIDERED A
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CONSTITUENTS.
IN SAN DIEGO YOU OF CERTAIN
SERVER WATER TO ALCOHOL IN THE
MAY SO SPRING VALLEY AND LEMON
GROVE.
WE CERTAINLY HAS EVERYBODY
SUPPORTS THE CONCEPT OF THE
AFFORDABLE SAFE
WATER THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT. IT'S AFFORDABILITY AND UP
AGAIN WE WOULD REMIND YOU THAT
THIS IS A RECESSED OF.
RECESSIVE TAX IN THAT IT IS A
FIXED AMOUNT OF PER UNIT.
AND.
WE WOULD SUPPORT THE BILL BUT
WITH AMENDMENTS AS PRESENTED BY
OUR.
HI MY NAME IS JULIETT CHRISTIANS
MET THEM WITH THE WATER
FOUNDATION. A PUBLIC AFFLUENT
PHILANTHROPIC ORGANIZATION I
WANTED TO START BY THANKING THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE STATE
WATER BOARD FOR ON TAKING ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE PLAIN WATER
REAL. THEY ARE AFRAID OF THE
WATER THAT'S COMING OUT OF THEIR
TOP AND THAT'S WHY PHILANTHROPY
IS INVOLVED.
FOR FAR TOO LONG WE'VE BEEN
RELYING ON GENERAL OBLIGATION
BONDS AND THE GENERAL FUND IT
HAS NOT WORKED.
SO LET'S JUST BE CLEAR.
PEOPLE WHO ARE ASKING FOR
ALTERNATIVES
AND COMING UP WITH ALTERNATIVE
VAGUE SOLUTIONS THEY'RE ASKING
FOR MORE OF THE SAME.
IT IT'S TIME FOR US TO FIND A
REAL SOLUTION AND THIS IS THE
SOLUTION THE HOUSE SUPPORT.
HUNDRED OVER A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS AND A MILLION
RESIDENTS WITHOUT ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER INCLUDE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MARK
GRACE AGAIN I'M ELECTED OFFICIAL
FROM HE LOOKS WATER DISTRICT
DOWN IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU TO OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE WHAT WHILE WE AGREE
WITH THE INTENT OF IT. THE
TAXATION AND COLLECTION
MECHANISM THAT'S INVOLVED WITH
IT WOULD. PUT AN UNDUE BURDEN ON
SOME OF THE SMALLER WATER
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO ON LESS AMENDED WE WOULD ASK
YOU TO OPPOSE IT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME AS HEIDI
SENSITIVE AND I AM PUBLISHED A
COUNTY I LIVE IN DAHLE HI. I'M
HERE TO SAY THAT I AM ALSO A
REPORTER WITH THE A WATER
ISSUES.
AND I ASKED HIM PLEASE THROUGH.
TAKE THAT ACTION AND ALSO I
HAVE CONCERN OF CHILDREN CAN
CALL THE DRINKING WATER AND
LOVES SUMMERTIME BECOMING. SAW
ON WATER IT LIVE WHAT IS RIGHT.
AND ON THAT DAY THAT HAPPENED
BOTTOM. I WANTED TO SAY NOT ONLY
THE HUMAN THEY WATER BUT ALSO OF
THE AND I LOST ONE OF THE YEAH
DOT THOUGHT WE HAD ON.
AND THE WATER HAD LIKE ORDER OF
A ONE IN IT SO THAT I WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO THINK THE WATER AND
IF WE BOIL SO.
WATERS IN THE SERMON ON THE
COMMUNITY WERE HERE AND I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BEARS
AND SALMON SADA AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE KEEP RELIANCE. I
REPRESENT LOCALLY BASED WATER
KEEPERS WHO ADVOCATE FIRST HOME
WHILE OFFICIAL AND DRINKABLE
WATER IS FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES IN ECOSYSTEMS AND AS
TODAY'S HEARING HAS UNDERSCORED.
FAR TOO MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER WE ARE NOT CLOSE ENOUGH TO
ACHIEVING THE HUMAN RIGHTS WATER
FOR ALL.
WE SUPPORT FUNDING FOR CLEAN
DRINKING WATER WHERE POLLUTERS%
PAY WE'RE OPPOSED TO A SAFE
HARBOR THAT WOULD SHIELDS. I
DISCHARGERS FROM LIABILITY.
I JUST WANNA AT BRIEFLY ECHO
STOPS COMMENTS ON THE LA JOH
ANALYSIS THE GOAL OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS VERY MUCH NEEDED IN
PRINCIPLES.
HOWEVER BY INDEMNIFY IN VARIOUS
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS AS LONG
AS THEY MEET CERTAIN MEDICATION
REQUIREMENTS.
IT ASSUMES THAT NITRATE
CONTAMINATION IS A PROBLEM OF
THE PAST.
IT IS NOT.
OF THIS GAME COULD PERPETUATE
RATHER THAN MITIGATE POLLUTING
PRACTICES AND CREATE PRECEDENT
FOR REGULATED ENTITIES TO
NEGOTIATE PAYMENT. IN LIEU OF
MEETING THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER
CLEAN WATER LAWS.
THESE CONSIDERABLE AND LONG
LASTING POLICY IMPLICATIONS HAVE
NOT YET BEEN FULLY VETTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
BILL THE POLICY IS YET TO BE
HEARD IN THE SENATE. I ASK YOU
TO EITHER REMOVE THE SAFE HARBOR
PROVISION OF THE TRAILER BILL
AND PASSED THE OTHER ELEMENTS.
IF THAT HAPPENED WE WOULD BE
PLEASED AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
A TRAILER BILL AND SENATE BILL
SIX TWENTY THREE. OTHERWISE.
PLEASE REMOVE THE SECTION
ENTIRETY FROM THE BUDGET AND
SEND IT BACK TO POLICY COMMITTEE
WHERE IT BELONGS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DON MAC AND HELEN
FROM HILLS BERGEN WITH RUSSIAN
RIVER KEEPER I WORK EVERYDAY TO
PROTECT CLEAN WATER TO AVOID THE
KIND OF TRAGEDIES YOU'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT. WE BEND IN
SUPPORT OF HUMAN RIGHT FOR WATER
SINCE WE STARTED OUR
ORGANIZATION TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO. AND I'M HERE TODAY TO.
SUPPORT THE THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL TO BRING CLEAN DRINKING
WATER TO THESE LONG SUFFERING
PEOPLE.
WHO ARE RESIDENTS OF OUR STATE?
BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S CURRENTLY
WRITTEN I HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE WE ARE OPENING THE
DOOR TO CONTINUED AGRICULTURAL
POLLUTION WITH NO ENFORCEMENT.
WE BIND THE HANDS OF THE STATE
WATER BOARD WE'RE GONNA HAVE
MANY MORE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WITHOUT CLEAN WATER AND GROW THE
PROBLEM SO. PLEASE LET'S FILL
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL AND GET
PEOPLE CLEAN WATER BUT LET'S DO
IT WITHOUT LETTING THE POLLUTERS
OFF THE HOOK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ONE THAT THEY SAW WELL LOOK
THERE MIGHT BE NOTHING POLITICAL
ABOUT IT MY THAT I. ELITES VETO
THAT FIVE ARCHETYPAL NAM SO MY
MOMENT FOR US ON. BUT ACT A.
DUMPED ON NINOS GALLION
FEDERALIST THOUGH MY WORK DAY
AND THE MOTHER CALIFORNIA.
PHONE LINES THIS WITH MY MOM IT
GOT US ON GRASS AND.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WELL
BUT ONE SALAS A MARTINEZ A. N. I
ASK YOU TO PLEASE PUT YOUR HAND
IN YOUR HEART FOR ALL THE
CHILDREN FOR OUR CHILDREN AND SO
UP PLEASE KEEP THAT IN MIND.
HI MY NAME IS ON THIRTY BUT THE
SET UP IN MY LIVE IN LIVINGSTON
AND I AM PART OF THE FIGHT IN
THE BALLOT ORGANS TO. SAY SHOULD
NONPROFIT AND I JUST.
SUPPORTER THAT SIX THIRTY THREE
BECAUSE IT'S.
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE KILLING US
AND ALSO IS THIS.
THIS IS A NEGATIVE CAN'T FOR YOU
GUYS BECAUSE.
BECAUSE UNDER SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT THE.
THE BASED OPPOSE THE FRUIT NOW
THEY'RE KILLING US.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS COMEY
LET CHVEZ I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THAT THE LOTUS WORTH
A FOUNDATION WE HAVE A
COMMITTEES FROM KERN TO IN KERN
TULARE AND FRESNO CLOVIS SEEN
ALSO NEED THOSE UNITED
NEIGHBORS.
ON BEHALF OF A SINGLE SONY THOSE
AND THAT THE LOTUS WHAT THE
FOUNDATION WE EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. CLEAN AND
AFFORDABLE WATER FOR ALL THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TING VALDERRAMA
WITH THE WHITEMAN GROUP ON
BEHALF OF NEXT GENOM ERICA AND
SEIU STATE COUNCIL.
CLEAN WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT
WE'RE PROUD TO STAND WITH OVER
ONE HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS OF
SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF THE ONLY
REAL SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM.
WE WANT TO THANK GOVERNOR BROWN
IN THE STATE WATER BOARD FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP THANK YOU.
I GET AFTERNOON GLENN FOR ALL
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY.
DO EARLY IN THE HEARING CHAIR
MARCUS SAID ROLE IN THIS
TOGETHER WE. COMPLETELY AGREE
AND YOU'VE JUST HEARD FROM
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHO AGREE
THAT WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER
THERE'S A NEED. THERE'S A GAP.
THE OUR OPPOSITION THE
FOUNDATION OF OPPOSITION IN THE
FOUNDATION OPPOSITION FROM
ANYTHING YOU'VE HEARD FROM IS
THE SOURCE OF FUNDING. HERE'S
SOME CREATIVE ALTERNATIVES OUT
THERE THEY'RE NOT FAKE
ALTERNATIVE THEIR REAL
ALTERNATIVES. MISTREATED BUSH
MAPA TALK ABOUT ENDOWMENT OUR
TRUST FUND OR HEARD THAT HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS TALK ABOUT CAP
AND TRADE YOUR SOME FUNDS
AVAILABLE. TO DO SOMETHING
MEANINGFUL HERE ON A SUSTAINABLE
BASIS THAT'S NOT SUBJECT TO THE
UPS AND DOWNS OF SWINGS IN
CYCLES OF THE GENERAL FUND.
WE'RE READY TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES AND WORK ON THOSE WITH
YOU AND WITH ALL THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND UNTIL THEN
WE'RE OUT WE APPRECIATE
OPPOSITION TO THE US THANKS.
I'M JUST GONNA HELP
KERRY.
I MY NAME'S AND LEFT HIM.
THEY SAID A.
.
I LEVEL FRESNO.
IT'S GOOD GRIEF LOOK CLEAN WIDER
OR ELSE YOU'LL GET TAKE
EVERYTHING DEADLINE.
YOU CAN.
Q. ALEXA.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ADAM ROBIN WITH THE REGIONAL
WATER AUTHORITY WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS MEASURE ASSOCIATE OUR.
REMARKS BETHEA COMMENTS FROM
THIS RARE BUSH IN THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES THANK YOU.
HI AROUND TO ROSSI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION WE'RE ALSO POST MUST
AMENDED AND. WE ASSOCIATE OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF AQUA
THANK YOU.
WHEN THE STATUS OF BOTH. NUMBER
MEDI OUT OF OF THE GOAT ANGLE
THE FRIEND BUT AFTERNOON IN MY
OUT OF THE BIGGEST FOR FRESNO.
IT'S THE YANKEE BACK UP WHERE
YOU LEFT UP REQUEST THAT I'M
HERE TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. ORGANIZED WHOSE TOOK YOU
KNOW THAT ASSIST FELLOW MEDICAL
THING UNLESS YOU. THINK
IMPORTANT WHEN THUNDERSTORMS IN
THE THAT WAS WITH YOU
BECAUSE IT'S NOT FAIR THAT IN
ONE OF THE RICHEST STATE IN THE
NATION WE CONTINUE TO SUFFER
BECAUSE OF CONTAMINATED WATER.
WHEN I THOUGHT THAT THE LOOK
MINIMUM THE LETTUCE MANGO THE
FOOD IN THE CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE
TO NEWMAN IS MUCH THE LATEST
FROM FRESNO.
OF THE MEN ABOUT UP KEPT GOING
UP REPLACE THE.
NOT MUCH BUT ENOUGH OLD LOOKING
ABOUT THE APPLE LA NACION GIFT
OF METHODIC PALACE ROTH IF.
I I COME HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT NOT ONLY FOR ALL OF US
FOR THE WHOLE NATION AFFECTED BY
THIS ISSUE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CLAIMS GREG MORRISON
HERE ON BEHALF OF ALL SERVE ONLY
A SMALL WATER DISTRICT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND ALONG
WITH THE. POINTS ARTICULATED BY
MISTER FARRELL FROM SENATE
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY IN THIS
RARE BOOKS FROM AQUA WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL AT THIS POINT WE.
FULLY SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL BUT THE FUNDING MECHANISM
IS WHAT WERE ULTIMATELY OPPOSED
TO THANK YOU.
SARS DIVERSE FOR THE LAS
VIRGENES WATER DISTRICT IN THIS
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
OPPOSE TAXING OTHER WATER
DISTRICTS AND RELATED THE
PROBLEM BUT NOT OPPOSED TO THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON LAURIE JOHNSON
BEHALF OF THE MONTEREY PENINSULA
WATER MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN THE
CITY OF WATSONVILLE.
IN OPPOSITION AND REITERATE
AQUA'S SENTIMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER CLARY
CLEAN WATER ACTION IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BUDGET.
ITEM ALSO ON BEHALF OF PLANNING
AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE ME FEEL
FAMILIAR VOTE OUR COMPANY LEGAL
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND MARVIN
COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT. I
JUST WANT TO SAY I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND FUNDING
OPTIONS FOR FIFTEEN YEARS NOW
JUST HOW MY ANNIVERSARY LAST
MONTH. AND GUESS WHAT WE SAT
DOWN WITH AQUA FIVE YEARS AGO WE
HAD THIS WHOLE BIG STAKEHOLDER
GROUP WE HAVE THE WATER FOR THE
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND. AND
AGAIN WATER DISTRICTS IN
AUCKLAND EACH A COMMUNITIES AND
WE ALL SAT DOWN AND SAID WELL WE
NEED ANOTHER EVERYONE AGREED WE
NEEDED A FUNDING SOURCE OTHER
THAN BONDS. AND THE S. R. F.
WHICH IS BEEN GOING ON FOREVER
IN THE GENERAL FUND WE COULDN'T
AGREE ON THAT FUNDING SOURCE BUT
SINCE THEN WE AGREE TO REGULATE
THE HELL OUT AGRICULTURE AND
THEY AGREED TO PAY US MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A YEAR. AND NOW WE
WANT WATER AGENCIES TO STEP UP
AS WELL WE DON'T NEED TO ROLL UP
OUR SLEEVES AGAIN I DON'T WANT
TO DO ANOTHER STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS. I JUST WANNA GET IT
DONE I KNOW THIS IS SUPER HARD
SO LET'S JUST DO IT THANKS.
BERLIN DOT ORG ON THIS WITH THE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR PAULA ARE
FOR. JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
I JUST LIKE TO.
EXPRESS MY FULL WHOLEHEARTED
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FIND IN IN JUST A COUPLE
POINTS AND ABOUT TWENTY SECONDS
OR SO. SO IF YOU'LL BEAR WITH ME
AND.
THE FEE THAT WATER FEE IS AT BY
JUST A TALKING POINT FROM THE
OPPOSITION THE FEE IS NINETY
FIVE CENTS. PER HOUSEHOLD.
ABOVE ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND HOUSEHOLDS ARE EXEMPT.
AND THIS IS NOT INCLUDE THE OVER
NINETY FIVE CENTS DIET LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY SPACE WITH HIGH
MEDICAL BILLS BUYING PERSONAL
WATER AS WELL AND SO THE COST IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY SHIFTED ONTO
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS ALREADY.
AND THE EXISTING SOURCES OF
FUNDING AND DO NOT GO FAR WE'RE
WORKING WITH PROP ONE AND
FUNDING TO GET SEPTIC AND TO
SEWER CONVERSIONS WORKING WITH
PROP ONE FUNDING THE CLEAN WATER
STATE REVOLVING FUND. EVERY TIME
FUND SOURCE THAT WE CAN GET OUR
HANDS ON AND YET THAT STILL DOES
NOT ADDRESS THE AT THAT THE HOPE
BIG MAGNITUDE OF SCALE.
WE NEED SOMETHING STABLE AND AS
FAR AS ADDRESSING PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FINE
DOES HAVE ANNUAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS AND IS VERY
TRANSPARENT I'M. TRANSPARENT IN
BROWN PROVIDING PUBLIC AND
MEETINGS AND PUBLIC INFORMATION
REGARDING THIS ENTIRE PROCESS AS
WELL.
SO IN REGARDS TO JUST
ACCOUNTABILITY THEY IT'S THE
BILL IS STRICTLY DESIGNED FOR
COUNT ABILITY AS WELL TO. AND SO
THE COMMUNITIES DEMAND IT WHERE
WHERE ON THE FRONT LINES WORKING
WITH THESE COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
AGAIN DISPROPORTIONATE.
.
AB AND VULNERABLE INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL TO SO THIS IS A NEED AND
THIS NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT HARD SUPPORT AND
OFFER OUR RESOURCES AND.
AND EXPERTISE
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OUTSIDE OF THIS THIRTY SECONDS
THAT HAVE TAKEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SITTING OUT THAT
IRWIN IN REPRESENTING THE O. TIE
WATER DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
AYE WELL WE DO AGREE WITH THE
INTENT OF THE BILL WE ARE
OPPOSING THE BILL TO BE AMENDED.
THE NINETY FIVE CENTS
I ADDITIONAL CHARGE TO OUR RATE
PAYERS.
IS.
I THINK AN UNFAIR ADVANTAGE FOR
OUR REPAIRS WHEN ADDITIONAL OUT
OF THE WATER RATES ARE ALREADY
GOING UP.
AS I SAID WE DO. AGREE WITH THE
INTENT OF THE BILL BUT WE FELT
LIKE THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THROUGH
GENERAL FUNDS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SAAD GUSTAVO
KUERTEN IS AND I HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS AND MADERA COUNTY AND
FRESNO.
THERE FARMWORKERS AND WHAT I'M
CONCERNED NOW I SEE.
THAT THERE'S BEEN POLITICIZED
YOU KNOW WE'RE SEEING TO TWO
SIDES OF THE COIN HERE IN.
AND I SEE THAT THERE'S A BIG
PROBLEM HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EMERGENCY PROBLEM WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW TAXING HERE TAXING
THEY'RE TAKING FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TAKE TAKEN FROM OVER HERE I
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT WORKS.
MY PROBLEM IS THAT THERE'S A BIG
CONCERN HAS BEEN GOING ON LIKE
MATT THE GENTLEMAN SAID BIT DE
YEARS.
I FAMILY MEMBERS THAT HAD CANCER
THROUGH THIS.
NOW THIS IS A PROBLEM.
HUGE PROBLEM
AND I HOPE YOU GUYS UNDERSTAND
HOW THE. BIGGEST PROBLEM IS AND
ALSO SEE THIS IT'S TARGETING
FRESNO COUNTY TULARE COUNTY IN
ALL THESE COUNTIES WHERE THE
FARMWORKERS ARE AT.
FARMWORKERS
OKAY DEFECTING NAM BUT THEY
DON'T WANT TO ADDRESS THAT
RIGHT.
IS THERE HIDDEN.
PEOPLE ARE.
NOBODY REPRESENTS THEM.
WE GOT TO STAND UP FOR PEOPLE.
THEY'RE NOT BEING REPRESENTED I
MEAN I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT WE SIT
HERE AND WE TALK ABOUT GETTING
TAXED EUROPEAN TAXER. THERE'S
PEOPLE DYING.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE DON'T EVEN KNOW THIS SOME
OF US ARE SIT THERE WE PICK OKAY
WE REPRESENT DISCOUNTING WHAT
ABOUT THE COUNTIES ARE NOT BEING
REPRESENTED.
EVERITT BEING REPRESENTED BY THE
FARMWORKERS INSTEAD OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING FOR THE
FARM WORKERS.
MISTER RICHARD BLOOM.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
NOW I THINK WE SHOULD LOOK AT
THAT.
ON A DIFFERENT ANGLE INSTEAD OF
LOOKING AT WHO'S GETTING TAXING
WHO'S WHO'S NOT BENEFITING FROM
THIS.
I THINK THE GENERAL POPULATION
OF THIS.
STATE NEEDS TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND EIGHTY ADDRESS IT
SOON.
OTHERWISE ARE GONNA BE PEOPLE
LIKE ME. COME UP THE CAPITAL.
AND MAKING THESE BIG
DEMONSTRATIONS.
FIGHTING FOR THESE CAUSES.
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT BEING
REPRESENTED.
YOU KNOW I AM IT HURTS ME
BECAUSE.
I CAN SPEAK BEHALF OF THEM
MY PARENTS COME FROM THAT
THEY COME FROM FARMWORKERS.
AND IT HURTS ME WHEN I SEE THESE
LITTLE KIDS COME THROUGH HERE AT
THE OLDER MAN. AND YOU AND THEIR
BUDDIES TALK ABOUT TAXING
THEY'RE TALKING TO ANOTHER TAKEN
FROM A GENERAL FUND.
COME ON THIS IS ABOUT AN
EMERGENCY PROBLEM.
THANK GOD YEAH THANK GOD THE
GOVERNOR DID SOMETHING BECAUSE
HE COULDN'T RELATE.
NOW I DON'T KNOW SOME OF THESE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATE
MEMBERS.
SOME OF THEM WON'T RELATE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T THEY'RE NOT
NOT COUNTY.
OR THAT DISTRICT.
SO I HOPE I HOPE YOU GUYS DO
SUPPAN OTHERWISE IT'S IT'S GONNA
GO THE MEDIA THE MEDIA'S ALREADY
ADDRESSING THE TELEPHONES RATE
PRESSES BIG BEHALF OF THIS
MEETING.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS TO YOUR
DISTRICT.
IS LATINO VOTERS COMING OUT.
IT'S GOING TO YOUR DISTRICT.
THE VOTE TO COUNT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THAT.
CLOSES OUT
THE OF PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
OUR HEARING AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE. OF FOR
PARTICIPATING.
MS MARCUS I NOTICED THAT YOU
WERE ASSIDUOUSLY TAKING NOTES
SAID DURING THE COURSE OF THE
HEARING AND TO A AS YOU.
COMPLETE YOUR REVIEW OF THE
COMMENTS THAT YOU HEARD TODAY
AND PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO WERE
IN. OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSAL
IF YOU COULD TO HELP PROVIDE A
REPORTER DOES THE SOME KIND OF
SENT.
A RESPONSE. TO MYSELF IN THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I
THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
US AND OUR CONSIDERATION AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD.
BEFORE WE CLOSE OUT TODAY ONE AT
A MISS MARCUS SAID JUST CALL TO
YOUR ATTENTION A LETTER THAT I
RECEIVED DATA THAT YOU MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE A COPY OF IT FROM
US. ZONE SEPARATE TOPIC. FROM A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AND
SENATOR DODD RELATING TO THE
MALLARD FIRMS CONSERVATION
BANQUET SOME. ISSUES THAT
APPARENTLY HAD THEY'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT A MAKE SURE YOU GET A COPY
OF THAT BUT I WANT TO CALL TO
YOUR ATTENTION JUST CAME INTO MY
OFFICE.
SO THAT BRINGS US TO THE
CONCLUSION OF OUR HEARING THIS
MORNING THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND ATTENTION AND SO
WILL BE BACK AGAIN NEXT WEEK
RIGHT.
NEXT WEDNESDAY THANK YOU ALL